public service by your cable or
satellite provider
and up next on book tv on c-span 2
investigative journalist seymour hirsch
talks about his newest book it's called
the killing of osama bin laden he
challenges some of the facts presented
by the obama administration and others
about bin laden's capture and death
so
let's start by talking about
osama bin laden who's plays the title
role in your book which is called the
killing of osama bin laden
you challenge virtually every detail
of the story both the official narrative
and the media reports
can you start by summarizing sort of
briefly what you what you found in this
piece well basically
the the one one reality is the president
did authorize the
execution if you will of osama bin laden
and the seals did carry it out and
that's a fact and that's absolutely
correct and it was done in a badabat
which was a resort town
about 50 or 60 miles uh up up uphill
from from islamabad the capital and it's
a place that in the summer
islamabad if you've been there in
summers it gets to 120. and so it's a
it's i call it the martha's vineyard of
islamabad it's of pakistan where the
rich
and the the generals and the the senior
bureaucrats go and they have summer
houses it's sort of an upscale area
that all happened after that it's sort
of what i describe as a lewis carroll
story
because
um the white house said this was all
done he was he had gone there uh he'd um
last time we heard about bin laden we
were looking for him in the mountains
the torabor area uh between pakistan and
afghanistan the hindu cushman sort of a
wild man no man's land we were looking
for him we couldn't find him
um this was late 0-1 0-2 we went on to
bomb and attack iraq and and and moved
away
we're still in this war that 15 years
now bob and you know how we doing in
that war but no that's another question
and so
give it another 15 years oh my god
um um
uh yes there's no end it seems a win
because we're doing the same policy my
argument basically in the book
in the essays in the book most of them
were written for the london review books
all of them were and not that well known
here um uh his argument that is that
that osama bin you know that that the
present united states the baraka barak
followed the cheney bush policy much too
much much more than we really want to
know anyway the story is that the white
house story is that
oh my god we we had wonderful couriers
we had people in the basement of the uh
cia were tracking couriers and bin laden
once he left
uh tora bora why he was active he was an
and he was the energetic runner and he
was sending messages and directing
traffic for al qaeda i guess worldwide
that's sort of the implication never
quite said that and um then the couriers
with amazing skill uh
and with the use of torture
waterboarding if anybody's seen the
movie that was generated out of this
zero dark 30 i think it's called i just
see it it begins with the torture
enhanced interrogation waterboarding and
we got the evidence we wanted we got bin
laden and then we didn't tell the
pakistanis and we went in by ourselves
two choppers uh could evade the radar of
pakistan and went in and did the mission
killed the guy and um the guy in the
initial story he had an ak-47 when they
confronted him bin laden and in order to
protect themselves the seals had to
shoot them they're in in in a in a room
in on a compound there and then we we
fled out and uh we had a copper we had a
chopper that was uh blew up it was an
accident it crash-landed and uh uh since
the blackhawks the chopper in which the
two the twenty two two two
two squads actually four squads of six
says
uh this navy seals even though they
haven't been on water in years uh they
still uh move in groups of sticks which
that's how many fit into a dinghy sort
of a nice touch because
the the seals have gone crazy with the
fact that they don't go they go
they're not going into the water anymore
and many of them leave
because that's just not what they were
trained to do not just run on the ground
and kill people but anyway the seals
went in and and had to kill him i took
that took the body out and flew back
meanwhile a rescue chopper came in which
was a two engine a twin engine a chopper
i've forgotten the name of it it's a
uh carries 55 passengers it travels
about 110 maybe 130 miles an hour
at most and with they they took that out
along with the blackhawk because they
didn't have enough room in the one
blackhawk and they flew out that way
without being detected by the radar
that's the story
and the american press went gung-ho for
it uh it was a great night when the
president announced we've got him that
was the words you know basically he's he
was killed and
the war on terror is over and americans
march in the streets and i celebrated it
too was very happy to see him dead
although i knew
this guy had been out of business for 10
years this isn't going to end the war
but
in the next week or so the american
press they it's what happens when you
get a story like this the white house
controlled the narrative uh they're
begging for briefings everybody wants an
exclusive
and they're dealing out facts they had a
recant after a little while that he
didn't have an ak-47 then they went to
he had two women with weapons protecting
him and then they had to back off that
and uh there was a fire fight huge
firefight a lot of people were shot up
and killed they haven't really backed
off that but that sort of diminished and
if you remember his wives
and children were were were taken away
and we're gonna we're gonna interrogate
them that never happened they were flown
out by the pakistani intelligence
service a few a month or so later back
to saudi arabia all these stories sort
of
disintegrated over the next couple of
weeks but nobody paid attention we were
still the press was still tell us more
and i remember my favorite story was the
one about
one of the seals that brought a dog in
on the mission and they described how
the president met the dog and and one of
the stories was that uh
when the chopper crashed they had to
blow it up and you know big explosion
and if people came neighbors came in
this very sort of elegant area of
pakistan a resort area if people came to
wonder what's going on the dog was put
outside to tell them you know to stay
away and i remember thinking oh my god
we've got a dog that barks in urdu which
is the local nature an urdu barking dog
so there was no story that wouldn't go
the fire department in this area which
is very skilled the police department
which was very skilled did not show up
at all
even though the time of the mission
which was supposed to be 20 minutes
ended up being 40 because
the the seals had to fly in a rescue
chopper that was also parked in pakistan
with again without the i the pakistani
knowledge
and so
it's such a bad story let me just tell
you a few things
and one of my my one of my complaints
chronically
you know when i speak to journalism
schools and i speak actually more in
europe on investigative journalism than
here these days but but still the annual
meetings of the ire investigative
reporting group i speak to a lot of
schools
the first thing i always say is you have
to read before you write
you've got to read and so one of the
things you need to do is take a look at
the radar system that pakistan had
and i'll just take a second to tell you
what the rate how it began
we know
that bin laden worked for us
in in the in the early 80s when we
decided uh jimmy carter and brzezinski
decided we were going to drive the
russians we're going to have a proxy war
with the russians in afghanistan and
jordan for short and freud the russians
were stuck as we thought we had been in
vietnam and we were going to go and we
used bin laden and other fundamentalists
to help fight a war and win the war
and we also brought in we began paying a
lot of money to the pakistani
intelligence service which is known as
the isi
and now it's become one of the great
tough services of all time uh the
pakistani isi is like the egyptian
military they have great investments
they own things they buy property in
australia they're building a huge
housing and business complex in
islamabad they're big they're tough
they're very skilled we all know that we
brought them in to help us
fight the taliban and the
other groups inside afghanistan help us
win the war against the russians and
what happened then is
the pakistan is very
wisely the one thing that happened is
when the isi got in um when to go back
as you know there's a long enmity
between india and pakistan two oil
colonies of the brits that split up
and
when when the russians began to move
into pakistan the indians moved in they
set up not only they had an embassy but
they set up consulates when the isi
began the fight on our side one of the
things they did what i'm telling you now
was reported impressed you could find it
in news clips
um um they invaded some of the
consulates and began killing pakistani
diplomats and even hanging some you know
that kind of entity exists well then in
the early by 85 or so when they were
active in all the anti-indian and all
the stuff for us inside afghanistan
helping us beat the russians and drive
them out
at that point
the indians had nuclear weapons and
could deliver them pakistan had a
reactor going a place called kahuta
enriching uranium but they weren't able
to weaponize yet so what did they what
did they do they said help us
and so what did we do
we put up money over eight or ten years
to build
a a very sophisticated 3d audible which
means you can't erase a signal
a system i think raytheon was the main
contractor when i looked at it was over
900 million bucks we built a great radar
system for them and between islamabad
and delhi there's one flight one or two
flights of weeks now and it's about an
hour flight 350 miles or so
and so my god
all you had to do is look up the kind of
radar system they had and you knew this
story that they the story the basic
story that our two blackhawk helicopters
could evade radar was a ludicrous just
ludicrous so you start from there and i
began looking at all the different so
what so what you said what you said in
your article and in which is in the book
let me just
sort of
suggest some things is that it wasn't
brilliant intelligence that discovered
where bin laden was
but it was a walk-in it was a tip from a
pakistani officer
that
we took that to the pakistanis and said
now we know where he is so either you
cooperate or else they did they cleared
the decks
for the whole us operation we we moved
into pakistan
knowing that they were basically
standing down
in and around the compound and in the
skies of pakistan
there was no fire fight as the
administration said it was really just
one old guy who was
not just shot once or twice but as you
say obliterated by by the fire
they even allowed us to set up you
report a command center
in a nearby pakistani facility to guide
the whole operation
so this was really a a complete myth
essentially that was created by the
administration
uh in order to
protect pakistan i guess from the
consequences among other things
um is that about right or is that a
perfect summary um the the the man that
walked in i was
i can be less coy about him now because
the pakistanis obviously know who he is
he was a pakistani colonel and not in
the isi but in military intelligence
army intelligence who was disaffected
and there was 25 million on the table we
offered that much money for information
about pakistan he did come in 2010
and to show you how sort of naive i am
um he um
i made a point of early in the piece of
writing that he went directly to our
station chief a very competent guy named
jonathan bank
um
uh who and what i did in the article is
i wrote that bank was there because bank
had been mentioned earlier particularly
in the urdu press um because there had
been a flap involving
the cia and we had to move him out of
the country early and it was so his name
was mentioned you know it's against the
law to write the name of a covert
operator it's a theoretical they haven't
really tried to push that law but it is
a law but even mentioned
so i mentioned him by name uh for the
simple reason that i thought
um the way you could really go after me
in this story there was a long story
it's ten thousand words and it was
checked very carefully by the land just
as carefully as when i worked for stuff
for the new yorker they in fact they the
london review hired some of my better
new yorker checkers who did the checking
and took weeks of this stuff you know it
cost a lot of money to do this right
which the new yorker is famous for doing
in any case i thought by leaving his
name in there
i knew i was going to jeopardize him
because there are many people in the
government immediately think because
he's named he was the source but he
wasn't in any case i thought
the way i could really be hurt on this
story i knew there'd be attacks by the
white house is if
john they somehow could convince john
banks who are bank who i knew had a
reputation for being honest to go public
three or four days after my story which
attracted enormous attention as we all
knew it would
and go public and say walken hirsch i
don't know what he's talking about he
said nothing and i thought the press
would appreciate
the dog that didn't bark is really
important but they didn't they were too
busy chasing the white house briefings
to really pay attention to the fact that
who wasn't talking about it the one guy
that was directly involved well and so
let me certainly you certainly had
yeah go ahead well the the other point
is
that of course the underlying point here
the critical point is when all of this
was being planned when we confronted the
pakistanis uh we were enraged them for
and of course their answer to
the whole point was they they were going
to look the other way we were going to
go take them out
we had to take the body out and we were
not going to talk about it not for a
week or 10 days and was all agreed the
president then would announce we had a
drone raid we do it all the time in the
hindu kush mountains on the pakistani
and not on the pack on the afghan side
making clear it was on the afghan side
and we hid a house a wooden house with a
hellfire missile and we did a
after-action look and we found the long
tall guy there
bin laden 6'4 or something like that and
we did dna and my god we got him and
that would have been just as good but
that night and i remember this vividly
because it was a sunday night here in
washington
and
by 7 38 there were reports all over the
media that the president has a special
announcement to make and by 10 o'clock
there were stories that might do it
might have to do with bin laden but he
didn't go public until i'm almost three
hours after the first word and what was
going on was a fight
because
there was pressure on him political
pressure from the political advisers not
to wait the seven or ten days
they were very angry at robert gates the
republican secretary of defense whom
gates had if you remember uh gates had
been reappointed or allowed to stay by
um
uh uh he'd been appointed he replaced
rumsfeld by by george bush and he was
very close to the bush family gates was
and when obama came in he reappointed
him but two and a half years later there
was tension inside a republican doing
things and gates was very much against
some of the things that happened in the
operation he thought we just should bomb
the place and let it go and not
jeopardize the seals because if
something had gone wrong and they've
been captured they would be accused of
they were they had no protection they
were they were basically committing a
war crime
and he was a prisoner of wars with the
point and they executed a prisoner of
war um and they went into a country with
without any notice to the authorities
that's theoretically what happened so
anyway
here's what the issue was for gates
basically and and and for me as a
journalist
what's so important about pakistan why
do we have spend so much time cozying it
up to the generals who run it it's
because they control more right now when
i wrote about it in the new yorker in
2009 it was more than 100 nuclear
weapons and we worry about their weapons
we worry about their safety there's a
huge muslim fundamental prop
fundamentalist population in pakistan
and in fact the reason that the
pakistanis had never indic said anything
publicly about having him
since 0-6 is when they walk in told us
that he came in
isi found him an 06 according to the
walk-in which may or may not be correct
it could be earlier i think it might be
but in any case that's what they walk in
told us
the pakistanis
kept them secretly because the public
would go nuts they the publics that
loved bin laden many elements of the
public
50 percent 40 of the country uh
saw him as a hero
and so as long as they had bin laden
they could privately tell the al-qaeda
groups and the taliban groups in both
pakistan and afghanistan we got your guy
pay more attention to us keep us
informed they had more control that was
the argument the second argument they
made explanation for keeping him is the
saudis paid him a lot of money
the saudi arabian
government you know he's a saudi he came
from a he came from an elegant a very
wealthy family bin laden family in saudi
arabia big construction family not royal
family but they were major
constructionists
in building building and very wealthy
and the assumption we make and i make is
that nobody wanted an american
interrogation team to talk to him so the
whole deal once the pakistani leadership
a general name pasha who ran the isa and
the general named kyani and my god what
we did for them you want a new armored
car yeah you want a helicopter yeah
gianni love golf you want to go play
golf with jack nicholson jack nicklaus
in in
in ohio why we'll fix it up we did that
stuff for them because we wanted them to
trust us
enough to let us know where the bombs
were and it was a cat and mouse game
going on of course we didn't tell them
what we planned and they didn't tell us
everything too
the word in the intelligence community
our fear was that some of the bombs that
they were telling us about you know
where they were in igloos or under the
ground uh where some of the bombs
actually were hidden in the tall grass
along the runway out of the count they
always kept a few there was this natural
natural suspicion so this is what's on
the table so that night when the
president decides to violate the
agreement
he's really jeopardizing a relationship
that i will tell you until today
has not been fully resolved there's
still bitterness in the among the
pakistani leadership about being hung
out to dry
well if they were if they were holding
captive
and public enemy number one
and not only holding him captive but
protecting him and using him to their
advantage they they obviously have a lot
to
answer for um your story
in the book and in the london review has
been disparaged by a lot of people but
there were also people like carlotta
gaul and some other folks uh steve kaul
uh nbc that confirmed details of what
you reported
um
are you surprised though psy that
there's been so
little follow-up in other words that so
few journalists since this piece first
came out have picked up one or another
piece of it and
and tried to confirm or disprove what
you wrote are you con well you know are
you concerned or surprised by that when
i was at the new york times for seven
eight nine years i was there sort of hot
shot lead investigative reporter i won a
lot of prizes you know writing about
watergate writing about vietnam and the
cia in chile and all that stuff
kissinger's wiretapping and the domestic
wire domestic spying by the ci that led
to the church series a lot of wonderful
stories and
if somebody at the times had said um
there's a great story that was published
by the la times he wants you to follow
it i would have said me i don't follow
other people's stories i do my own it's
a very [ __ ] business so for the really
good reporters the good investigative
reporters and the times and the posts et
cetera they don't want to follow someone
else's story um it's just a reality and
here's the thing that really got me
was
within a week of the story
there was a interview show with
i i don't embarrass anybody but there
was a senior reporter
for the washer foreign policy reporter
for the washington post one of those
reporters who doesn't like following
other stories and this reporter was
asked about my story
and
the reporter said
well
actually she said
we all sort of knew right away this is
within five or six days of the
publication of my story we all knew that
the pakistani military and intelligence
services had to know where he was it
didn't make sense that they did not that
part of the story doesn't work
and but yes
so what what was being said essentially
was oh we had that we you know that's
that's how you get rid of a story i used
to work for the ap covering the pentagon
in the 60s on the job training and
learning how to hate the vietnam war and
as a reporter for the ap if anybody
broke a good story they would call me
and wake me up at 11 30 at night
sometimes the new york desk or the
overseas desk can you match it and the
first thing i would do was call the
press secretary for robert mcnamara who
i concluded was a psychotic liar
after dealing with him i i really did i
thought he just was lying about
everything and didn't didn't even know
how much he was lying as he later sort
of talked about in a later arrow
a wonderful movie by a great movie maker
anyway
i would call up and say can i have your
denial so now to file a story and say
the pentagon denied today i'm telling
you it was that petty that's how [ __ ]
we are in the business but i was
you know it's funny you crossed the
water
this book came out in london too at the
same time as it did here and i was i
went for a few days to london and did a
couple of big events in it like you know
with one case with a senior editor of a
of a major newspaper there
and we had a there were a lot of people
there and we talked about the bid london
story and i turned tables on him after a
few minutes i asked him i said you guys
though pack you're closer you know as i
said it's a royal colony you guys go to
india and pakistan you have much more
ties you're much more sophisticated
about that part of the world than we are
we have all that water between us
and he said yes and i said so what did
you guys think he said i'm not
exaggerating he said well
we had meetings to be concluded right
away it was impossible for the pakistani
isi because you know how competent they
are not to know
that where he he was there because among
other things abadabad happens to be in
the center literally the center of not
only the secret base you mentioned about
you know you mentioned earlier a secret
base in which we worked with the
pakistani intelligence service and our
cia on covert ops also a base in which
the pakistanis train the guards for the
nuclear arsenal
two reactors pakistan now has a
plutonium reactor also in a ring about
it a major air base if you circle draw a
circle in the middle is a bada bot he
wasn't there by accident they parked him
in a place where they had total coverage
and also they made it clear the pack you
know it was clear in the earlier
reporting and you have to go back to the
first things that were said he had no
internet he had no electronic
communication he he was
he was completely isolated in fact our
our guys when we landed we were walked
into his prison uh by an isi official
and um if you remember in even in the
stories they told we had to blow two
steel doors
if there were two steel doors why was he
was a prisoner clearly a prisoner of war
or prisoner of what you want not a
prisoner of love but anyway
it just the more i got it so now there
have been
there's been a lot of criticism too
right of of the story not just
a lack of follow-up but
um i
booked out a few quotes i'm sure you
have heard them uh mark
bowden said
it's fake moon landing territory story
and
peter berger called it a farago of
nonsense the salon and politico and vox
weighed in
the washington post talked about
it being quote even too kind even kind
of crazy said that paul firey their
media guy so
what's this all about why was there so
much not just failure to follow up
but but this kind of of nastiness of you
know accusing you of being a conspiracy
monger well there are a couple of things
about what's that about
well i mean i've had this most of my
career with all most of my stories
there's been an enormous amount of
criticism
you know when i did the milai story when
not so much albugrave we had a document
there but i did the abergrave story yeah
but a lot of the stories if you look at
the original story i wrote
about the see domestic cia spying in the
new york times there was december late
december 2000 1974
my god the washington post for three
months was attacking me and saying that
wasn't right i was oh you know that that
there weren't files the ci wasn't
keeping files on americans et cetera et
cetera and all of that stuff eventually
you know people you know that's
uh you tell me you know i
i don't want to use i don't want to
describe what it's about i mean it's
pretty obvious in some cases what it is
because you know i've been doing this a
long time and writing stories that uh
often people
that should have been written by others
much earlier so part of it is that in
the case of mark i like mark bowden he
wrote black hawk down he were good
friends
and and you quote him in your book a
couple of times well i quote them
because
one
first you have to know something
in the cia
when you have a walk-in
that's mana you protect the walk-in and
so here you have in the basement of the
intelligence bureau there you have a
bunch of people
working on tracking couriers you want to
figure out where the couriers are
and
if you pay attention to the senate
intelligence committee which last year
if you remember i think early last year
they published a major report on on
terror and a torture if you remember
that report it was a six thousand page
report only 500 pages of which were
cleared but 500 pages were published and
if you read those
as i did
there was a section on couriers and it's
described how the white house the cia
was trying to attract couriers and got
nowhere couldn't do it just couldn't
make any sense of the couriers the names
that we have so many problems with an e
and an a in the name you know how they
they're spelled differently in the west
some of the muslim names and we it's
literally said impossible to track but
that's okay according to the cia
uh to the debrief not so much in the
initial statements and a day or two
later uh seeing his senior intelligence
officials even the head of the cia mr
brennan he was then i guess then the
white house was a counterterrorium
the deputy for counterterrorism uh
brennan john brennan later went to the
cia gave briefings in which they talked
about
um how we tracked up by couriers
and all got into this torture business
gates had fought bitterly against this
saying don't start lying about torture
because the cia is worried about the
fact there may be congressional hearings
and there may be legal findings about
what we did they the cia was killing
people in torture that happened very
much more than anybody knows
there was a lot of murder going on i
wasn't murdered they tortured people and
they they bled to death whatever and
in some cases there were murders and no
prosecutions of course in our grave
there was a a couple of cases where
nobody got punished for anything and so
you had that issue you were trying to
justify using the couriers and the
problem was
um that um
in order for him to be using couriers
you had to go all you had to contradict
the earlier stories about this guy who
was isolated at one point they talked
about him sitting around watching video
porno he was briefed they showed a
picture of this old man hunched over
watching pornography it was said you
could say anything you wanted in the
first few days everything was down was
taken so that element
um the couriers was and the the people
doing
the courier tracking we're told
my god you helped us you helped us find
them yes it was your work why not
because you'd want them to think so
because then reporters could talk to
them and the people giving them the
briefings would be convinced they had
you don't tell them about a walk and you
tell nobody about a walker that's a
sacrifice secret not even inside the
agency so that's one element the other
element is bowden had written a piece
uh on one of the what they call a tick
tock piece you know five months later he
saw everybody the president and all
those people brennan and everybody
involved oh my god what a wonderful
opera he wrote a piece about the
operation
uh for vanity fair long piece and enter
the included account of the photographs
of bin laden being buried at sea off her
carrier
and
um he described it vividly and so i knew
mark and i like mark i didn't want to
embarrass him i waited till the week
before the piece was published first of
all um i knew a lot
i knew that
where the bin laden was taken to was the
base in pakistan called jalalabad it's a
forward base close to the hindu kush
mountains at that time there were no
fixed-wing airplanes there they only
used choppers
the aircraft carrier they went to was
something like 800 miles away in the
indian sea how do you get him there was
a problem secondly i knew
from ways i don't want to talk about
because i don't want to get some navy
officers embarrassed but i knew that
that everything is reported on the navy
ship and that night
the navy that aircraft carrier never
turned around to recover anybody never
told higher command we're picking up a
chopper now or an airplane that's very
important they have to do that there was
no such report in the in the logs and
the logs have since been classified
the third thing is i didn't know there
were imams aboard an aircraft carrier
ready to do an official a muslim married
so i asked
i knew that there was impossible that
that [ __ ] that that happened so i called
mark up he's teaching at the university
of delaware
and um
uh and i said to mark mark i'm gonna ask
you a question to which i think the
answer before i ask you is no
and here's the question did you actually
see those photographs you described so
vividly in your article he described how
they went in and how they looked
long pause and he said no
i said well how did you learn about him
well i was given a briefing about him
and from somebody i trusted he described
them very vividly i said well why didn't
you say you you didn't you know why did
you say you you hadn't seen him he said
well there was something to the effect
uh something the effect that he wished
he had or the editors didn't want it
there was more vivid if i just didn't if
i didn't if i left that out and i'm
telling you that's what happened
and so i can understand
um uh um
um
uh look
um he didn't see him
it didn't happen i'm sorry it just
didn't happen they didn't know what to
do the body was a mess let me tell you
why the body was a missed because the
seals were only supposed to fire a few
shots there were six as i said they come
in groups of six you know in a dinghy
one guy guarded the door
and um
and by the way when they used a plastic
to blow up the steel steel covered doors
they had learned from the isi in advance
exactly the dimensions and the thickness
of the steel because plastic 64 if you
use too much of it will kill you
so it had just the right amounts and you
wanted one of the questions is how do
they know just enough to knock the door
down with anybody getting hurt anyway
all because the pakistanis were giving
us that kind of intelligence it was a
lot of back and forth once they decided
to play ball with us to two leaders and
so
um what they did is they fired a lot of
bullets into him
dumb dumb bullets and you don't have to
do many but each of the guy took took
some shots and the buzz wasn't much left
of the body we're never going to see
photographs of the body they produce one
sort of tortured i don't know how they
did a picture of him with two holes in
it but i got to tell you there are a lot
of holes in the guy's head you could you
know i don't have to tell you how easy
it is to make a photograph you know
depict anything you want uh anybody saw
that wonderful movie what was it called
the fog award
a movie
anyway it doesn't matter some movie with
that described how we faked the war
done
back in in the clinton years anyway um
um uh
so what happened is you mean whack wag
the dog wag the dog remember how let's
get let her have a dog and there's a
brook running and and remember uh let's
change the color of this i i you can do
that and so anyway i i don't know why
people are don't pay more attention to
that stuff but
um um
i looked at
yeah
go ahead yeah i i found a quote from
hillary clinton when she just became
secretary of state on her first visit to
pakistan
this was in uh first part of 2009
and
she said this is a quote from her from
on that trip and she said this in
pakistan
i find it hard to believe that nobody in
your government knows where osama bin
laden is now she would not have said
that i don't think
in 2009 in pakistan if she didn't have
some assurance from the intelligence
community that in fact the pakistanis
did know in 2009 exactly where he was
there she is on record saying we heard
this then after the raid in 2011
just two years later
she said quote there's absolutely no
evidence that anyone at the highest
levels of the pakistani government knew
so in other words she went back on what
she said
after the raid
and i don't want to introduce politics
into this discussion but
what does that say about secretary
clinton and do you think this is
something she should be asked if she's
running for president
well it's you know it's not going to be
asked because it involves too much you
know too much uh uh uh you know it's
it's complicated and politics has played
out that's a simple question right she
she said this once and then two years
later she said that well then you'd have
to you have to be you'd have to somebody
who maybe buys into questions about what
happened and that's an uncomfortable
thought that the president you know we
had i'll tell you something more in his
initial statement that night the
president when he decided when the the
political people went out he made a
public statement in which he made a he
made a lot of assertions i write a lot
about it i don't know whether he knew
everything he was saying was untrue or
most of it was because you know the
president sometimes
they get a speech and they read a speech
i i don't know what the men's real did
he know how much he described um bin
laden as having been confronted with
weapons and we got a treasure trove i
remember that of documents here you are
you're on the run seals one of my
favorite stories they keep on talking
about all the books sometimes they say
the seals took out the books with them
that night is if they had time to carry
out bags of books or as if the seals or
most of them illicit guys i i some of
them are i'm sure very bright but i i
can't imagine that the seals after
you know
after having a chopper crash being in a
panic sitting there looking at the
bookcase saying which one should i take
first which which one do i want to read
first it's comical some of the stuff
they did so you have to buy into that
story but that night the president also
said i want to thank the pakistani
counterintelligence forces for their
help
and help and they had to get rid of that
within days they were explicitly saying
the president misspoke and then the next
week he went on television and by this
time within a week
i knew the day after the raid that there
was trouble that gates had made some
real problems for them i did know that i
did know that from somebody high up in
the white house that gates was
considered to be an enemy he was against
this
and then
what people
don't want to know about me i guess is
in no nine i wrote a piece for the new
york new yorker about the pakistani bomb
and our fear about it and i got i spent
weeks in pakistan they've been there
three or four times before that
and i spent weeks that i really
got into some interesting stuff to the
point where and here's what happens in
the government
you do a story and you you come in with
some some issues that this is obama
administration some issues that are
comfortable and the white house denies
everything that's just what they do and
but so they denied we had i said there
was
um
whatever i said i said that
our goal basically was to make sure
pakistani could not pakistan could not
fire a bomb
without our approval and if they ever
tried to we wanted to be in a position
to knock out the whole system
the whole system so they couldn't fire
electronically actually attack the
igloos knock out the command system it's
a pretty tough thing to say
and so
after denying all this the white house
called up my editor dave remnick
um
and
david called me to say that he got a
call from somebody behind the government
and this is two the night before the
story closed it must have been a
thursday night the story the magazine
goes to print friday night at midnight
uh somewhere in tennessee
and um
he said that they're very concerned and
they said that if the story goes we one
of the things we did at the new yorker
and we do at the london review is we do
share what we're writing with the with
the people give them a chance to talk
even though it's usually hopeless and
um they said david said that um
that the
the american government somebody senior
in the government that he respected i
guess and knew
maybe just because of the position
had told them that if the story is
published as it was we would have to
close our embassy immediately and our
consulates we have a bunch of consulates
the big country and move the people out
for fear riots because the
fundamentalists who really loved the
bomb would attack us for for alleging we
had so we toned down the story quite a
bit
quite a bit so
i have contacts i say that to mention
that i have contacts in pakistan and
within it i heard the day after that
there was problems in river city
inside the white house with with with um
bob gates
uh he was seen as somebody who wasn't on
the team on this
and um and i heard then from somebody
close to the intelligence service in
pakistan a three-page email
that described pretty much what i ended
up writing i went to americans
i had to wait a day or so i went waited
till the middle of the week and i went
to some americans who would have known
everything about it i have i'm sorry i
have contacts you know
bob
i as a journalist
we all have to depend on briefings you
know and we have to depend on access if
you're covering the white house you've
got to maintain good relationships and
you can't go off the wagon too much you
could be aggressive but not too far
and
and the the mana the thing you want
is somebody who in the government and
there are many people like that there
are a lot of wonderful people in our
government whose loyalty and when they
sign the oath of office is to the
constitution and not to the president
and when you have somebody like that on
the inside
who is
appalled by the lying and the
misdirection and also
leaving the two senior generals who
control the bomb with the reason they
hate us we left them with two options
pasha and kiana one option was to tell
everything to the people that we knew he
was there and have their children not be
able to walk to school because of fear
of being counter-attacked by by the
fundamentalists who are very vigorous
there the other option is do what they
did
we screwed up and we didn't know our
radar system our radar system didn't
work here's a radar system that we paid
and you could find it 900 million bucks
for all you had to do with some work if
you're a reporter the next week instead
of calling up and begging the white
house for another briefing go take a
look at what's online
the contracts that are led you can find
stuff even the most secret top secret
contracts have to be announced they may
be announced top secret contracts to so
and so for this no more detail but you
can find that they have to be announced
somewhere in the government and so
nobody did that
all you had to do was go
do the research and you would see the
the stories
um
about the radar not working and we left
them in this horrible position having to
say to the their nation that their their
national defenses including the
protection against a nuclear attack the
first strike from from the hated indians
uh uh is capable of being so easily
defeated and there was a terrible
position to leave him and gates position
was all along his underlying position so
i believe
um
is that you're messing with the two guys
that control the bomb you're
undercutting our faith and confidence
their faith and confidence in us and
that's to me the reason why
the real
power behind what i'm writing is and the
real issue is that we have jeopardized a
relationship with you know what we used
to be so frightened of we call the
islamic bomb it's there
and we're not on good terms with the
pakistanis so i'm sorry go ahead
so
i wanted to shift gears a little bit in
the time we have left because a large
part of your book obviously several
chapters have talked about syria
and syria is a a
i don't know a five-sided rubik's cube
with
uh very difficult to see you know
through the hall of mirrors there the
the
united states is supporting some rebels
and not other rebels and we're
supporting iraq but iraq supports
the syrian government and iran supports
the iraqi and syrian governments and
there's you know it's a it's it's a it's
a mess right and
you talk a lot about syria and the gas
attack
and a number of other things but one of
the points that really struck me is the
chapter you call
military to military
and
you talk about how
the military essentially
on its own initiative
the joint chiefs
undertook to
sabotage or undercut presidential policy
in syria because they didn't agree with
it
you say on page 101 we did this without
going through political channels on page
102
obama didn't know
the next page you say it was not some
sinister joint chief's plot to go around
obama to support assad but a few pages
later you say that assad understood this
message that where we can stop
presidential policy says the military
you say it doesn't sound like
military independent thinking and action
but it does sound exactly like that and
regardless of what you think about
obama's syria policy and as a reporter
i've done my own reporting on that
isn't it kind of scary that the military
as you report
um undertook to provide intelligence
indirectly to assad
while
u.s official policy was to support
the the overthrow of assad um i i think
this happened
because
um as i um it's a comp you're asking a
complicated question you've done a a
close read on it and um um and uh you're
right well it isn't complicated because
you say directly that the military
did something independently without
informing the white house
to essentially support
i don't know i don't want to call assad
an enemy but somebody who you know we
didn't like and we're trying to get rid
of
the issue was
for the military was very complicated
because there was a tremendous amount of
disagreement in with with the military
of the american policy if you remember
one of the articles i also wrote was
called the red line in the rat line it
was about the the shipping of weapons uh
into turkey uh through uh ergodon's
turkey ergo that we now know is of
course his it's pretty well known he's
become quite sort of crazy he's now
there's uh just just just in the last
day or so the u.n is raising questions
about the murder of pkk the opposition
kurds that are going on daily and he's
also supported the isis very much and
illness where there's no question we
have intelligence on that
and
i mean it had for years and it was very
hard to get the white house to
to switch from the military's point of
view um the arms going in were there
whatever moderates existed in 2012 uh by
early 2013 have pretty much been
overtaken by the crazies by the more
fundamentals the office and mojaves um
the group supported by
saudi arabia and qatar most notably and
so meanwhile we're still shipping arms
to the alleged moderates who had lost a
lot of leverage inside and many of them
by the way in the at the last count 61
various different tribal groups have
made an accommodation with assad in the
last six or so months he's been making
accommodations with groups that become
disaffected
that maybe were rebels but they were
disaffected because the control of the
opposition was in the hands of people
who if they taken over the country would
have caused enormous trouble uh israel
would have been concerned about an isis
government you know because they would
have been the next target the iranians
certainly would have been moved so there
was and it was very it was very
difficult for them to get a reading in
the white house the white house was
stuck on a policy and the president was
isolated and my understanding was that
on a lot of issues memos from the
chairman of the joint chiefs
general dempsey
would
uh who's now retired would um just
disappear and to avoid and this is
something you hear quite a bit that a
lot of bureaucratic stuff doesn't
doesn't get to the president he's rather
isolated and removed
and so
yes
they did decide
that it was very important for bashar to
maintain leverage this doesn't mean that
in some future time
if an election process goes on he would
be out of office but at this time he was
doing he was he was getting shaky uh in
2013 and we also were very concerned
uh i will tell you that by the fact and
it is a fact i have documents it doesn't
matter you know it's it's um i i even
mentioned the documents in one story
very secret stuff i had
that by early spring of 2013 we knew
that saudi arabia and the turks were
passing
chemicals into al-nusra and what became
isis the more radical groups that when
melded together
created a form of very powerful nerve
agent very difficult to work with but we
knew they had that capability there were
huge studies done about it in june july
and um in june
may june and july even in one study
about maybe how many troops would it
take to wipe out all of the chemical
weapons that were in the opposition's
hand it was 60 000 troops it couldn't
just too many american troops we thought
about doing it this is before the august
event in which we claim bashar did the
um uh did
murdered his own people with nerve gas
and so
the issue was
um
we had the kind of intelligence that he
needed we have satellite intelligence we
have intercepts and the germans were
there helping them and so we passed it
uh the germans asked for help and once
they asked for help we give allies a lot
of help i'm giving you the rationale
i'm not disputing your assessment of
what the import was and what was
understood and i'll tell you something
about dempsey we always think about
generals as sort of neuters dempsey
majored in english
at the academy
a military academy and the army which
does this often
recognizing his he was quite skilled i
guess as a student
they allowed him to spend two years
getting a master's degree in fine arts
at duke he's he's renowned among his
friends and peers
for his reading knowledge and for his
love of yates and his knowledge about
yates he's sort of a passionate
a devotee and the day he retired retired
he retired august 31st of last year and
the september of the first instead of
joining the 14 boards of defense
corporations many are as our former
chairman do and make you know five
hundred thousand dollars a year in that
and war uh he went back and he was given
an appointment at duke and he's teaching
there he's a different cat
and so
he made the call i guess uh with the
help of others inside the joint chiefs
and outside the government perhaps to
start helping supplying
uh osama
as uh
bashar assad the president of of uh
packet of of um
i'm getting lost here of syria of syria
um with intelligence that would help him
turn the corners on the war and he did
and the other big thing that happened in
the war that in the last year was of
course the right that doesn't sound that
doesn't seem like treason to you to to
to deliberately undercut the president's
policy i mean i i you can quit if you're
a general
um and then you can speak out
but really you kind of pretty much have
to salute and say yes sir if you're in
the joint chiefs don't you
um
i find it pretty refreshing that we had
a chairman of the joint chiefs who tried
to express a view and in that same
article in the next paragraph i quote
the former by name
the head of the former and i i mentioned
dempsey by name too in the article the
chairman the former head of the the
defense intelligence agency i quote him
by name who was talking about michael t
flynn michael flynn who's um um yeah i
was gonna i was going to ask you about
well because
um he you cite him as a source one of
the few people on the record you know
that you talk about
um and you portray him as kind of a
truth teller and somebody who resisted
obama
he was fired as head of dia a couple
years ago
um
but here's the thing about
about flynn i mean he's recently emerged
as an advisor one of the top advisers to
donald trump absolutely he's written a
book he's written a book with michael
ladine who is one of the well they're
right they're writing the book now
they're writing the book now well no
it's it's a published publish it comes
out
right pretty soon yeah it's called
its title is field of fight
how we can win the global war against
radical islam and its allies
so i mean flynn has clearly put himself
in the camp of
an extremist on fighting islam in the
global war against terrorism i i i don't
know why he was fired from dia but from
the sound of it he was fired because
he was insubordinate he was a he was a
radical who wanted to go after these
guys and he accuses the president
of not wanting to fight hard enough
against islamism and and all that just
the way you know the the
ultra-conservatives do he was very much
i mean
let me let me let me you quote him as a
a truth-teller you know uh uh because it
he one of the issues was about him you
know as you as you know he also worked
as the the head of intelligence
uh for this joint special operations
command for years he was a two and three
star workers yeah and he worked with
mcchrystal in iraq
during the right the most brutal of the
time in iraq when they were just
assassinating people by the hundreds
during the the
you know the counter-insurgency effort
there um in bar and and so on right now
absolutely there was a lot of stuff
going on that was considered to be
wonderful and if you notice the crystal
really got always great press that he
was promoted by obama after years in
iraq of the being very bloody to be head
of the war in afghanistan
and so on all of that i and flynn was
always there he was a very active with
the press corps a lot of people had his
email which is how i got it
and um
the issue for me there was you of course
described somebody who was very
conservative and got got pushed out um
but the fact of the matter is uh what he
said was very consistent with everything
i knew
and he was willing to say it on the
record and he what it was is that there
was a whole series of reports that
summer about al-nusra
and isis has it emerged very early about
how dangerous they were and how they had
access to chemical weapons too
and so on that basis um i will tell you
that
um uh obama
uh he was shoved out and they wanted him
shelved out earlier uh but he um
you know when you get a source on the
record and he's saying something that
you know
from documents you have that is also so
um and if you'd make it a point to make
sure he was somebody who was held
you know he was considered i wouldn't
say a wild man but if you go back and
look he's been he'd been he's been
quoted by so many journalists along the
way all the way and so he wasn't
necessarily in this case uh somebody on
the record he was saying something that
suited my what i learned is that he was
that um he and
uh
the chairman of the joint chiefs their
staffs were simpatico on this issue
there were many issues they were not
sympatical on you know he he was
certainly
his real problem was he created also
dissent internally he was reorganizing
things
her partner was like cold he was
reorganizing things on the inside
but i don't think
i think in all fairness of the guy i
think he was calling it as he saw it yes
in that case he was absolutely right and
i had documents that demonstrated they
actually came from his office and went
to his office some of the stuff all
sorts of stuff cia nsa israeli
intelligence some of the doc some of the
reports that were going on about the
amount of
amount of um nerve agent potential in
the opposition uh before the what
happened in august before this the
incident with um
uh in in the suburb of the damascus when
1400 people were killed not that many
but that's how many was alleged to be
we're alleged to be killed so you know
it's a tough goal somebody on the record
and he's what he's saying is consistent
with believe me i'm checking what he
says consistent with other people
involved
in terms of that narrow issue his
personal political views were way off
the chart but on the issue of what he
was seeing and what they were saying he
was very consistent and so the argument
against him is he was mouthy and he was
a very conservative guy and he was
always saying things but if you go back
and look he was used as an authority by
all the major media when he was working
for jay sock you know despite the fact
he was known to be sort of a hard-on
right-wing sort of guy
like many officers are and so there we
are you know you live and die i i i
don't want to call i don't want to talk
about estresia i think it was about an
inability to get the white house to
recognize something that had been
reported and reported and reported which
is the moderates don't really exist this
was being reported consistently by all
sources inside and they weren't paying
attention to it so i think at that point
um i i the the the the chairman of the
joint chiefs made a call that that um
um um
uh you know that makes some sense to me
could you know
uh and the argument that if you the
chairman of the joint chiefs is always
beholden to the white house
again that that
it's he's beholden to the constitution
is what i'm saying and that's what he
saw he saw that the overall the white
house simply was not paying attention
and obama for better or worse
in the throughout the bureaucracy
there's their one complaint is you
really have a hard time getting stuff to
him
and i could tell you well of course not
to not too many generals are
constitutional lawyers and so
that's really what i was getting at when
i asked the question about i don't know
if generals know what the constitution
says or means but it's certainly not
their job to to interpret it but we got
to wrap up here it looks like um
let me ask you you mentioned at the in
your intro of your book about obama's
legacy
um at least on foreign policy
um
i i would say i guess it kind of starts
with the iran deal maybe and you know he
pledged to end
the wars in iraq and afghanistan and
i don't know maybe he tried his best he
he tried to
avoid getting entangled in syria when
clinton and kerry were pushing for a you
know much greater escalation of that
fight
um
on the other hand you know he's got this
drone program i mean how do you where do
you come down on on his legacy when it
comes to foreign policy uh i'm you know
i don't like the fact that he even in
the case of iran
um we just had an article by one of his
a's ben rhodes in the new york times uh
of last sunday uh in which he was
bragging about how they manipulated the
press on the iranian deal
it's wonderful what he did in iran but
the critical thing wasn't about
sanctions and pressures it was about the
fact that after 12 or 13 years of
consistently telling the iranians that
we will discuss a nuclear deal with you
in enrichment when you stop all
enrichment that was the requirement you
stop
about two or three years ago we made it
known to rouhani and others you can keep
on enriching and that's when the deal
got going and that there's nothing wrong
with saying that there's nothing wrong
with saying uh in the case of the
serendil when when we we still accuse
bashar assad of of uh doing this errand
and uh when the when the attack took
place
they knew they had intelligence galore
that there were two suspects elusive
potentially they had saren and isis and
also bashar assad's military they only
had one suspect
they didn't tell the american people
there was another suspect and they also
didn't tell them that both
dempsey the chairman of the joint chiefs
and general clapper who was head of the
director of overall intel national
director of national intelligence the
overriding agency for all intelligence
services had both told the president
that they couldn't be sure that they had
a case against bashar they both said
it's as as clapper said it's not a slam
dunk because the sarin that we've we've
seen doesn't match what we know to be in
the arsenal and he doesn't tell the
president the world that and so i don't
i don't like not telling the truth about
critical issues to leave the world
thinking bashar may have done what he
may not have done and i'm not saying i
know i just say that the whole story has
not been told by the white house
um is is like a blood libel to me and it
you know
look you can't get two votes for bashar
assad in the in the in the in in the
congress today i mean he's hated he's a
hitler and we love our hitler's we've
had millions of hitler's you know um and
uh i'll take a second and say this to
you he's fighting a life and death war
with those people if isis and one of
those people get in power
uh he and his wife and their two
beautiful children are going to be hung
up like mussolini you know with their
throats cut uh you know in the square
and yes he uses barrel bombs but i know
what country that you know heinous awful
barrel bombs i know a country that used
barrel bombs for seven years in a war in
which their our national security their
national security was not at stake it
was us we use barrel bombs full of
cacadelic acid a defoliate that also has
consequences for all sorts of people as
we know now the number of deformed
deformities in vietnam we use it with a
day palm seven years we drop barrel
bombs why because they're cheaper a
barrel bomb it comes oil comes in a
barrel bomb is 63 gallons and it's
cheaper it's cheaper than than dropping
a 500 pounder so i always wondered when
we attacked him for that uh first we did
it i mean i always wondered about our
morality of that and secondly is it
really better if he'd use the 500 pound
bomb which had maybe three times as much
lethal stuff than a barrel bomb i i you
know i'm just a i i'm not making a case
for the guy he's a despot he's like is
he any worse than the guys in saudi
arabia who are chopping off heads right
now among the shiats in eastern saudi
arabia is any worse than bahrain any
worse than uae where all sorts of
horrible things are happening to the
shiite and minorities i don't think so i
think he's of a piece and so there we
are
i and you ask about the president not
getting involved in syria just put 250
special forces troop into syria and as
far as i know bashar assad's the
reigning still recognized by the u.n as
the reigning power and the russians are
there yes with with approval by the sub
by the the syrian government uh the
iranians are there with approval by the
syrian government hezbollah the shiite
group from from lebanon uh nazareth's
group they're there with approval by the
syrian government we're not we're in
there not with the approval would the
president have put 250 special forces
guys into israel without
that casually or to canada hell no so
there's i mean it's a point of view the
world sees what he does and i'll tell
you something else if you think the
number of american troops into iraq
is three or four thousand as they
announced i'm telling you it's four or
five times that amount and maybe even
more if you count the pilots and crew
that are doing the bombing uh from the
from the ocean
and so um
i think i think we have to i'm just
saying he's not telling the truth to the
people about some basic stuff and that's
bad on the other hand let me just say
this i also think he's probably going to
be the brightest president we're going
to have for the next 50 years
well
that is um a low bar but
thanks so much for your
thanks so much for your your time today
i really enjoyed the discussion thank
you robert
c-span created by america's cable
television companies and brought to you
as a public service by your cable or
satellite provider
haters
good evening
good evening
that's more like it
[Applause]
good evening
my name is paul holden grab i'm the
director of public programs here at the
new york public library known as live
from the new york public library as all
of you know my goal here at the library
is to make this heavy institution
levitate and when successful to make it
dance i'm so pleased to have sai hush
back he was here last with chris hedges
two years ago in may
2016.
after that visit he discovered the a
brozenthal
archives here and it changed the course
of his memoir
as always i'm grateful for the continued
generosity of celeste bartos manas and
adam batas tonight is closing night for
live from the new york public library it
has been quite the season which opened
with patton oswalt and closes tonight
with seymour hirsch i would like to mark
this occasion by thanking the new york
public library team it takes a village
in no particular order but with
gratitude i would like to thank faye
rosenfeld tully stolzenberg myers
anthony audi raylyn grogan
carrie welch femi kirby jean hodesh
emily krell nora lyon serena rocco
colleen gibson arden ambrester allison
palmer vanessa novak emily pullin helen
silva raul ramos david mackey aiden flax
clark elizabeth hep richard schnorr as
well as the wonderful curators who have
shown our special guest things of great
beauty and relevance before the events
to inspire them further
i would also like to thank
the guards at the library as well as our
wonderful av team from park boulevard
tonight i would also like to thank all
the wonderful people at knopf amongst
them joseph purcell and always somehow
presents throughout paul beaugard's
tonight we celebrate the just published
memoir of sai saihersh simply called
reporter
sai will sign books after our
conversation
now it's not my my habit to really read
blurbs
but
[Music]
this one is quite extraordinary it's
it's a blurb that you you know stick on
the book um and this blurb is by john le
carre and it says this book is essential
reading for every journalist and
aspiring journalists the world over
quite an endorsement
now
i also would like to give you a sense of
of just how extraordinary this book is
and how beautifully it's written
by reading to you
the first paragraph and the first
sentence of the second paragraph which
you will see is very important
the first paragraph goes like this
i am a survivor
from the golden age of journalism when
reporters for daily newspapers did not
have to compete with the 24-hour cable
news cycle when newspapers were flush
with cash from display advertisements
and want ads and when i was free to
travel anywhere anytime for any reason
with company credit cards
there was sufficient time for reporting
on a breaking news story without having
to constantly relay what was being
learned on the newspaper web page
there were no televised panels of
experts and journalists on cable tv who
began every answer to every question
with the two deadliest words in the
media world
i think
we are sudden with fake news hyped up
and incomplete information and false
assertions delivered non-stop by our
daily newspapers
our televisions our online news agencies
our social media
and
our president
this is a
next important first sentence
yes
it's a mess
now in in in closing i wonder if you
were applauding yes it's a mess if you
were applauding the fact that it is one
or that psy wrote that
sai writes in on the second page um of
his memoir he says
my career has been all about the
importance of telling
important and unwanted truths and making
america a more knowledgeable place
we have given our life from the new york
public library spring 2018 closing night
the hopefully fitting title of unwanted
truths
now many of you know
that for the last seven or eight years
i've been asking my guests to give me a
biography of themselves in seven words
seven words that might define them or
might not a haiku of sorts
and my favorite for the moment
apart from my own which i got from my
mother who said that who told me when i
was 11 years old that we had two ears
and one mouth
which i used as my seven words was joan
didions who said seven words do not yet
define me
but i
think i think my favorite one
for the moment
is cy hershey's seven words would you
like to hear them
it's fun
rounding up the usual suspects
he is
all right
i like that it's weird to be asked to
summarize anything in seven words but
that's okay
you did a
but newspapers always take ten words and
reduce them to seven so you get used to
it
now
no but i did like those seven words they
are my favorite for the moment
nanoseconds
um
now
your critics
have often described you as paranoid
and you've always been a big reader of
fiction
so it perhaps makes sense for us to
start
with a line of thomas pynchon who wrote
the following proverb for paranoids
in gravity's rainbow
he said
if they can get
you asking
the wrong questions
they don't have to worry
about answers
i've read that book so many years ago 20
years how old was that book do you think
when was that probably 20 years ago
a long time ago
i remember that line but the idea is not
bad that's
the whole purpose of sometimes
well let's put it this way
um the most
fallacious
words i know
are we have high confidence when the
american government says we have high
confidence
that if you remember they said it again
and again for about 18 months that
saddam hussein this is in 2000 before
the invasion in 2003 we have high
confidence he have he has weapons of
mass destruction
they also said i have to tell you again
and again
they say we have high confidence that
the russians were responsible for
hillary losing and when i hear that i
just think
there's another story there and and so
it's in a way
they're posing the wrong reality i get
to turn what you know his but his ideas
right if they can get people
it's it's a good idea
it's it's
if the government
can
somehow
deflect
what could be some serious
rational concern
by making statements for which there's
no basis they win
because it's very hard
you know we even have a case where we
have a president that's a born-again
liar right now right he lies about
everything he just it's it's more than
lying it's
i mean he
it's a pathology because he'll in the
middle of a 20-minute sentence he'll say
something then later he said i didn't
say it
which is the kind of lie he makes it's
like a three-year-old sort of i don't
know what maybe i'm being cruel to
three-year-olds
but but anyway he does
and so he lives in a world that doesn't
exist on some things
and so um how do you parse all that how
do you
um
well
one thing then
is when the president says
i saw pictures of starving children or
children that were murdered by the evil
sodom who's saying
or in this case as this president does
we we had that with with the bush and
creating a universe that didn't live up
to a point
we have this president
the press doesn't believe anything he
says except when he says things like
um
bashar assad murdered 800 000 people 3
million people with nerve gas yesterday
and that's taken at face value when
haley says we saw pictures of dead
people
and so there's a funny dichotomy some
things we don't believe a thing he says
about but sometimes when he says
something about either people we don't
like or people that are unpopular
uh saddam hussein is is a hated man in
america right now like
we always have to have people we hate it
started with you know of course hitler
obviously and mao
and joe and lai and then you go through
the list there's been you know scares of
gaddafi for a time uh
the mullahs in in iran we've always had
saddam hussein
we've always had people we had to hate
so i don't understand why somebody who's
whose
mayor conversation is com replete with
what the washington post gives what they
call pinocchio's 1-4 is a big deal
replete with misstatements and missed
facts why on some things
foreign policy or something he's taken
he's taken literally
and so i don't that doesn't mean he's
wrong i just don't i just say i don't if
i don't believe him about what he says
about anything you know if he wants to
say he did change his
you know he is running for reelection
the fact that he did what he did today
with the with the children shows he's
definitely committed to running
and at this point it's is that how you
read his oh my god yeah so he had no he
couldn't go another day without it
for the first time he was losing really
seriously across the board the when you
the the newspapers the major newspapers
and
the new york times does great you're
lucky it's a great newspaper even though
the money's not there they spend a great
deal of time and investigative stuff but
still on the major front
it's still they're always
it's like like a fencing match with his
his his tweets
they're living in his world
they're playing in his little bed bedpan
or whatever it is not that
well you know
it's interesting you have those who
believe in you all right i find that
interesting and you actually meant to
say that i said it anyway i didn't want
to say it i tried to stop myself but i
can't do anyway but no it's it's it's um
and so
look
uh this isn't about anything
you know as you said in the beginning of
about the
about the people who say i think
uh when they're on i've watched these i
stopped watching cable television we've
really got to a country now where
there's no when i worked at the new york
times i call it the halcyon days in the
70s we were taken seriously if we wrote
something it meant
that uh it was a rational judgment and
you could you could take it to the bank
and now what you have is a whole
half of america that don't believe
anything anybody says negative about
bush whether in the new york times or
not whether new york times or msnbc
or the cnn and they want to listen to
fox and the papers that support what he
writes and they tune out everything else
so we have there's no middle ground
anymore in the media and unfortunately
the times has joined in
um with this visceral
and i i think they should back off a
little bit that doesn't mean you give
him
it just means that
for me it means
don't worry about what he says let's
write about yemen let's write about two
months ago this stuff happened began
with the taking the kids away and what
why did it take until somebody broadcast
children crying for the press to get
into it they really were slow and it was
there and also why worry about pruitt
this guy who runs the epa who believes
he's entitled to whatever he's entitled
to we've always had people uh look he's
got the worst cabinet going but start
thinking about some of the things he did
i was at a conference
a journalism conference last week in
orlando there's investigating reporters
and editors conference just a group of
of young journalists
um large group now 1800 in a downtime
wanting to become reporters because i
think they see
young people it's sort of a renaissance
um the inter this this group ire is
called oh it was their annual
conferences jindal the five or six now
it's up to three times as many in a down
time for the market when people are
going into this business
knowing they're not going to get the
kind of money they did you know when i
mentioned my credit cards you know the
new york times my first week at the new
york times the first day i was sent that
night business class in air france to
the creon hotel to start covering the
peace process i was obviously office
kamiyami you know the
lay duct toe and the french the talks
the 1972 peace talks with the north
vietnamese but i'm suddenly enough you
know i mean it was the glory days
they're not that like that anymore kids
going into it because they care
and so i i i i talk to people when i go
to these conferences and i talk to
reporters from oklahoma and reporters in
the city and they they tell me things
like
they have a manufacturer of baby
carriages
and
he can cut costs on the manufacturer
there's a lot of there's their baby
carriages
little towers fall out of them for years
and they've toughened the restrictions
like a little you know six month eight
month baby won't be able to push and
fall down out of it now they're they've
cut back the safety they've they managed
to lobby
the conservatives who work for for trump
and they've they've reduced some of the
requirements for having these these when
they're a pull mechanism everybody's had
children know we're talking about
they made it much easier for a child to
inadvertently flop out
and um it's being litigated but that's
the kind of stuff i think you can go
after him all week on that and if you're
playing his pen pen it's a dirty little
pan as i say
um lewis because until just this thing
happened he was up eight points in the
poll
uh just in the last two months of all
this vituperation
and some of the stuff
i mean
it's bad
he is president and it's bad but he goes
to korea
and it's bad he doesn't know a thing
about nuclear arms but most presidents
don't
you know i mean
ronald reagan didn't know there was a
nuclear arms or a triad air sea and
and land
and um um he didn't know how bombs were
delivered he didn't know anything
in this case
um i'm just trying to think how secret
this crap is
there was in a very intensive paper done
about
the new the leader of the third
generation of north korea
and the paper was done by psychoanalysts
and others that worked for the american
government many of them are in private
practice they're they're clinical
psychologists psychiatrists and
psychoanalysts that look at
they look at information that you can't
see and i can't see intercepts
conversations he's had private stuff
that we collect you know we always
in america we always oh my god the
iranians and the russians and the
chinese are listening everything we're
the big listeners we're terrific at it
we're really good we are really good we
just don't want to talk about it
but we know who does what anyway we had
a lot of stuff in him these guys are
given the transcripts and they produce a
report
an extensive report the president is
never going to read it but it's all
about this guy's incredible real desire
to have money
to not be an impoverished nation
and he wants to be a leader a assist he
wants to be a tourist leader he wants to
do that so they they tell it to the
president
and
the way it comes out in his conversation
for which he was mocked
he says to him he says you've got
beautiful beaches i can see condos being
grown you know he's he's he's a he's the
atlantic city guy in casinos and all
that
but
and he's mocked for it but the idea
isn't
is the idea is a thoughtful idea he
can't articulate because he's he's you
know but he did get enough of it to know
that i can offer this guy money and
he'll drop his bombs
and that's what's going on so it's a
little more complicated than the press
makes it it's just not him bumbling he's
a bumber
and he's going to be that way forever
but my attitude towards it here i'm
talking about politics when i should
answer instead of saying i'm telling you
what i think and i should answer by
saying how the hell do i know which is
what i would answer if i was on those
shows what's your view on this how the
hell do i know because what doesn't
matter what i think well how the hell do
you know well i do know people i do know
i've known people all my life who do
things
and do on places that would surprise a
lot of people and my editors at the new
york times and at the dave remnick and
um
they used to somebody that was talking
to me would suddenly show up
being offered a big inside job and he
would call me i remember in one case
david did and said don't they know and i
said no they don't know what i'm talking
to there's ways to do it
and so what what i know is
he wants to run
um he's he's developing a kitty
he's set in the stadium in the state of
the union nobody paid any attention to
it he said we're going to have a
marshall plan like we did and go back
and read the last it was the last
paragraph or two last maybe the
penultimate paragraph
maybe i stopped listening earlier but it
was in the end of the
end of the speech it's hard to listen
it is hard to listen
i mean it's this is something else but
he is president
and he said we're gonna have a marshall
plan and private companies are gonna be
able to to contribute for it
he's been raising money
around the world
for a reconstruction
kitty that's going to be it's over a
billion now it's going to be 3 4 billion
he's going to announce at some point
after the congressional elections
whatever happened it doesn't matter he's
not going to lose the senate he's not
going to get impeached
um and he's going to now no i don't
think so
um collusion
uh uh
mueller's problem is collusion
implies
that you have an ability
to take this step
knowing what's going to happen to this
step
you can step a and it's going to impact
step b
this is impulse man
the idea of a significant collusion what
it's just let's do this
there's no that there's no b there's
only a
so how are you going to prove that he
was colluding with the russians
he's not capable of that he's mens ria
you know so he's got a problem you know
he they're not going to get enough
they've looked at his tax stuff right
away at that i know they found not
enough there to make a choice so
so let me ask you a question
but i'll just answer it for 20 minutes
again so go ahead yeah
i'll i'll try to change that a little
bit if i can
you you just open it up man yeah i know
so
you you speak about yourself as uh in
your memoir as an aggressive
learner
and you say you signed up as a teenager
you signed up
to the book of the month yes
what kind of books did they send you um
i i was about 13 and you have to
understand my parents were
dare i say immigrants who hadn't gone to
high school
and i really didn't figure them out it
was hard to figure them out because
eastern european
lithuanian polish they didn't
communicate very well with students that
we were we were in a different
generation very quickly in a different
era so
i i and my mother communicated by
cooking my father communicated by saying
nothing
[Laughter]
and so
um
um
he liked walter lipman so i knew he
could read and write but he never talked
about so when i was 13
i joined up i saw these ads for the book
of the month club which is huge back
then i went talk about you know 800
years ago and it was it was um
and a dollar was 99 cents i think a
month and i always signed up for the
non-fiction
and um
uh four out of 12 months i would get
something by edgar hoover and the perils
of communism this is in the early 50s or
john gunther somebody might remember him
another one you know he made a living
writing about communism but then i would
get a book about something called the
habsburg monarchy
and chinese civilization and so you just
was like what
i was in grammar school for you know
they didn't teach you much in school and
you know i i could read and write and
stuff like that when you got a book uh
about communism in that way did you did
you detect already that it was fishy
that something was wrong
how in the hell do i remember
um well you it's an interesting question
because you actually i don't know
because you ask yourself that question
but you know i don't remember often what
i do remember is that when i one jump
ahead 10 years or 20 15 years i'm a a
reporter in more in chicago for the
associated press i'd already worked as a
police reporter or he worked for united
press coming the legislature
in pier south dakota
um uh oh my god but anyway but it was
great because i was a chicago kid south
side chicago kid i never you know i'm in
a town of ten thousand
and um
what
i didn't you know i had to figure it out
uh that helped but when i did my first
reaction to the vietnam war was i read i
was passionate i began to read the new
york times very early every day
and i began to read
bernard fall i'm i'm working for the ap
i'm a i'm a reporter but ap was great to
me they let me
they i was good and so they let me just
run you know and i i and i grew up
working in a african-american black
neighborhood so i was very sensitive to
racial issues and
i got to know mahalia jackson the singer
and martin luther king i was assigned to
cover him
and um
i was i was i was
madly in love you know i was the ap is
powerful he'd have a rally
and he'd call you he'd go like this to
me because he go like this come meet me
later and then i
yes sir you know i was in love and so i
go see him and he would do the ap is
every paper in the world and he would do
for the overnights he understood my
business there was a rally and there
were rocks on and he was pat he was
marching in this incredible rage of
southwest chicago white southwest
chicago in in panic about blacks
marrying their daughters and taking
their jobs i was real serious and rocks
it was horrible stuff that he would
never waver lead these marchers scared
to death of course
not not acknow not afraid to say i was
always scared and then he would i would
i would go and he would see me and he
would say
i'm so mad at the president johnson for
not doing this and that and i have a
great story the next day
king blast johnson he would do that with
me a lot but he was aware getting back
to the earlier stuff my i started
reading a lot about the vietnam war
because i saw it coming i knew i just
don't know why
and um
my first impression i read
david halbersam and neil sheehan
uh both of them became friends and
malcolm brown who was then with the ap
neil shane was with upi and and maurice
safer if cbs was doing stuff he he was
going on he was the first guy to report
they were torturing villages and for
which he got in great trouble and so
there were a lot of journalists a ward
just who later became a very good
novelist for the washington post for
owning for himself
war just was a great war reporter and my
thought then was pretty much the
conventional thought
we got to stop
communism is coming i didn't know the
history of vietnam
and china i didn't know they hated each
other
i didn't know dan ellsberg was one of
the first to tell me that years later
that you know he couldn't get the
pentagon to understand that there's no
way china we're fighting a war and we're
fighting the north vietnamese and in the
thought that the chinese would come
stupidity has never been a big thing
anything other than a major serious
issue for us in our wars going back to
the dulles brothers and the world and
the korean war which they thought the
russians were responsible for not at all
no evidence of it at all anyway the
point being
and so i thought
we got to stop communism but they were
fighting the war wrong
they weren't fighting it the right way
and it took me a little while to begin
to realize you know a year or two before
i realized
this is mass murder i got assigned to
the to washington
from from chicago and i always began to
cover the pentagon
and what you do as a reporter what i did
i can't believe this is so original
i
i
we had access as a reporter the pentagon
the officers and enlisted men but mostly
officers and the the good people get
rotated back there they're bright people
and what you want are the guys
that when they take the oath of office
it is an oath to the constitution it's
not to the general it's not to the
admiral it's not to the president and
you find those guys and they began
talking to me once they got to trust me
a little bit and i told them about my
great skepticism this is in 65 and 66
that early they began to talk to me
about mass murder out there just mass
murder and i was reading the other thing
as i when i go to journalism schools the
talk
i always they say well what's the trick
and i said the trick is read before you
write
so i read the church groups by 66 are
beginning to put out booklets about the
war i want to stop you there for a
moment you can be there any time i want
to stop you there for a moment because
someone i discovered through you very
late in life now
um
[Music]
i think now will matter to me greatly
and i want to show you a little moment
with him if we could look at video
number one please
is it me there
it's not the lion but we'll come on
mr stone uh the last 19 years with the
iaf stone bi-weekly you've had a chance
to
stand apart from institutions not be a
part of any institution why
well institutions are very powerful
and uh
those who run them are run by them
because the uh the circumstances and the
nature of the institution
severely limit
his decision-making capacity
it's true of every but men can't live
without institutions of course
so it's important in a good society to
have
institutions you have to have them it's
also important to have
independent voices
with the freedom to express themselves
who can check the abuses of institutions
what about the men you've dealt with
over the years in institutions they
behave differently as members of
institutions and they might behave as
individuals are they influenced by the
institution
i think inevitably and invariably
i mean no matter how they think a man
like mcnamara was a very able man
there were severe limits on what he
could do with secretary of defense
that's a
tremendous
organization the military bureaucracy
and
no matter how
active vigilant vigorous the head of it
is it
very severe in others to what he can do
the only way to be free is not to have
power
i mean diogenesis in his tongue was free
and
could afford to tell alexander to get
out of his
to get out of the way while i was taking
a sun bath
but you have to you have to have people
with power
yeah sure
you have to have people without power
you have to have uh your rocker you
can't run a complicated society without
bureaucracies
and you have to have uh mechanisms that
preserve
independence of judgment and expression
that
will check their abuses and criticize
their shortcomings and
and uh act as a watch to all over them
that's what the press is supposed to be
in a free society
but the press itself becomes
institutionalized
does it have an adversary relationship
with with institutions with government
it has to have
if it stops being an adversary
it's not it stops doing its job
that doesn't mean it needs to be
perpetually hostile
but basically
skeptical
he looks younger than i remember him
he's extraordinary
i want you to to tell about me and him
yeah
and how you got him into the ap office
well it's just an amazing story actually
i didn't know much about him until i got
married my mother-in-law had been a
subscriber of the ivestone weeklies and
she's the one that got me into it
and um
as i was reading izzy and um
i got a sign by the associated press i
was a reporter there in washington as i
said and i was a i was a i was a little
be i was good i was good and i got to
the i got signed to washington
and um to the sorrow of some of the
editors in new york i was assigned to
the pentagon
and
i thought mcnamara didn't take me long
to think mcnamara was a psychotic liar
i got involved in a story that involved
something with procurement about
airplanes and he was lying about it we
were losing many more planes and he's in
vietnam than he wanted to talk about so
i knew right away there was trouble and
the fact that i was
within a month of being at the pentagon
i was going after him about not telling
the truth led me to those guys in the
pentagon those officers with four stars
who were very worried about the line
that was going on in the war and so i
began to write some stuff and izzy stone
can smell stuff i don't know how he did
it i just wrote stories and i was
writing stories for the ap this very
neutral organization with a little bit
of edge
but you you do know how he did it and
well i i
what what i'm going to say is what
happened one day i was newly married my
wife and i on a saturday night went out
with some we went to somebody's house
for dinner and you know we probably got
to bed at three o'clock and my first
encounter with izzy was at 6 30 or
quarter to seven in the morning what
happened it turns out there's a new
stand
in downtown washington that gets all the
sunday papers by six
and he would go be waiting
to further stay in the open and so he
called me
and the conversation went like this
about a quarter to seven in the morning
i thought maybe i might you know i had
i thought maybe it was the desk in new
york saying somebody had a great start
anyway and he said uh um you're the same
guy that's a reporter i said yes have
you have you seen page 19 in the
philadelphia bulletin today
i said hell no
and so we agreed to meet
and i then be had we began to take talks
with him on walks with him i took a lot
of walks with him he would come and get
me
yeah even you know um on weekends when i
was you know not at the pentagon or
whatever and we would just take walks
for hours sometimes and he was
he was he was a teacher but it was to
the point of
read before you write but it was it's
what he did
and he was
i write about
he was forbidden by the ap to come and
read all its files
he was the most anti-com he was not ever
costa rica he didn't like communism he
said he didn't like the way communism
treated its people and he didn't like
any
totalitarianism he didn't like us the
way we were treating in vietnam
and um and the ap was getting every
night they would get
in the washington bureau they would get
there was every day in saigon there was
a briefing it's called the five o'clock
follies this went on for years and and
it was a long briefing of everything
that happened all the raids and it was
an avon
and izzy wanted access to it
and so
um there was a time i was working we
rotate i was working a sunday double
shift
and um
uh maybe it was i'm jewish maybe it was
some one of the holidays
uh you know something like christmas
and i told him i was working a double
shift he said can i come
will you let me in i said of course what
do you want to do he said i want to go
through those files
so i got i started the eight he was
there waiting for me winter
and there was only me in a teletype as i
had explained to the teletub he couldn't
care less and so is he and so we had a
scene where izzy
there was a big library and he's in the
library and there's volumes
and he's just there
and
he's about 100 the only thing as i wrote
i said
um the only thing i i would hear with a
little noise of happiness
you know little grunts and i'd say it's
sometime about one o'clock you want me
to get you something you know i'm fine
he was just
in heaven
and he took those files and he later
wrote a four-page spread
from those files that he'd read over a a
period a two a period of alleged truth
uh tooth that was called the tet tet
stand down it's just a period when there
was no fighting you took those files and
he wrote this magnificent series of how
we were misusing a piece juice in ways
we always accused the other side of
doing it but we were doing it four times
worse and i remember thinking wow
you know and and
it was just it was just
i mean it wasn't all work um one time he
introduced my wife and i the japanese
food very early and once we invited him
for dinner just just the four of us
and uh
um
his wife was married was the daughter of
um the sister of leonard bodine who my
wife's father
had practiced law with so we had some
connection and i remember my wife worked
all day making chinese food about a half
an hour before we came
we realized it was horrible it was just
hard to make some of that stuff so i ran
out to a chinese restaurant a good one
and i me i beat him by two minutes we
put it in pots so we had that kind of
stuff it was and he was you have to know
uh
you could get a sense of him he had a
sense of humor incredible incredible he
was funny and he was proud of himself he
became very successful he ended up
moving next to william fulbright the
chairman of the the senate arm
formulations committee and they became
great friends and izzy was not
a thr he was not a bomb thrower is he in
fulbright were like as tight as you want
to make it they were buddies
he wasn't afraid to consort with some
power because of course fulbright was on
the right side of the war and all that
and so it was just um
um
he saw something of me that was right
and he helped me a lot later when i had
trouble with mila i couldn't get me life
published and he was trying to help me
get it i stayed friends with him all of
his life
i'd like you to respond to um a
quotation
by by george orwell
about morality and language i know that
one right i think you do
so um and this in light of of your your
reporting about milai and abu ghraib
he writes this in the politics of the
english language
in our time
political speech and writing are largely
the defense of the indefensible
things like the continuance of british
rule in india the russian purges and
deportations the dropping of the atom
bombs on japan can indeed be defended
but only by arguments which are too
brutal for most people to face and which
do not square with the professed aims of
the political parties thus political
language has to consist largely of
euphemisms
question begging and sheer cloudy
vagueness
defenseless villagers are bombarded from
the air the inhabitants driven out in
the countryside the cattle machine
gunned the hut set on fire with
incidentally bullets this is called
pacification
millions of peasants are robbed of their
farms and sent trudging along the roads
with no more than they can carry this is
called
transfer of population
or rectification of frontiers
people are imprisoned for years without
trial or shot in the back of the
necklace sent to die of scurvy in arctic
lumber camps this is called
elimination
of unreliable elements
such phraseology is needed
if one wants to name things without
calling up mental pictures
of them
what was the what date what year was
that you know
anyway it's like you know we had we call
the pacification
pacification
the vietnam war was
um
what am i to say except that you know it
still goes on you know
what do we call um he just called what
was this atrocity that was going on at
the border he initially
called it it's it's their fault you know
it's that we you know these people are
coming to rob us and steal this it's all
language but he's not good at it
um
jack kennedy was good at it very good at
it jack kennedy started a lot lyndon
johnson wasn't that good at it
um but kennedy was good at it kennedy
was great at it kennedy was he he made
the first plunge into the war
and um to this day i don't know
you know is the people all say i wrote a
book about kennedy that dealt a lot with
the war but unfortunate fortunately i
learned a lot about other stuff from the
secret service so that became the
identification for the book but there's
about 18 chapters about
about assassinations that he was
involved in with his son and with his
brother rather that they knew about
compromises made by investigations um
scorched earth policies that were
described as they say but pacification
and removal this is exactly what
orwell's talking about we did in vietnam
uh and uh it just
so it goes you went back to
milai about three years ago i didn't
want to go back ever
you know but you know
is where i cut i made my first fame and
as i said my my wife and my my kids
the dog the cat the gerbil the mice all
the animals buried in the backyard
wanted me to go back
so after
after some years i finally did
it was very uh
um i wrote a piece for uh for the new
yorker about it
um
uh you can't what you
what i don't say in describing
there's a couple chapters there more
detail than ever about doing the story
uh what he's talking about there if if
you read
uh the
the what's his name the great
investigation done by shaw by um
uh if you read the the church groups
that publish stuff in the 60s about what
was going on in the vietnam
and if you if you if you just read some
of the stuff um um
that that was being published
particularly in europe about the war
you knew there was something really
wrong and i was also learning ojt but
being in the pentagon
as a reporter and i ran into big
troubles with them
the ap about it because
they were lying the the mcnamara was
lying about bombing
we didn't have satellites then we'd and
i i learned they were bombing lying
about it in harrison souls where he had
gone to
uh to uh vietnam and he was accused of
being a traitor because he wrote about
the bombing you saw and if you read i
also read uh what was it i want to say
george bernard show but it's wrong the
the great in the great
russell tribunal right um
yes bertrand russell which was debunked
in america
bitterly i remember reading this
i read it in 66 or 67 it just came out
that a big volume nobody in america paid
much attention but they had a section on
vietnam
a kid they had three boys testify from
from um
home from cleveland there was 65 march
of 65 where
johnson's not
there's lying there's lying that that
that
that the orange man does
and there's lying that johnson did
johnson spent much of 65 saying he's not
going to send boys there by march he had
boys there
and he when the marines went there in
the summer he still lied about it i mean
that's quite a lie to the american
people but anyway the first group that
went in there in march they said that we
would go in a village in an army unit
with tanks and mortars and they go in a
village and they would thought they'd
find the enemy there it's such a story
it's the same story as three years later
in milan and they find nobody there
and then to be frustrated and enraged
because they can't find the enemy and
yes at night somebody would take a shot
and kill somebody there'd be a sniper
there they'd fall into a pit with bamboo
sticks and stuff like that and they were
losing people but they didn't have
contact and so what the the captain of
this one person's unit said okay
they went on a mission and they began
this process if they didn't find any
real enemy everybody could just have a a
mad minute
and the door gunner and the guy shooting
rockets on the tanks and the guys would
go and hang with the just rifles and the
guys with machine gun could just shoot
up anybody in the village
to shoot what they call the hooches i
mean they were full of people but that's
okay they had a mad minute
and
that was slow that was i knew it was so
and so
um
it's just
it's tough and so that's what made me
believe the milai story because i had i
had done when i got a tip i just got a
tip out of nowhere
and the thing about me like that i as i
started to say i don't tell in this
story
i am writing about myself but there's
some things that are just too hard to
deal with
i've i thought about i finished the book
months ago and i've spent months you
know fact checking it and doing what you
do and i had great
it was published by kenhoff and the the
staff there was as good as the new
yorker in terms of fact checking and and
copy editing it was really good stuff it
was a great place to be and it was all
serious and we worked hard on it
but what i didn't talk about was when i
first got a tip from a lawyer named jeff
collins his father was luke had been
head of
cbs news
uh a decade earlier and he was working
it was alien law school he was working
for the first public policy
non-profit law firm doing social stuff
in washington
he said he had told me and called me in
69 18 months after milan
and said
i've um
i've heard that some
gi is going crazy and there's a big
massacre there hiding and there's some
off 75 people were killed my nose is
running so i'm going to just wipe it
there you go
i mean you don't have kleenex here and
so what am i going to do so anyway
i can pretend it's not
i sat next to a kid one day who had a
cold and kept on blowing his nose in his
shirt
and then i remember that's what mothers
tell kids to do so i couldn't get mad at
them but they didn't like it
whoa
no it's too fancy it's got a it's got
it's oh oh no you from john give it i
can that's my editor
he's been cleaning up after me
for for two years on this project
now he's now literally what else you
gonna do just gonna put that back on you
so that okay hear every word you say
oh yeah yeah
uh is is this the kind of crowd that
will come up to me i've spoken to groups
of lot more than this and gotten done
and everybody came up to me and they
said none of us could hear anything no i
think
so if in the back you can't hear
something no no no i think you can you
can hear right i did i did a talk
earlier today a bunch of journalists who
started screaming right away we can't
hear we can't hear so that's but okay
anyway no they can hear you so i start
out doing this story
and i'm thinking ah okay it's going to
be a good story about the killing a lot
of people and then i discover and i'm
learning it as i do it that's not about
some pretend combat stuff they go into a
village of civilian that they they've
been stupidly told by bad intelligence
from a cia guy actually
a cia contract employee was an idiot um
like all the guys where they were hiring
people left to right
you know
pinkerton cops working part-time would
join the cia and be sent to a province
to be in charge of intelligence i mean
it was comical just comical
no murderous they told this group of
kids who had done nothing they were just
farm kids
and this unit in particular had a higher
percentage of african-americans and
hispanic than most units but and the
white kids were
rural kids not educated
and marginally educated mcnamara lowered
the standard because
by 67 too many bright white kids with
college degrees were beginning to get in
the army and seeing what's going on and
not liking it i mean so he realized we
got to get these out as when i worked
for senator mccarthy when he was running
for president i didn't know whether he
was so definite and so difficult but and
i didn't know if i was going to do it i
was offered a job as press secretary and
he needed somebody to write speeches too
he just was winging stuff
and what he said to me what he said in
the first speech i listed him to talk to
about vietnam this is in late 67 when
bobby kennedy went run against johnson
the democratic party was up in arms and
they couldn't get anybody to challenge
johnson for the nomination
and
he gave a speech and he said
he said two things that knock me out and
he never was anything but difficult i do
write about him in a way i've never done
before
he's dead and it's okay it wasn't all
perfect with him he's tough guy
he said
that
this is an immoral war
he'd been in a monastery learned later
he i could never talk about very
religious went to mass every day and i
could never talk about it to anybody in
the media that was his business he spent
nine months in silence in a a
benedictine monastery in
uh in minnesota
uh where he was born and he said this is
immoral i'm just debating whether i'm
going to do this i was a freelance
writer i was offered this job and i
couldn't do it in the press
the
the ap finally
did me in by i was writing about the war
very more and more critically and one
day there was a mcnamara gone nuts about
something i wrote
and went to the head of the ap and the
next thing and i was reassigned from the
pentagon to health and human services
that i took the hint
um you understand that
guys like me as i later learned
uh my job essentially was to walk into
editor's office with a dead rat full of
lice
i've said this many times no because i
do believe it dump it on their desk
and say
okay this is a story that's going to
take a lot of time it may not work and
it's going to get you people that want
to sue you and people that hate you and
all that and after a little while it
gets counterproductive in any case
mccarthy said he said two things he said
it's an immoral war and he also said
he's changing he's talking about johnson
and lowing the standards he said he's
changing the color of the corpses
from white to more
hispanic yellow and black he's changing
the color
man i was knocked out i've never heard
such talk you don't hear anybody talk
about morality anymore
so
um i did go to work for him anyway
what happened to in milai they were told
they were going to meet the enemy there
a mythical unit that that does exist a
north the 48th north vietnamese
the battalion that used to fight
americans they fought in the central
highlands but they weren't in this part
of vietnam along the coast
beautiful coast
and instead they found
about 560 men women and children making
uh heating up rice for the morning
breakfast
and they began to slaughter them
and
i'm learning this ojt i said i'm
learning this i didn't know i just knew
that something happened i'm beginning to
talk i find the kids that did it and i
eventually find the tender cali
and i eventually
find
[Applause]
i eventually find
um
the people who did the killing a man
named paul medlo who later went on
television
and what they were doing that they
couldn't bear
they were throwing infants up and
catching them on bayonets
and they were raping like crazy
everything everything every from five to
fifty
just going nuts and some of that stuff
was just
wow i'd been in the army
i thought this is it
and you know we were
we were censored in world war ii
we didn't know what really happened
there's a wonderful academic at yale i
forgot his name it's like seth soon the
poet but i forgot his name he published
a book about censorship
and so here i am
um
when i was a kid my sisters used to take
my brother and me in in the end of world
war ii
to the victory theater in chicago on the
south side of chicago where we'd see the
war movies which were propaganda and the
one i remember i remember today errol
flynn and john wayne it begins with
they're having a fight over a nurse in
the officers club in the pacific they're
fighting the nips who flew the zeroes
you don't remember world war ii our boys
flew p-51s the cadillac of the sky as
has that wonderful rotor writer uh he
wrote these great books i can't remember
his name described it anyway
um a british writer um who wrote these
anyway um
my wife will tell me tomorrow what it is
we do that anyway um
and
uh in in the movies i saw
uh uh flynn and and and and um
john wayne were had terrible fist fight
over a nurse and the next day they're
flying against the nips and a nip is on
the tail of john wayne at the last
minute arrow flynn saves his life by
shooting a lot of bullets another hot
picks and our boys
in the movies i saw we flew with the
canopy open
our guys had white scars no hats going
like this
right maybe sunglasses their guys had
the canopy clothes
buck teeth
they wore these little hats that soft
leather maybe you didn't grow up in the
north in chicago in the winter my mother
used to make it these little soft
helmets
that under you tied under the chin you
sort of tied it with a bow tie we we
hated those things they wore those kind
of helmets big glasses and the bullets
would fly in and the plane would go down
and i remember you could hear it was
very primitive stuff but it looked as
good as star wars did to the kids of
today's age i'm telling you back then
and just before the the nip hit he was
he was shot and just before he hit the
water
but this is literally what i remember a
trickle of blood would come out of the
corner of his mouth and he hit the water
and die and we'd all go nuts
so that was
my definition of world war ii
white you know we flew around thumbs up
scarves white scars and it turns out
we don't fight wars any better than
anybody else does and i'm going to start
telling the american people that in a
story i knew what i was up about i knew
i was this is not going to be easy as i
got into it as i got into it
and in one case
i there was a boy who had done most of
the shooting i was writing stuff i
couldn't get anybody to buy it and i
eventually wrote it for an anti-war news
service called dispatch news that
actually people don't know was much more
confident
they had reporters in vietnam who
covered the war but they knew vietnamese
and so i'm there's a i learned there's a
kid named paul medlo a farm kid
not not
not overwhelmingly and just a kid didn't
know much much education not bright
uh but
uh cali had told them to shoot in the
ditch
they lined up kids most of the shooting
was just there were three companies and
two of the companies just killed
wherever they could kelly was an
organizer let's put them all in a ditch
there's a famous picture of the dish i
went back to look at the ditch
not easy to do believe me
not easy to do
anyway
so me the he was a couple of boys flew
shot a couple rounds that clip i
something like 17 bullets in the m1 it's
autumn semi-automatic you press the
button it keeps on going
and and he shots clip after clip and the
next day at his leg blown off
and it was pretty famous in the unit
because he
they were just marching around going on
another patrol they had lied about
everything what happened it was just
another day in the war there was no such
thing in this war as murder there was a
violation of rules that violated the
rules you know anyway that's that's my
explanation of vietnam and all the
torture and all the killing that went on
anyway
so the next day is medevac out and it's
stuck in the kid's mind
and what i remember is i somebody gave
me a company roster for thanksgiving
they were still in schofield barracks in
hawaii they didn't get to vietnam until
january the me life took place in march
of 68 i'm a year and a half year later a
lot of the boys are home by then they
did two years there
one year combat one year out so they're
home i'm doing it from america
but it was m-e-a-d-l-o and i remember i
was in salt lake i don't remember where
you had to put dimes in for information
or nickels but i had a pile i called
every telephone exchange i knew some
indiana and finally in terre haute there
was one in the place called new goshen
and i call up i get this old southern
voice it's right next in the deep south
the kkk was there you know in the 1920s
that part lower indiana
right next to the illinois border and i
have no idea where it is and i fly from
i was in salt lake i fly to chicago and
i fly to minneapolis and i get a car and
there's no gps i go to terre haute and
this town is called negotia
and i called up the night before and i
said i'm coming i did it overnight and i
said i just assumed meadlow was the only
one i could find me a dlo i said hi uh
how's your son's foot she said well he's
doing all right with it and i said um
he's back from the war she said yes
that's the way i figured out and paul's
he's there leaving he just said yes he's
married and he lives in the he's here
here can i come talk to him about the
war she said i don't know if he'll talk
to you but you so i was blind
she said i don't know
and so i fly there and i get i finally
get to this farm it's a whole rundown
farm there's chickens all these chicken
coops with the wires gone you know it's
just like i don't know what paul's doing
her husband died earlier i learned that
later and i park in front
and i've got this ratty suit you know
like this ready shirt all sweaty and um
i started early today and
i um i don't change shirts twice a day
so anyway
and so um
i know people do so um
and so i pull up and she comes out and
she's
50 but she looks 70.
and i said hi i'm mr hersh the guy that
called she said yes and i said is paul
there around she said well he's in there
and then this old woman who's not read a
newspaper
doesn't know much she said
about her son about the war she said
i sent them a good boy and they sent me
back a murderer
i mean
you're dealing in
i don't know where you are deal i'm just
like
i don't know what to think so i
go see the kid
and he remember what you thought
the first thing i thought was
i was gonna go say hello to him and say
to him
take off your boot and show me your leg
i want to see the stump he's lost his
leg
and i just know
i just always had a sense that if
there's somebody with an affliction you
know who's you know i say what's what's
going on what's happening there i don't
want to pretend it's not there
i always try to do that it's just i
think people get comfortable if you say
you know
you know
you don't say things like you know you
don't have one leg or something like
that
you do it politely and so i just said i
just figured the hell with it i'm not
going to ask him questions at first and
he showed me his leg
and i said how long did it take
i later got a letter from somebody after
i did this story years later from i got
two rage and i did milai
he was taken from that field with the
blown off leg was blown up pretty high
and he was eventually evacuated so he
went to emergency hospitals and then he
was eventually flown to japan where he
spent five months relearning things he
was slow to get he wasn't as quick and
in rehabilitation
and
the fellow whose bunk was next to him
for three months another guy that was
shot wrote me a letter in the early 70s
i've kept it i don't that's a private
letter so i don't i didn't put it in the
book i mean i i have no idea how to
reach him and he said i sat next i slept
next to paul paul milo for two and a
half three months
and he was comatose
he never said a word not one word
and then i began to get letters when
milai would there was a book published
and it was a a
random house did a book bob loomis was a
wonderful editor who did a book
and i got letters from doctors young
doctors working in japan
and this is later in 70 and 71 when the
war was going bad
and nobody wanted to do what the
officers wanted you had um you had a
major black movement you had american
boys nobody wanted to be the last guy
shot and what was a losing crappy war
that nobody cared about
and a young officer coming out of west
point would say we're going to go on
patrol tomorrow you guys don't want to
go everybody's out and he would get shot
in the back
they said these doctors said i got two
three letters saying we're seeing four
or five
a month coming in with bullet holes in
the back some we can't we can't keep
them alive right out of west point
you know it's just amazing stuff
and anyway so
um
orwell orwell i a stone i was ready for
all those guys i want to talk to you
about the cia spying
let's jump to
december 22nd 1974
look at image four
what's two and three like
um we might you might get them you might
that's a very good question
ah there it is there it is
cia of operation reported in u.s against
anti-war forces other dissidents in
nixon years
um
if you can comment on this on this and
also how you got so much
space
because that story is actually it's
there's a lot of it in the book about it
because when i started first thing when
you for a lot of reasons i i i i had
done i had a contract for canal for a
book on cheney for a lot of reasons
having to do with protecting people who
are still in career intelligence people
and you never wanted to give
i just can't i couldn't do the book
because
a typical thing
i
cheney you know there was some talk
about how they people viewed the
constitution as a nuisance
cheney the torture stuff he was running
without telling the congress
and he was paying for it with billions
of dollars that he was parking
in various banks
and i know where and who and how it
works this is a complete violation of
the constitution
and
the people that know this stuff
if
he knows who knows the stuff he's out
he's alive so i don't know what i'm
going to do but anyway it doesn't matter
so i and this came became out of because
i couldn't do that book and it was very
kind of my publishers and john siegel my
editor all said
my handkerchief man
new title for him uh they all said that
uh
um
um
um uh they said do a memoir and the
first thing i learned realized what you
really didn't want to do well i'm not
done
i'm gonna do it i'm gonna do another one
more in 10 years and say post
volume 2
i don't think so don't worry about it
but that was my concern i kept on saying
i love like
turns out legendary you can be alive and
be legendary but it makes me a nervous
word you know everyone's legendary
reporter i'm not dead you know what i
mean anyway so anyway so
so what happened is
um in doing the book there are a couple
things about it legendary also might
mean that people don't need to pay
attention
that's a definition i don't like
it's a technically one you own 1918 oed
you're one of those guys
uh you know i mean you know i mean
that's that's um that's interesting
um
anyway
uh
words are interesting when you have a
president that doesn't understand what
words mean
you're in real trouble you know
george bush was that way words had no
meaning to him so this guy takes it to a
new level
there's just words don't he doesn't
understand words they don't mean
anything that's why you can say i didn't
say that ten minutes later and it's been
a transcript he said anyway it doesn't
matter it's it's troublesome for a
president but that's okay
we will survive this that's what i'm
saying we will you know the republic
will will stand if we have to get rid of
him we'll do it but so far
his turnaround yes the ceremony means
he's dead set to run again
and the democrats better think of some
policies instead of if they're going to
do what hillary did and run against this
guy as a bad guy it's going to be
trouble but anyway going back
to uh
so so you call it well what did i do
well no it's
it's actually a great story about the
new york times because
uh
i learned about
this stuff about the spying
i learned something about it two years
early
and i didn't tell anybody it turns out
the cia did a history of william kobe
and watergate there's a chapter on me in
the history i read a lot about in the
book in which it turned out the ca was
tracking me ask questions about it from
1972 on i learned about it when i first
joined the cia when i first joined the
times i was doing vietnam stuff
and for two years i was asking questions
about it
and they were worried to death about me
but i didn't know that it's it's it's in
it's a it's a it was a declassified
study 500 400 pages written by a very
bright ci analyst about the history with
all these intercepts and phone
conversations i had for two years
and so here's the story meanwhile i'm
i'm i'm you know uh
i'm using anonymous sources but
rosenthal used to ask me who the sources
are and he'd stop same with
same with david remnick he would stop at
a certain point because
i have
i named one of them in the book and the
one i named i got the family was fine
with it his sons were fine with it he
was a special assistant to richard helms
the head of the cia for four years and
he ran he was deeply involved in
domestic spying before that i mean
you don't get sources like that and when
you get something it's there's nothing
better than a guy inside who decides at
a certain point i can't live with this
anymore
and then that's what you need you don't
need a guy inside that's we're going to
make the boss how do you how do you
sniff them how do you know they come to
me sometimes
they come to me people sick people know
that i'll take care of them i don't i
don't i haven't heard anybody
i haven't heard anybody yet and that's
why i don't do certain things i should
do i could do it's troublesome to me
anyway the point is
i don't told nobody in the times and i'm
the go boy i'm the golden boy i'm
running around winning prizes doing all
this stuff
and in december the 20th i saw william
kobe the head of the cia
and i i finally went down i agreed to
see me in the morning i went through a
list
and at this point
he didn't know how much i knew he they
knew i'd been working stuff but he was
getting a sniff that i may knew more
there was something called the family
jewels
and it was the next day after i saw him
on the 20th that he asked somebody it
was all there tapes of all this he asked
the
the number two guy in the justice
department he said did hirsch ever talk
to you about stuff he said yes he talked
about somebody called the jewels and the
next day
he learned i knew about the jewels but
the day before he talked to me he said
well we did some wiretaps but he
minimized the numbers he didn't deny
anything
and for the cia
after 9 11
i um
well the cia's job is to lie
that's their job that's what they do for
a living that's what they do just a lie
that's all you have to understand i
don't understand they do some wonderful
things too but basically they're there
to lie about what they do
they hurt people they do things they
make mistakes
and um uh
they'll acknowledge fda will never
acknowledge mistake they this the
different culture of the ca is sort of
like swash
swashbucklers you know well we screwed
that up but okay we'll go kill somebody
else and wake up for it or whatever it
is so i told a rosenthal the editor of
the times who had hired me i was working
believe it or not for the new yorker
from 70 to 72. i couldn't get a job in a
newspaper after working for mccarthy
because i was tainted because i was my
politics were left because i was against
the war i made the judgment about the
war purely on the basis that the war was
bad for america it had nothing to do
with my personal politics it was a mess
and we're going to all be in disastrous
trouble by 1969 i knew how bad it was
anyway i knew earlier and so
i call a roosevelt on december the 20th
2019 19 1974 and i said about 11 o'clock
in the morning after seeing colby i
stopped
they see is right by a highway called
123. there's no cell phones and i went
to a gas station there and called them
on a pay phone collect i'm sure
and i said i've got to tell you about a
story i've been working on it's about ca
spying on my americans what are you
talking about i said it's a big story
they've been spying on americans
he said
what and i said yes he said well go
write it i said okay
so i went to the office
about 11 o'clock and i spent two or
three hours
calling everybody and i called up people
in high up in the ca whose names had
never been known but here's the thing
the wonderful about the cia in those
years
there's phone books then
and usually the wife's name was in the
phone book you know because she want to
get calls from the garden club or
whatever it is you know people live they
live
and i i could find a lot of people just
in the phone book it wasn't magic and
some of them were and i talked to a
bunch of people that they even tried ed
musky because
he wanted to run for president sandy
berger who later worked his national
security advice for bill clinton was his
hey sandy's a good guy i called up sandy
and i said
i know he wants he's running for
president i've got a story that could
help him and sandy
he told me about it this is saturday
this is friday this is the same day i
told a friday the 20th this is two days
before the story ran
and
sandy calls me back a couple hours later
says ed's
he doesn't he doesn't want to take a
chance on this you know
of course that's why he won the
presidency remember anyway
john kerry when john carrier is running
in 2004
i had the same issue with him uh i had
done abu ghraib about the torture and i
wondered i was at a dinner with and i
like john and john was one of the
veterans who threw through rocks
and i remember
the issue was whether he should go out
against the war and attack it and he
decided to instead
to uh run on his record as an officer
that's what literally what he did and
not go after the war you thought that
was a better way to operate and of
course that that won in the election too
yeah
anyway
anyway the point going back to it so i
went to the office i'm calling people
and i have to tell you i called six or
seven major people in the cia that day
and said i always do this i said i know
what you've been doing
and they all a couple called they all
said they all said initially what and i
said engleton who is the head of
counterintelligence then a very
complicated man james jesus angleton who
i talked to quite a bit about this
and i said angleton said you were
helping to run the the problems of
spying on american students over 100 000
files they had they were spying on
americans but i never could get to the
big person they were looking at was
stokely carmichael who was killed in
that process murdered and i always
wondered i just never got to it but i
got to a lot of stuff
i mean it was a big story
and
nobody said to me you're not using my
name of course because i was given
i knew the game so i had sev i named
seven sources without saying they're
seven different people
so i write this story
and i'm writing and i go home for dinner
for a hot meal and go back
i'm about two or three in the morning
this is in the book and i'm
if you ask me about it i'm just going to
spin it off short
but and
i'm called by an editor at the times a
guy named ev jenkins who was when they
ran the sunday paper was the big paper
for the times
that particular sunday paper i looked up
later had 574 pages in it
i mean you were talking about a
newspaper was making money like you
couldn't believe and they were the
salzburgers were great they kept
they wouldn't make more than one and a
half to two percent profit the rest went
into people like me running around and
going to good hotels
and flying on business i mean that's the
way it was then it's much different now
and so
i'm writing and and the guy that got us
making up the sunday paper the first 600
000 copies i think uh there's something
there was some early they had to make
airplanes to get to the west coast and
all that to be available on sunday the
new york times it was a it's a still
powerful national paper
and he said well abe said you're writing
a story but he thought it was going to
be about 2500 words and we have no space
and i said what he said well
do you want can we hold it a day or two
and i said what
you know it's like
it's like he was a good guy but he's his
job was to put out the sunday paper and
he didn't have space for it there were
so many ads he couldn't and so i of
course went nuts
anyway i tracked down a rosenthal which
is a complicated story in itself
because
because he
i didn't i don't socialize with editors
that's just a good rule i i think it
shortens you know it's it lengthens my
life
and so
i didn't know much about abe i met his
wife his name was ann and it's 2 30 in
the morning i'm being told at this story
and i said to ev read it
this is gonna this is gonna knock the
cia
into hell
they've been spying on american
wiretapping and following them tracking
journalists keeping files on americans
worrying about anti-communists and
disloyal americans if it was a story
about the fbi would say hello
congratulations to doing the job but the
cia was only allowed to spy overseas
they couldn't do anything in america are
you kidding me big thousands of hundreds
of people that work in this big and we
said this is the end death now
he said i don't i can't help you i don't
know what to do
so i called up ann
who i met once
and it phone rings a long time it's 2 30
in the morning
and
she answers the phone finally the second
time i let it ring the first time she
didn't have one of this breakdown i
ranked 10 times and then i rang 10 more
times
and i said
i had to go find in a desk i was alone
in the bureau there's nothing more fun
than being alone in a major newspaper
office like the new york times just me
and a guy that teletype us it's you feel
like you own the world there's still
lights and there's still heat or air
conditioning but you're just there
nobody talking to me nobody bothering me
i've had an office since 1991. even
though i'm gary-less obviously when i
get out of it but in my space i don't
say anything
except to myself so anyway and so
i call her up and i said i gotta talk
dave i gotta talk dave she said what do
you mean i said i got talked to abe she
said don't you know he's left me for
that nasty word about some other lady
he's left me three months ago
i said what
she said that son of a [ __ ] whatever
she said
she was mad and she hung up it was 2 30
in the morning too
i thought to myself i'm in a soap opera
but
then i thought
this story has got to go
this story is more important than
somebody so i call her back
and she answered
and i said ann you've been a reporter's
wife for 30 years
and let me tell you what the story is
about
as i told a little bit it's a story that
you'd be very proud of abe being the
editor of and you'd be very proud as an
american citizen
i need to know the name of the person
he's stacking up with
and she gave it to me because she wanted
that story in the paper i mean
i mean i guess right she was a an
editor's wife she had to
have some feeling for the institution
and at the institution of the times at
times is an institution where you do
have a feeling for it and
then i had a problem because this person
was one of those people that
because of what she did for a living
wasn't wasn't in the phone book
so i had i had published some books and
i had an agent and i had to call my
agent
who had somebody in his office who did
handle those people and had phone
numbers
and so this took a lot of people getting
woken up and i got a number of this
person's home just now it's about 3 15.
and meal i'm going nuts i'm still
writing i'm about 4 000 words in this
story i don't know how long it was going
to go stories novelists talk about
characters taking over
but i had been working on this story for
two years i was worried about getting
enough
to make it go and i needed enough and
kobe gave me the imprimatur
he said kobe said there weren't 142
american reporters wiretap more like 40
or 50. you know he thought
he thought he
as he later wrote it no more he thought
he'd count me down but he didn't he
didn't know how much i knew more than
that because i did know more than i told
him i'm you know i'm not in the business
of telling everything i know to
see either obviously
not i am here because you know
um uh memoirs are interesting turns out
it's sort of nice writing about yourself
but anyway but you have to go back it
turns out everything you think happened
didn't happen that way so it's a lot of
work too i had to go back and read
anyway the point is you talk about that
in the memory well how hard it is to go
back and find out that you were wrong
about things and when people are dead
it's really more complicated so i would
i mean but you know you can really do a
lot and the land and farm remember i
came here a couple years ago and and
yeah and um what's his name
tom lennon took me to the finals
his second wife was mad at the times and
didn't give his papers back to the times
they gave it back to you guys and
there's stuff on me big files on me i
know and it filled in so many it's so
interesting so i'll always come anytime
roll a quarter down the street anyway
free coffee so
i i got the unlisted number
and i did dial it nobody answered cut
off after five i dialed it again if i
had a second i was going to dial it for
weeks and finally she answered the phone
and i said look lady i don't care what's
going on there i know abrasive throws
there i know he's there telling me he's
got to talk to me i beg your pardon i
said just get abe and there's a long
sign that he gets on the phone
and abe was
as i as i said i've said a couple of
times and giving talks
abe abe hired me from the new yorker and
i asked william shawn if i could go if
i'd be all right and william shawn
he liked me a lot he wanted me to be
stay he was the famous editor of the new
york i'd done stuff for him i'd done a
long take out and he
i got along with him but he said you i
need you at the time we need you he said
you could do more for america at the
times than you can for me
i'm a weekly i have a lot of other
reporters and you can be in there and
just do it he said and you'll be i said
well i'd be fine and he said to me this
wonderful man said you'll be fine
and i still i i wrote anonymous stuff
for him too when the times wouldn't let
me write stuff i wrote some anonymous
stuff i always stayed friendly with him
and um
and anyway
um
so
i abe gets on the phone
and i go so i go blah
he says you know
he said
he said first thing he said was
okay he said
where are you i'm in the bureau he said
what's your phone number on hello i know
i'm sitting at somebody's desk look at
the goddamn phone it's on the phone and
he called me names he was he was very
angry and i said it's 202
he said hang up don't do anything
five minutes later he calls up
and he says okay
he said before i say i just want to know
you will pay for this but in the short
one he said
he said he was really
he was let's put his way i never told
the story too well after he was dead
except a few of my friends
he said
tomorrow your kakamemi story
the new york times is going to have 1.6
million extra pages added to it
we're talking about he's not the
publisher he's the editor we're going to
add one we're going to put a page page
another page 11a and then the back is
going to be a house ad and you're 7 000
words that's all we could have 73 and
stop there they're going to be on that
page and now you have to understand
something
he knew you saw the banner headlines the
new york times doesn't do that i mean
they get those days the new york times
when they took on the caa the new york
times had the exact when i joined the
times they had the exact opposite view
of the cia
we were there to work with them on
stories they they buried a story in laos
i i went first thing i did was went to
the files
and they would they would do a big
series and there would be some notes
from editors and be sure to run this by
dick helms the head of the ca before we
publish it i mean what
you got to be kidding this is in in the
60s before i was there
and then
i saw that i mean in other words they
played
obedience to the leadership that's what
the times is a funny paper it's
it
it it feels
it's
it's this conflict i don't know how i
can say this in simple words
it feels it's an american paper
and i always thought it should be a
world paper
i always thought you shouldn't
have a big
do we do this to america and that's what
some of the instinct i was getting
people talk about
the problem i had changing a culture i'm
i'm not exaggerating when i said that
was the issue
they had to decide they're going to go
after a president
and without going and telling the going
and checking my story with the head of
the cia or the head of the white you
know he doesn't have to go with what i
had and so what happened here is
this is a day later saturday the they i
think it's an early closing 4 35 o'clock
for the first edition that's going to be
shipped abroad maybe six o'clock it's
now i went and fell as i went home and
slept a couple hours i come back
and
it wasn't
this is december 21. this is the new
york times
taking on
the cia on the basis of a kid named
hirsch
and rosen rosenthal used to come into
the office up behind me
when i was going hot and heavy i helped
him on watergate i didn't want to do
watergate but they were getting killed
and he was enraged at ben bradley being
more famous than he was and he
reassigned me from the ward on watergate
he needs to come up and do the bill
murray rub later the knuckle whatever
that was and he'd say how's my little
commie today
and then because he knew i was against
the war and openly about it the next
sentence would be what do you have for
me
this had been going on for a year and
you know he stopped asking me who the
sources were and every day i was a
there's a page in this paper one of the
one of the um
i was asked by a tv guy who interviewed
me a cable news guy
we talked a little bit i was on one of
these cable news show just a week ago or
two weeks in washington one of these um
one of these nightly shows that they do
the shiny shows everybody says i think
and this guy had and he had no idea what
the book was and we he asked me a little
bit about trump and then he says let's
talk about your book which is a strange
question because he didn't even have a
note from a producer saying ask him why
he did this or that
and i almost said well it's got i think
36 pages of pictures and a lot of words
but i didn't do it i didn't do it i said
something mumbled something well it's a
story about my life you know i mean it's
just this is what you have
you sound you're a little cut above that
paul a lot i want you to know that um
anyway the point is they ran that story
there was a debate i'll ask you another
question well let me just finish they
ran this story i didn't talk to the
lawyers abe said who aren't who they're
seven i named seven people who are they
they ran that story
uh
five hours ten hours after i finished
writing it and when you've that and so
no matter what i think i get mad at the
times in my house for years when after i
left the times they it's delivered to me
in the morning and one of those the real
creme de creme the subscribers who just
have they have my credit card that's
that's the real money in the bank seven
eight hundred thousand of us the rest of
this
the online stuff is nothing we're the
we're the guts the core we're the core
subscribers i've been that way since
what 63.
and i used to rant i ran rave about the
times why didn't they do this why did
you do that but for to do that the
roosevelt led to the church hearings
that the first investigation led to the
first time congress invented two
committees to the house and senate
intelligence committees to oversee
intelligence we didn't have it before
it's blown apart now by the craziness
between the democrats and republicans
there's no oversight anymore it's
disappeared and i that which is not good
for the republic not good for any of us
but it led to that and he did it on a
story
that you know it was barely it was copy
edited
but you know that's all
i mean when you have an editor with that
much trust in you
and that they're called
all my difficulty with abe
but you you can't walk away from this
it was as i say it was the most amazing
time because
we we had a president that was no one
relieved on anything this guy is still
believed in some foreign stuff which to
me is crazy and you shouldn't believe on
anything simply what he says about it
yes he did to korea yes but you saw him
there you believe him
nixon was still running the war
and he lost any capability between 72
and and the the moment that ford came in
we set the agenda we the collective
press
we were writing it we were the truth
tellers more than the white house
there's never been a time like that
again it was a thrilling time
you were you you said a little earlier
that it was a pleasure in some way to
write about yourself um but
the book that you're currently writing
or the book that is currently
in my head yeah about dick cheney it's
about
cheney today
cheney started something
there's a something called the watson
institute at brown university
and
it's a a study group that's run includes
people like a wonderful former
ambassador to china named charles
freeman who's if you don't read his book
image number two but anyway anyway
what's that
what's image number two i'm curious
what about what about image number 10.
are we going to get out of here
yes
okay
76 countries
right now
and
cheney developed the notion that you
could operate
without congress knowing anything and
you didn't have to fund it you found
ways to fund it and what he did he was
very creative and by 2004 there was a
system set up that i know too much about
right now that i couldn't write about
we're in 76 countries right now most of
them in africa
um i want to tell you when you read
about four guys getting killed in mali
and a mission i mean if you want to
believe it i got a bridge i want to sell
you they're out of control the special
operations people are out of control
they're led by a general
who does there's a lot of
they're they're very christian
mcchrystal was very christian he was a
disciple of rudolf steiner if you know
schneider's work who was one basically
um
the notion
steiner did a lot of things but one of
them was the notion that um
we're here to fight the infidels this is
the 13th century and what happened in
nine what happened in 911
uh with the the killing uh
we should right we should we were we the
christians in the special forces are
going to fight the uh the masses of the
arab world who want to destroy us and
cheney bought into that notion the
notion that you can fight something
called a war on terror you can fight an
id against you can fight a war against
an idea
instead of humiliating the process of
the reasons there's people hate us it's
just beyond and so it's it may not be
possible to do it because it's i run
into problems
because there's so much stuff that we
don't know about and this administration
is keeping completely incapable of
getting control
there is a general name mattis who who
has ideas about doing it but it's
complicated there's so many other things
i'd like to ask you but yeah we won't
it's midnight yeah yeah it's midnight
but um but a a couple of a couple of
surprises
uh if you could look at anybody with
babysitter problems if we if we could if
we could look at image number five
um i
i was kidding about post four
is it gonna work
no
that is
come on tell me i don't remember
well
it's interesting
no it's interesting who is that guy i'll
tell you
it's george saunders
oh george
i gave a talk with him that was a long
time ago it's george saunders and i
asked him to send me a question
um for you
you know what i wrote about him i told
you i wrote about him i said george
saunders
could rate it could white write his way
out of a mengele experimental lab
and um which is the highest compliment i
can give anybody
and i i interviewed he i interviewed him
a couple of months ago he's one of the
most extraordinary people i've ever
spoken god i didn't recognize yeah and
that was a long time yeah and i'll tell
you exactly he said well you could start
out by saying that i believe he's one of
the great minds and spirits of our time
he's speaking about you i have fond
memories of meeting him at the harper's
magazine
175th anniversary party back in 2000 and
keep for inspiration of a framed photo
of the two of us chatting at that event
my simple
easy to answer question how has our
democracy and culture changed in the
years since he first started writing
about us
and as a quick follow-up
[Laughter]
what is the meaning of life's side
he's he's having fun with that
um how in the hell do i know it's too
complicated george or always
george
uh he i knew him from his short stories
and uh i was at the new yorker then and
i was of course
i mean
if you can't appreciate george sanders
you can't appreciate that we just had a
tour of some great writing in one of
your one of your uh
collection yes one of your collections
amazing stuff
and he's in that league he's just in
that special league where he can he he
takes things to another level and the
imagination
so i can't
look we as i'm just going to say what i
said earlier
um
we'll get through this
we will get through this
we will get through this
i wish
i i
i i don't see
the white knight on the on the horizon
i don't see we saw
we saw obama by 2005 we saw him we saw
obama we could see him coming you know
he you know we could see we could see
that there was hope there
for 2008 when kerry lost which election
he shouldn't have lost i
and uh
we could see
some we could see some somebody coming
that made
i don't see it you know i when i talk to
my i have political pals and they talk
about the guy sherwood brown maybe but
i i don't see him as as so you tell me
what's going to happen and then is it
going to be maybe some woman is going to
come out a lot of women are running for
congress and the major media don't do
enough my son my youngest son works for
vice news and they have a show in which
they've been tracking some of these
young women
running these young complete outlanders
and they're doing great there's a lot of
women now that and um it seems
um uh there's somebody running in
virginia i know
the wife of a journalist friend of mine
a british friend and there's a lot of a
lot of um she's an american she can't be
running in america unless he was anyway
there's a lot of um
there's something different in the air
and i think the democratic party
is going to have to be broken up
bang the way
we're going to have to have new
leadership and it's going to have to be
it's not you know
bernie sanders did a public service
there's no question and hillary did a
disservice by
taking control of the party and making
sure he didn't get a chance that that's
we all know that happened with the
debbie wasserman schultz was that her
name
um making sure that the five five
debates they had were on a sunday night
or on a monday night football night or
at a strange place at a strange time
that was all delivered we all know that
now the idea was to freeze them out
and make sure that hillary won the
election
um
which is i don't think that's an
overstatement at all
and uh to obama's i i fault obama for
letting her do it she also bled the
party dry she took a lot of money that
should have been put into the into the
local elections since you put it into
the uh campaign against um
in closing you have said um
um
what does that mean that word those
phrases um another oxford oed book uh oh
in closing in closing does that mean
shut up no um
no it means i want you to answer
something else i can't answer george's
question because he knows he always
poses things in such complicated ways
it's fine that's fine uh he he he will
maybe maybe you'll have a chance to
answer
when he please tell him i didn't
recognize him don't i don't i didn't do
not tell him that no but he's older he
might see this i don't he might be
watching right now um you say i will
happily
permit history to be the judge
of my recent work oh yeah
and
i did stuff on
i've done this stuff i did something i'm
fascinated by libya
and what happened in libya with all the
oil
and i i did stuff for i couldn't get it
in american press they just
i honestly think that
part of me thinks that
i was writing stuff that if bush had
still been president cheney probably
would have been easy to do but it was
hard to believe
that the democrats in 2012 could be
secretly working to support the isis the
then
actually was al-nusra the extreme groups
against bashar assad
because if assad fell in syria it was
the country is going to be taken over by
people who believe in the most radical
form of sharia law we're going to
execute really literally killed people
who didn't agree with them even sunnis
fellow sunnis who didn't accept their
radical their radical practices and you
that was going to lead to an
immediate war from with iran iran was
not going to tolerate that and same with
israel
israel for all of its yapping got along
very well with the assad family because
they you know israel so you think you
you would be proven right
is that what you mean i think what do
you mean i think i was right
i don't have to be proven right by whom
um
by by including closing now but um
in closing now um
i i have the same sources i had when i
wrote all those other stories
i i i'm just saying and
one of the problems in america is i did
a lot for the london review of books
which a lot of american reporters think
it's one of those little tabloids they
give you in the in the in this in the
tube in the subway before you go in full
of ads you know they had no idea that
they they would hire new yorker fact
checkers
pay tons of money to fact check the
stories as as incredibly well um uh not
pay me as well as the new yorker there's
nothing like the new yorker but that's
the way it goes um and so
it's just that america begot too hard it
was just
it was um if i had to think about it it
probably had to do with the democrats
were in in some unconscious way that you
didn't want to believe that the
democrats would be really working
to support the crazies
and it was a story called about was
called the rat line and the red line in
the rat line
and another one was about bin laden
um if you want to believe that
i don't want to go there because it's
just
i could write more about it because i
know much more about it i've had people
from you sometimes feel the burden of
secrecy on you no i never feel the
burden secrecy is much more
burdens of my own word
i feel the obligation to people that
talk to me
you know what i did in that story when i
did it for the london review and it was
a they got their computers broke on the
story they got me in hits overnight on
that story the most amazing i mean the
magazine editor here just threw it away
it was because it was why in america no
all over the world it was why they
accepted
in the fourth graph one of the things
you don't do is you don't name you don't
name a station chief
if he hasn't even if he's been outed in
urdu as this guy was the station chief
in pakistan what the story was simply
somebody walked in and told us five
months before it happened that he was a
prisoner of the pakistani intelligence
service that's all that was the story
and the cia has a special team
they do they do interrogations
of you know this anybody who's a suspect
it was he was a pakistani high ranking
officer and there was a reward
there was 20 25 million bucks for
information he got 20 of it
and he moved to another country but i i
knew about that and i knew that started
a process that led to the killing of bin
laden he was a prisoner and we were very
angry at the pakistanis the pakistanis
didn't tell us because
they captured him in in
probably inside in in the area between
pakistan and india they captured him the
pakistanis
and they held him because
saudi arabia did not want him to be
put on trial he was a saudi he came from
a very prominent family and they paid a
lot of money a lot of money under the
table for years to keep him quiet
and so the station chief
was a very very competent guy
and a good serious guy and i didn't know
what to do
um
i wanted to telegraph
that i knew more than i'm writing
so i named them
i said they walked into him and then i
said a special team i didn't use the
code word for these kind of defectives
that come in there is a special unit
that just we're not just talking about a
lie detector there's a unit that really
can get to whether somebody's telling
you the truth or not i'm not talking
about paranormal stuff i'm talking about
just
very clever
deduction stuff and they're very
competent and i'm sorry he was handled
by a special unit and
and his name was george bank his name is
george bank and so here's what i thought
i said okay
they're going to go nuts about this the
white house what obama did
was he made
something that was a rote mission
into i did it why because the political
people said
this is re-election and he's a black guy
running for re-election and it was
important for him to be re-elected and i
thought so too i mean i could understand
when the story first i offered it at the
new yorker and there was hesitancy there
i waited till after the election
and then i did it because i
i'm stubborn i'm not gonna let a story
sit
and particularly one that there's just
no reason not to publish what you know
when i'm ready to anyway
so i thought
banks was known inside by a lot of
people as being a very high quality
person somebody who's going to rise high
and i thought if the agency wants to
blow him
and screw me to the wall
he's in the fourth graph of my story get
him to go on cnn cable and say that
story is just crazy i'm the station
chief nobody came in to me well he
didn't do it
and i thought some of the reporters
would figure out whoa i left a tell
there
there's a big tell about what what was
going i can i can tell you right now
there's a tell everybody's missing about
trump and what happened after the
election there's a big tell that
nobody's figured out yet this is a tale
as big as you want to make it
the guy i named the station chief and he
doesn't say boo he doesn't come on to
say and deny the story i mean that's
what you would do
but everybody was so when the story
first broke
and there was a big fight in the white
house about it because he had made a
commitment to the pakistanis not to talk
about it for a week or ten days and have
the body found in pakistan or in in in
afghanistan
nobody was supposed to know he was
living there he was living there as a
prisoner in secret nobody was supposed
to know we wanted him
and he had that pax the only thing the
pax intelligence service said is
um
take the body with you
you're going to kill him kill him you
had to kill him no trial take the body
with you and we are we also had to
supply an incredible amount of money to
all do what the saudis gave which we did
to some generals to keep their mouth
shut
and there's a process for doing it it's
which i know but i'll write in some
other books some other time there's a
way to do it the government's figured
out a way to do it involves oil anyway
and so
um
so i actually thought in my naivete but
what i didn't understand is the white
house was supposed to they sort of
double cross but you can understand he's
running for president and they have the
photograph of everybody going like this
and a lot for a lot of people that was
wait a second they're having all worried
about what it is you're going to take a
photograph of it why would you
photograph you don't photograph
situation room meetings i've been to the
situat once in a while it's a secret you
know come on so that's a that it was all
political i mean it's not even hard to
see if you remember the first stories
bin laden was hiding behind two women
with ak 20 you know our boys came in you
had to cover the sales because it was a
murder
the seals knew they were doing a murder
they were a little ashamed of it that's
their job it was just what they call it
a um they have a phrase they have an
ugly phrase for it of
some kind of a a [ __ ] it was some kind
of a
some kind of a [ __ ] it was it was one
you know and when a mission is just a
straight out
murder
you know
they do it that's their job and they
came in and they did the the hit
and there's a couple one of the tells
was they described in one of the books
about there there was a steel door
you know he was a prisoner and they blew
it and if you know anything i don't know
it but i learned steel doors if you blow
it with a dynamite charge and you don't
get you don't know these back exact
specific specifications of the the depth
of the steel that and the strength of
the steel you're going to kill yourself
because it's going to bounce back a bomb
even if you're down the hallway 30 feet
you're going to really get in trouble i
talked to a lot of
bomb guys and they said so you had to
know exactly within
who told them that only the isi took the
measurement for them and walked them in
the pakistani intelligence service
and so
um
what happens is that for the first day
the white first three four days they had
to roll back some of the stories they
said no he was
then they said he was watching porn
there was a picture of him watching porn
and he had nine hundred dollars in his
900 euros or something they told a lot
of stories they had to roll back one of
my favorite stories was everybody wanted
to get in briefings about the great
victory over bin laden i mean the war on
terror was going to end obama's going to
be re-elected one of them was
that us one of the seals brought a dog
in illegally and the dog was
went out when they were in the compound
doing the killing there was
one of the choppers exploded it crashed
and they had to bring in a release offer
and there was a big explosion and the
neighbors perhaps would be curious i
will tell you if you went and read the
urdu press about two or three weeks
after the raid they went and talked to
the neighbors all said the same thing we
were told that morning there was going
to be a lot of action there that night
close the window so don't talk to
anybody
and it's in the it's in the urdu press
well let me just say this so one of the
stories was
it was a us news one of the stories was
the seals brought a dog out there and
the dog was put outside to tell the and
if anybody got curious about what's
going on with those explosion to bark
and warn them off and i remember saying
a dog that barks in urdu
wow we can't beat this story
but i did i but it was two years later
and in the newspaper world when they all
see the president and uh
another mass liar the
brennan who was then the head of counter
and connor connor he was the deputy
secretary president of isa the president
counter-terrorism later the cia director
who doesn't lie as much as kissinger
only because he hasn't been in office as
long and anyway
and
they had all these briefings that were
going on and everybody's getting great
stories
and it's a wonderful story here comes
somebody two years later that suggests
there may be a slightly different
history it's history still the same some
guy wrote a letter to the london times
saying
he's a bad guy and obama killed him what
else who cares the rest is just fringes
and he's right in a way obama did kill
him and so what if he anyway but they
all my my colleagues even at the new
york times when some a different story
came out it was as if
there's
two years later there's no reclama i
mean you can't have a different version
and i remember thinking to myself
don't they have mothers
you know does a mother to tell them no
common sense would say it's like that
kennedy you know um
um
one of the
it doesn't matter um
um
it's just the way it is let me ask you
this question oh my god
let me ask you this question and then
we've we we true ending it's just it's a
a question that comes from errol morris
my buddy yeah your buddy he says
napoleon of saint helena said to the con
de las casas
what then
what then is generally speaking the
truths of history a fable agreed upon
this quote is of course cynical
but is it true
is truth merely an agreement between
people particularly where history is
concerned
i took a course that i studied us
chicago for four years um
um we read plato and socrates in the
final year you had a course called
organizations methods and principles
and it was sort of a one-year course
taught by a brilliant professor in which
you looked at all of it
and
earl morse
does live in plato's republic
he he's a he's wonderful i worked with
him on a documentary and he's
most ethereal interesting man he's just
amazing
um
and
he is full of those lines you know he
wrote a wonderful strange book just
recently it was just published by the
new chicago press about he studied
philosophy so how the answer is han
hello i know
thank you very much bye-bye
[Applause]
book tv is on twitter and facebook and
we want to hear from you tweet us
twitter.com
booktv river of fire using the box at
the top of the page
good evening everyone pardon
okay thank you
everyone
i'm so gratified to have this wonderful
turnout for i think uh a unique event
that will start off a whole week of
uh
of
work that has been the the
a program that has been the work of many
hands certainly many departments here at
the university
many outside groups
uh co-sponsors are on listed in the
program that you've received
my name is linda yarr i'm a research
professor here at the elliott school and
director of partnerships for
international strategies in asia this is
a program here at the elliott school
that partners directly
with universities and research
institutes
across asia and
since 1994 we've had extensive
work with
universities and research institutes and
government agencies and ngos in vietnam
we love to be able to also bring the
voices of the region here
to washington
this
this
week devoted to
peace waging peace in
vietnam is especially
i'd like to especially acknowledge the
partnership with the institute of policy
studies
and their associate fellow ron carver
whom you will hear from
in a moment
today at many locations around the
nation's capital the service of veterans
to our country is recognized with
gratitude
we also remember that november 11th
first marked the day the guns went fell
silent in europe in what was known then
as the great war and was supposed to be
the war to end all wars
in succeeding generations
men and women
have been enrolled in military service
to the nation but at times their
patriotism and sense of duty
were sorely tested as policies
conflicted with their own consciences
the exhibit for which we are celebrating
the opening commemorates the bravery of
u.s military men and women who
understood their allegiance to their
nation
to encompass speaking out about the
abuses and the legitimacy of prosecuting
war in vietnam
i hope you will take your time to fully
absorb the extraordinary information
that has been made available to us
to enjoy the vietnamese music later on
and we can thank the elliott schools
office of public affairs for the
excellent arrangements tonight
[Applause]
i will leave it to ron to explain the
genesis of the exhibit and book
and
especially
the opportunity to introduce his
co-authors who are also here
barbara doherty in particular
but let me first say a few words about
ron carver himself
ron has been a warrior but a warrior for
peace and social justice
the day after he graduated from high
school he joined the student nonviolent
coordinating committee and first worked
as nick's
atlantic communications department
and later in rural mississippi
his successful campaign efforts over the
decades included supporting american gi
resistance during the vietnam war
halting the slaughter of dolphins by the
tuna industry
fighting the senseless shutdowns of
factories winning relief in a labor
agreement for truck drivers abducted
while fighting to form a union in mumbai
and compensation for chinese workers
beaten for stepping out of the lunch
line
he was has designed and directed
campaigns while working for green space
green apartment green
green peace greenspace
friends of the earth
the ue the uaw and his founder and
director of the teamsters office of
strategic campaigns for the union's
first reform president
as a photographer his work has been
exhibited in himaji japan taipei mexico
city and galleries across the united
states
ron the mic is yours
[Applause]
greetings
thank you for coming
i'm overwhelmed at the turnout i
appreciate it very much
linda i appreciate the introduction i
didn't expect that
and coming from you it means a lot
this
we have been
bringing this exhibit to universities
across the country this is the most
wonderful
of all of the
uh exhibits
and as you see
from the program we have a week-long
series of events
including great movies
poetry peace poetry open mic
the reenactment of a famous first
amendment lawsuit court right versus
riser reserve being the
uh the the
secretary of the army
who had
uh
punitively transferred david cortright
for protesting the war
and with the added caveat that not only
did he protest the war
but he
refused to tell his girlfriend that she
should stop protesting the war how's
that
so that reenactment will be here at the
law school on thursday afternoon
and then on friday
we have all day a great program
starting in the morning with
history professors
talking about
various initiatives to end the war in
vietnam not the least of which was the
gi anti-war movement
next we have a panel on teaching the
vietnam war
and the the gi anti-war movement
but we didn't think it would be proper
to
bring all these people together without
talking in the afternoon about the
ongoing legacies of the war
and we're not going to talk about today
how the war began
or how it was prosecuted but we can
never forget and should never forget the
ongoing legacies of the unexploded
ordinance
that unfortunately keeps exploding
and the
victims of agent orange
and they keep coming also because the
impact of agent orange
transfers through the generations so we
now have second and third generation
victims of agent orange
and there's a lot that can be done but
mostly we want to be talking about what
of
vietnam american vietnam veterans are
doing
to mitigate these legacies and they may
also then be talking about what
the rest of us could do about that
at the end of that program on friday
we're going to
have a reenactment
of the uh mobilization march
and and of course that's why we have
this program here in washington this
month because this is the 50th
anniversary of the mobilization against
the war
the largest anti-war protest in the
history of the united states
both up to that date and even after that
date
a march in which
anti-war soldiers and veterans played a
key role and we'll talk about that in a
minute
uh and so that will be leaving here at
around six o'clock on friday
and marching
three blocks to the white house now this
is a special
march designed for those
of us uh
boomers boomers go home
no boomers go to the white house
and go
and go with young people and we're
pleased that there are so many young
people at gw and other universities
in washington dc who are joining us this
week
so anyway that will be a candlelight
march
pretty brief because it's going to be
pretty cold but you can do it if i can
do it you can do it
but what i really wanted to say up here
today before we turn this over to
the key speaker seymour hirsch and then
three
uh veterans who were
when they were active duty
were warriors for peace
what i want to do is say
i was in an event yesterday it's a
wonderful
short party to honor the four people we
have here from vietnam
and who will be speaking on friday
evening you can see them in the program
and someone asked well how about the
burns documentary
and how come they didn't mention too
much about the anti-war movement and
nothing about the gi movement well
they did
do two important things first of all
the the burns novak documentary
reignited discussion about the war and
that was good
they
clearly blamed a series of u.s
presidents for prosecuting the war even
when they knew it couldn't be won
because they wanted to let the next
president take the blame for
ending the war and losing the war
and they had individual soldiers
stories and that's important it's always
good to have stories but what they
didn't do in that series 10 part series
they didn't mention
the gi movement
you had individual gi's who made a
change but
this exhibit in this book that we're
celebrating tonight
a waging peace in vietnam u.s soldiers
and veterans who opposed the war
tells the story
of the
birth and the growth of the gi movement
the story is told through
different chapters related to different
types of descent and resistance
we have the folks who
the early resistors
dr howard levy who refused to train
green berets
you had
jj johnson part of the fort hood 3 who
were already in the army refused to
deploy to vietnam
early resisters
donald duncan
a celebrated green beret who quit in
disgust and because he as he said
he knew
what to do
but he knew what he was doing was wrong
but later we get into
the soldiers who
who marched in great numbers
now
ken burns knew this story because he had
a copy of
david zeiger's great film sir no sir
which tells this story with music and
it's going to be presented here tomorrow
night
in voices of these soldiers
but he ignored it
and and what he was ignoring was
and
many of you might not know this that
that from 1968 on every major peace
march in the united states was led by
active duty soldiers and veterans
in in 1969
you had a thousand active duty gis
marching in the streets of killeen texas
outside fort hood in 1970 you had a
thousand active duty marines in
oceanside california
outside of camp pendleton marching in
the street the next year you had two
thousand colleen you had
people marching in
in seattle washington in
in wrightstown new jersey
all across the country you had
thousands of gi's marching you had
susan schnall who will be talking
soon
leading
uh 500 active duties sailors and
soldiers down market street with a
couple of thousand civilians marching
behind them ken burns knew about this
and shows for whatever reason which we
don't have to speculate you can do that
on your own
didn't want to talk about it you had
how did this movement spread you'll see
in this exhibit and you'll see in in
chapter of the book about the gi press
gi underground press there were between
250 and 300 individual newspapers
written by and for gis primarily
returning from vietnam
telling their stories they would get
them printed and be smuggled back onto
the bases thousands and thousands and
thousands you'll read about that story
we're talking about
soldiers who are building a movement the
the newspapers were the social media of
the day
telling the story in almost real time
back then it was real time maybe it took
two weeks or a month
so this is the story of resistance this
is the story of protest
uh this is a story that we're honoring
by the way paul cox is here tonight who
active duty marine
saw his own mini-me lie
came back to the united states disgusted
angered betrayed
enraged
when he got back to camp lejeune the
paper he put out he named rage
so this is the heart of the gi movement
it wasn't just individuals it was people
building a movement
so
that let me wrap up by saying
the reason that we are doing this the
reason that we are touring campuses
across the united states
is
simple and
humble we want to change the way history
is being taught in this country
particularly the history of the vietnam
war if you don't talk about
if scholars don't write about
the gi movement when they're writing
about the war if they don't
teach about the gi movement when they're
teaching about the war how do you
explain the end of the war
we have to give full credit to the
vietnamese people
who fought valiantly for their own
independence
[Applause]
but it's important to know
when secretary of the army laird in
january 1970
came back from vietnam for tour of
inspection
he told president nixon
if we don't get the troops out of
vietnam we're going to lose the army
he didn't say we're going to lose the
war because they already knew they were
going to lose a war they'd known that
for years but he said we're going to
lose the army
and that is a tribute to
the troops that resisted in great
numbers you'll read about it in the book
it's on sale there
and the final thing i want to say is we
believe that this is not a sad story
it's an inspiring story
it's important for young people to hear
this story people who are facing great
challenges today with the environment
with
reproductive rights with
all kinds of social justice issues that
if the active duty soldiers
during the height of the vietnam war
were able to build a movement so robust
that it
was a significant significant factor in
ending the war
then young people today should feel
inherent they should feel bold they
should feel optimistic
about fighting for social justice today
thank you
thank you ron for giving us
a real
charge to uh
to go forward in in the the week's
activities
on these uh central themes
to provide some perspective on the book
itself which is for sale and you have
may have noticed right there
i'm especially pleased to introduce mr
seymour hirsch his outstanding
journalism has changed minds and
conversations on critical issues his
beat is worldwide and covers the u.s
government and its activities abroad
including for example
the milai massacre
and the egregious treatment of iraqi
prisoners
at abu ghraib
he's a graduate of the university of
chicago who shifted from law to
journalism after middle military service
he
co-founded a newspaper
and later worked for united press
international
associated press
and was press secretary for the eugene
mccarthy presidential campaign
hersch was able to interview lieutenant
us army lieutenant william l kelly who
recounted the killing in march 1968 of
hundreds of south vietnamese villagers
in the hamlet of milai by u.s troops
under his command
hersch's syndicated account helped end
u.s involvement in the vietnam war
and provided the basis for his pulitzer
prize-winning book milai
4. at the new york times hirsch did
groundbreaking reporting on the
watergate scandal and this led him to
write the price of power kissinger in
the nixon white house
well worth reading again
a damning portrait of henry kissinger
that won the national book critics
circle award
without further ado let me turn the
podium over to seymour hirsch thank you
[Applause]
yeah uh uh i'm on a clock here you're
taking time up i will say about the book
i'm really glad they told you where to
buy it because it's it's it is the
backbone of the exhibit and i i've uh
it's an amazing book i i will tell you
this
and if some of you have read it you can
daydream for a second or two but if you
haven't just start off with the essays
of paul cox i'm glad he's here i haven't
met him but what what stuff he's done
dennis stout bill short
if that doesn't get you those three
essays get you reading all of the book
nothing will
um i'm here because i'm a vietnam war
junkie like most of you here
um
i happen to believe i happen to know
oh you can't hear me i
you know
i've given speeches with before huge
auditoriums
where at the end of the speech
everybody came up to me and they said
they couldn't hear anything
so
what's wrong with you people if you
can't hear
you know i mean come on
we wouldn't have ended the war if
everybody had that attitude i'll tell
you that
anyway i'm a junkie on the war
um uh i do believe it's the most
misreported war in american history and
i'll tell you why
um
i guess the the people in this book and
many that many of the people who fought
the war understand why
it's really simple it was not just a war
fully understood actively or passively
um
it it was a
a war
that it isn't the question of the
generals just not getting it
westmoreland and the other three and
four stars and two stars that ran the
war it was a criminal war
a war of murder and rape and atrocity
that was known
and covered up in real time by the
generals who ran it from westmoreland on
down what i'm saying is that's funny is
i'm i'm into this again which is why
i was very glad when ron who's done this
is an amazing ex where you've been
seeing it for yourself when ron
uh asked me to speak
um or somebody
i learned something about the massacre
about a year ago that was staggering and
since back i'm at it researching a
documentary that will will not be made
we're we're playing around it ain't easy
the bottom line is that the men in
charge at the top
knew by early 1966 that war crimes and
i'm talking about the constant reports
filtered as they were coming up to them
of the killing of non-combatants the
inability of them of the soldiers in the
field to make a distinction all
vietnamese were viet cong even the
little ones they were vehicleing and
training or growing to grow up
the raping at will of young and old
woman and much mutilation involved were
a constant they knew this there was a
major study done very early totally
classified still secret i guess nobody
knows about it
um
there was a concert and they also
understood then in 66 just as we began
the build up
uh that unless then checked immediately
unless stopped unless telling the
officers that the low-level officers you
will not get promoted by the numbers of
the people you kill by the body count
that the war was going to be lost you
can't fight a war if everybody in every
village you're going to hate your guts
anyway
of course they did nothing and they
looked the other way i can tell you now
that i've learned so much about me lie
um
i can tell you that
as somebody said to me i love saying
this
um when i began to get into what i'm
into now i had a a guy that worked very
high levels in those years in 69 he's
long retired he said to me about i the
story i wrote was about lieutenant cali
who was accused of 109
killing 109 vietnamese
i never thought twice about why such a
big number for him five would have done
it anyway
he said to me you know psy said you're a
good guy this is a guy that spent 40 30
40 years in the military and undercover
and in other agencies and smart guy he
said you know nothing wrong with you you
know you're a good guy but i got to tell
you
when it came
to the milai story he said you were like
little red riding hood who saw the big
bad bear and you thought it was william
callie a first lieutenant got me going
and so um
i can tell you that the end of the war
westmoreland
had a long paper written i assume with a
lot of aid from the jag the legal
services of the pentagon and you have to
understand
as i really did that the army's judicial
corps
relationship
to westmoreland is like that of a of a
fixer law firm like patent boggs
famously is here to their client
it's not about the truth in that case
even the military judicial system is
protecting the client so wesley had a
long paper written
100 pages making the argument that there
was no basis for prosecuting convicting
and hanging him for war crimes as was
general tamayuk yamashita the famous
general japanese commander in the
philippines whose troops did who knows
what marsha batang untold horus
wesley and all of his peers the guys the
three stars and two stars uh at the top
knew the score
and um
um but
they knew what was going on the field
and they knew that the numbers of being
killed
of then anybody killed was being counted
by the middle of 66 as a vietcong no
matter how little they were or what
whether they were women and children
they were counted as enemy they knew the
story then so um
the paper was never published and of
course that never rose that was that
issue never rose i'm on a time clock so
and i don't have a watch here so i'm
going to ignore until somebody comes and
grabs me but anyway so i published the
book that you heard about 36 years ago
and didn't did not pick up then about
rusty's wesley's real fears
but wrote a lot about ironically about
the first moratorium which happened to
come out about a day or two my after my
first story about cali i remember there
were signs up of course i and my family
and everybody we could everybody
in in our group we were there
for the earlier ones too in 67 and
remember the famous one that um
norman mailer wrote about but this one
was important because it was also a
tremendous amount of military
involvement
ex-military and guys risking their
careers and their lives
but in this in the book that i wrote
about there was a lot about a lot of
moping and groping by
kissinger and nixon about the first
moratorium ironically enough
and what none of us knew then
the success of the moratorium had an
amazing impact because
nixon had campaigned
and won the very close election against
hubert humphrey
and um i always thought mccarthy
mccarthy i joined mccarthy's campaign
because i had been a freelance writer by
67 and you couldn't do that much and
mccarthy bobby kennedy went around and
mccarthy wood and he was against the war
and what he used to say one of the
things he always said is
that mcnamara as you might remember in
66 had lowered the
educational standards
of the war it was called the project 100
000. the ideas was to get more
people with
65 or to 90 iq into the army uh who will
be more congenial and more willing to do
what you want
and mccarthy used to call it basically
to change the color of the corpses
to get
more
fewer white people and more hispanic and
african-american people in the war
because obviously
those people are in educational systems
then and now
that give a much less of a chance
they're less good less money spent
nothing's changed about that amazing
well it's not going to change with this
current government we don't want to go
there we're going to spend a week anyway
so nixon had told everybody he had a
secret plan
to end the war but it turned out it was
to win it
and he began him back channel in 69 and
about the middle of the year to begin
signaling to the north that he was going
to be different he ordered the strategic
air command on absolute high control
lifted the there's a standard four
levels of of of of uh
of a terror basically of um
i guess you would call it just readiness
and he moved it from no readiness to
near the highest residence readiness and
these are all signs and the way it's
transmitted a lot of signals traffic we
know the other side can monitor that
stuff he also had a plan as some of you
may know
to escalate and start bombing
dramatically he warned the north
vietnamese he had nuclear options
planned and so what happens the
moratorium comes
and
um it was also called some of you might
remember the madman theory nixon was
going to present himself as somebody out
of control and scare the north
i think they really did think so
and um the idea was to force the north
to come in and accept the peace with
this awful
south vietnamese government we supported
headed by uh dean uh new zealand cm and
his brother
as um
frankie fitzgerald wrote in this amazing
book that was published in 72 fire in
the lake
she said well
the real mistake in the war was we were
backing the wrong side we should have
been back in the vietnamese com they
weren't communists they were vietnamese
nationalists we should have been they
were the legitimate government but
that's another story okay so
he was going to do all this stuff and
then here comes i wrote about this here
comes a lot of whining on tapes and
other documents saying in his own
memoirs he was talking about i you know
if you remember names like sam brown
dave mixter david hawk the first who
worked with me in the mccarthy campaign
and um
he was saying here's a direct quote
there was no civility or grace from
these leaders the the problem were more
moratorium prosecutor
leaders they mercifully i'm quoting for
quoting directly they mercilessly
persecuted those they regarded as
culpable
and so in and the day of more the
moratorium or the day before bill watts
a nato later resigned wrote kissinger a
note
i i got a copy of it saying that
um he's saying that if you go ahead with
this escalation given this
given the outcome of the moratorium not
only in washington but around the world
particularly in other countries in
america he said
there will be physical turmoil and the
rage would be hard to control if you
remember these are the days some of you
guys don't young people wouldn't know
these are the days when one of the great
jokes going about the war was
al hay who was a pernicious uh general
working for kissinger and a super
supporter of the war rushing into
rushing into nixon's office to say mr
president the president of protests are
getting out of control we meet more
security inside the white house well
said nixon as the joke has it call out
the 82nd
and hague responded mr president the
protesters are the 82nd
i love that joke it was done by fta
remember fta
anyway yeah right great group so anyway
so
he later said in his memoir in his um
called rn after all the protests in the
moratorium america public opinion would
surely be seriously divided by any
escalation of the war so he buried it so
the moratorium was far more successful
than it knew in a way they couldn't know
that they had really done something
anyway
um
[Music]
i got one more thing to say about all
this
uh and
ron said it too in in a way
and that is
um
yes
what these guys suffered and they were
put in briggs
there were some given 16-year terms for
protesting there was one shot in the
back if you remember there's one story
about that there were others who
the suffering that went on for those who
protested particularly early was acute
but
yes
they stood up
for the military and they were willing
to
confront the military and the gulags
they were sent to
um but a few years back i returned with
my family to to to milan i had been to
saigon and hanoi doing a plane boy
reporter
for the kissinger book and other things
since the war ended but never to that
village and that if you don't know about
it that awful ditch full of bodies
uh emotional for sure
anyway the one official i really wanted
to meet the vietnamese official was
madame bin who was the
a woman who was the leader of the
national liberation front the political
arm
of the viet cong in the south i'd
interview when i first i when i first
joined the times i was sort of the
comedy reporter i was sent to cover the
paris peace talks in 72 and i spent a
long day talking there and i wrote an
interview for the times that to the
everlasting credit they led the paper
with and they didn't have a after the
third paragraph they didn't say and
kissinger says this they just let her
talk about the lying that we were doing
and this honesty and i i really got to
admire her
not only for her brilliance and her
willingness to be direct uh she was
beautiful she had shiny black hair
and
she was this amazing
leader for a woman in paris she couldn't
walk a block or two in in paris without
being surrounded by people particularly
women she was just seen as a magical
sort of intent
i knew a lot about her so i wanted to
see when i was hanoi and chuck percy was
back there
with amazing
pocketbook
was it
was your iphone did you have an iphone
back there chuck chuck made some calls
and sure enough we arranged a late
afternoon visit i wasn't i was
i was on a trip with family and they'd
already go in the way anyway
and so i was going to see her in late
afternoon a very modest home she had
been falling out of favor with the
communist leadership in the north
because she said they're just they're
just little chinese
demagogues and capitalists in disguise
she was very contemptuous of them
and
sure enough she came it's a two-story
house and i was downstairs waiting she
came down you know late 80s dressed in a
hill a la francaise long dress and a
beautiful scarf around her neck
and she pretended very nicely to
remember me in the interview although i
wasn't sure of that but anyway it had
been a big splash at the time
and of course at one point she said oh i
do remember you and of course i remember
your milai stories and we in vietnam
were so grateful for those stories
because they did so much to get the
american people to understand what the
war was like and then she did this
wonderful thing she reached out in a
sort of grandmotherly way and put her
arm around my shoulder
and she said but you must remember
it was we the vietnamese we won the war
and the story
we owe so much to uh seymour hirsch's
reporting and thank you again
in today's
letters to the editor at the new york
times you may have noticed there was a
letter by iraq war veteran tom voss
who responded to the article that was
carried a couple of days ago
about uh the increase of suicide rates
among veterans today
and
in his letter he uh pointed to the
concept of moral injury
which he defined as quote wound to the
soul and psyche
and he writes it
causes combat veterans to question the
morality of the actions they were
ordered to take during combat
one veterans whose whose eloquent essay
in the book reveals his dilemma is bill
short
bill served in combat in vietnam and was
an anti-war
resistor
he now teaches photography at moon park
college in california
and he was an artist in residence at the
addison gallery of american art in
andover massachusetts and he is the
co-author with willis seidenberg of the
book a matter of conscience of gi
resistance during the vietnam war
i
i would like to welcome bill short to
the to the podium and let's let's hear
his perspective
[Applause]
uh so um
the book that bart that linda was
okay um and they're used to holding a
mic so uh the book that
linda was just talking about is this
book which is out of print which was
published in 1992. you can still get it
on
on amazon
it's 58 oral histories and portraits of
gis who protested the war one of the
early publications it's also kind of the
backbone of the exhibit in the book and
also a contributor as i was to
um cerno sur i was the associate
producer one of the associate producers
on that great film sonos cernoser which
is being shown tomorrow night and i'd
encourage all of you to go see that if
you want to find it online i have these
you can go to a matter of conscience.com
and there's also another project my wife
and i worked on that is called memories
of the american war stories from vietnam
we made three trips in the early 90s to
vietnam
to interview 90 people who fought
against the united states during the war
so
um
so
i wanted to start with a quote from
something we quoted in the book
which is a quote from sir stanley
shawcroft who was one of the
prosecuting attorney attorneys at the
nuremberg trials in 1946
and he said there comes a point when a
man must refuse his leader if he's also
to answer his conscience
and i think that's really true for a lot
of the vets who took part in the
protests individual and organized during
the vietnam war i wanted to consider
that quote from him as a way to talk
about or re-examine the idea of
patriotism what patriotism is
and patriotism is something for me
that was that came to me through my
family and through the upbringing my
both besides my family were
revolutionary war veterans
when we witness our country following
the wrong path it is an incumbent upon
us to speak
out or be complicit with that past
those who spoke out against the war the
civilians in the anti-war movement and
gr resistors were the true loyal
patriots of the united states i would
like to thank those of you in this group
tonight who are part of the civilian
anti-war movement for supporting gi
resistors and no anti-war demonstrator
ever spit on me
i can't
[Applause]
say i can't say that my voice was as
strong or as powerful as those working
against the war on the home front like
folks organizing demonstrations
publishing gi newspapers running
anti-cop anti-war coffee houses gr
resistors like skip delano
dave klein susan schnall and others who
reached thousands of americans and
helped turn the tide against the war
there are my heroes
i wish i had been as savvy as they were
but a small in a small way those of us
who resisted from the field of combat
and in isolation helped contribute to
the demise of the us military and
ultimately bring the war to an end every
grain of sand thrown into the machine
helped bring the military gears to a
slow halt
i'm the descendant of revolutionary war
veterans on both sides of my family also
the son of a civilian engineer who
was a
work for air force intelligence at
wright-patterson air force base grew up
in
military neighborhoods i was drafted
from springfield ohio in 1968
just after the tet offensive in in march
give you an idea of what how the tet
affected the draft at that time there
were 30 people drafted from my county in
february there were 150 of us drafted in
march of 1968.
i was trained in the in train for the
infantry at fort jackson south carolina
is also a patron of the ufo coffee house
the antwer coffee house that was run in
columbia south carolina at the time
i was aware of the anti-war room it was
a passive bystander at this point
i volunteered for non-commissioned
officers candidate school at fort
benning georgia
um
which is a school that
like kind of like a mini ocs they
trained people to be sergeants to lead
smoke small combat units in vietnam
i was sent to vietnam in february of
1969
and when i went i knew about
camp about campus protests because i'd
been at ohio university for a year and a
half before i went into the service or
before i was drafted
but i hadn't quite decided if i was
ready to take a stand against the war
um as as i
reported for
my
um
deployment to vietnam in in oakland
california i got there a day early spent
a night in a very cheap hotel and the
next day went to a church and sat in the
church for the full morning
trying to figure out whether i was going
to go awol or not
i decided that i should go and see it
firsthand for myself and then make my
decision about whether i was against the
war or not if i
by seeing it
in real life
so i took my dog tags off and hung them
on one of the crosses on an altar that
was in the church
and asked whoever was there i'm not a
very religious person but i asked
whoever was there
that
i hoped that they would help me find the
right path when i got to vietnam
when i got there i was
deployed to the out to alpha company
first battalion first infantry division
we were an air mobile assault group the
first injury division was kant was
commonly and affectionately known by
some gis as the bloody red one
i was on
i was a squad leader in a infantry
platoon and then eventually promoted to
a platoon sergeant
one of the things that really turned me
around aside from
the body counts and all the all the
combat we were in was that when we did
blow an ambush and there were peop
troops were sent out to count the bodies
i always would lay back and i was never
interested in doing that and i always
figured that other guys would be curious
enough that they would do it so i was
kind of trying to insulate myself from
what i was actually doing
another a senior nco who was a rank
above me
came to
convince me to help him start movie
trapping bodies
and that's what really turned me around
was was actually physically touching the
bodies and booby trapping those bodies
myself my first squad leader in the
platoon sniper the three of us went on
strike against the war i was initially
charged with leading a conspiracy to
mutiny against the united states
government
i was
initially going to be given a general
court martial i received a special court
martial and received the special court
martial twice received two six-month
sentences spent
about 47 days the first time in 14 14
days the first time 47 days the second
time in long been jail in in
longman south vietnam
and then was eventually discharged and
sent back home when i was in the
stockade the stockade was built to hold
250 people there were about 500 of us
there
most of the people who were there were
were there for um
various things like refusing orders
assault drugs all the symptoms of a
breakdown of the morale of the military
i believe firmly believe that if i
hadn't if there weren't an active
anti-war movement back here in the
united states i would have spent a lot
more time in prison i think the military
at this point in time had realized that
there's such a turn against the war that
they were just trying to get people like
me dump us out of the military as
quickly and as easily as possible
so i guess i just want to close with a
quote from um um colonel robert d heinel
a military
historian who wrote a commentary in the
armed forces journal titled the collapse
of the armed forces
and in his opening paragraph he says the
morale discipline and value battle
worthiness of the united states armed
forces are with a few salient exceptions
lower and worse than at any time in this
century and possibly in the history of
the united states by every every
conceivable indicator our army that now
remains in vietnam is in a state
approaching collapse
although combat soldiers in vietnam like
myself did not have the latest in news
or know the extent of the anti-war
movement
it was in the air and we could all smell
it even 10 000 miles away thank you
thank you bill it is irreplaceable to
have this eyewitness personal experience
report
of those times
now despite the hope that the lessons of
vietnam might include a reluctance of
the country to engage in armed conflict
we've now been at war in the middle east
in afghanistan for 18 years nearly a
generation how do our more recent
veterans view their sense of duty
i'd like to hear now from jonathan judo
senior
he's an honorably discharged veteran of
the united states navy
where he served from january 2004 until
august 2011.
as an enlisted member of the navy he
helped to launch the appeal for redress
mobilizing over 2 000 members of the
active duty and reserve ranks to send a
protected communication to members of
congress
appealing for an end to the wars in iraq
and afghanistan
jonathan is a native of atlanta georgia
a howard university alum
yes
father husband and lifelong human rights
defender
please let us welcome jonathan hutto
all right
i couldn't contain myself when she said
howard right
first and foremost
let me uh thank
uh the elliott school of international
studies here george washington and dr
linda here and all the laborers who work
to
bring this
this museum i'm calling the museum but
this traveling museum into being can you
can we give him a strong movement hand
[Applause]
all right
and
specifically to ron carver but before i
do that i would be remissed
if i didn't recognize
uh
some soldiers a soldier specifically in
the room he has a gentleman right in
this corner warren helm you stand up
here warren
warrenham give him a shot hand
warren helms is a survivor
of vietnam an infantryman wounded in
action in vietnam was in action for
three months and got medevaced to hawaii
i met warren on the basketball court
some years ago
and he runs like a racehorse he's my
mother's age he's i told him he's my
inspiration i asked him to come out here
this evening so i want to thank him
appreciate you warren
and uh and to my good friend
i am saying good friend with parentheses
ron carver because ron
uh in terms of that intergenerational
link
uh to the student nonviolent
coordinating committee organizationally
the student nonviolent coordinating
committee
really birthed me as an activist as an
organizer
and as a revolutionary
so i don't come to you today as an
intellectual
or as someone who merely studies history
although my mother certainly educated me
on the vietnam war from her very mouth
as a child
me as a child
in terms of her friends from high school
specifically a story of a young man she
tells she was an undergraduate student
at clark atlanta university and a young
man who
was walking to class with her one
morning it was the last morning where he
let her know that he had just gotten
drafted to vietnam and she talks about
this gentleman his name slips me right
now but she talks about the letters she
even showed me the letters that she
received from him and then at some point
those letters stopped
this is a story that many of you have
heard or have lived actually
living history and then coming to that
wall in the early 80s when i was a small
child i was six years old and seeing my
mother literally collapsed at that wall
when she saw that name on the wall and
and some other names
that she wondered what had happened
to her friends
to a classmate that she grew up with and
so it's that history that really bathed
my brain and my veins as a child i was
solidly born
in the middle class the black middle
class of atlanta georgia uh
through through a breadwinner my father
who went from being a breadwinner to
being a child support payer when i was
10 years old there's a difference when
your parents divorced right
so i was able to get to howard
university because my mother despite our
economic situation instilled in me a
superior almost superior belief in
myself and my own abilities to get
things done
she said you can get there you will find
a way to stay and i did i was student
body president my junior year i met a
professor at howard university named
rodney green this is rydo here raise
your hand rod this is rodney green here
a retired professor of economics and rod
was the first person that ever took me
out on a street action as a freshman at
howard university we marched on newt
gingrich's house the contract on america
at the time in 1996.
uh
i remember having that big boyhorn the
president of university see him in front
of student center and standing right
next to rob but i bring rod up because
rod is my first link to the gi movement
i didn't know he was a gi movement
veteran when i was an undergraduate
student but as a snick comrade of ron's
taught us in my undergraduate years
right there in rankin memorial chapel
his name to my generation was kwame
toure known to many of you as stokely
carmichael it was within that address
nine months before he passed
part of what he said to us as students
was that the more you struggle the more
you know
and the more you know the more you can
do and your people are going to need you
to do until you die
again i'm not coming as an intellectual
pundit i'm an organizer i'm an activist
so it is with that spirit that rod now
is engaged in struggle against police
brutality in neighboring prince george's
county maryland right up the road here
from washington d.c
it was it was within that struggle
rod and i in conversation with each
other i learned of his history in the gi
movement not knowing it three years
later due to my own personal struggles
26 000
in debt
in terms of college
i had a young son
i was a single father i made a decision
i joined the united states navy i
enlisted on january 14
2004
i thought it would be just a nice
smooth trip
just to pay off some loans tap into a
graduate education i was in for a rude
awakening
almost a year later i'm in a van leaving
norfolk virginia driving somewhere
because in my mind i'm not going back to
the draconian uss theodore roosevelt i
made a decision i couldn't take it no
more i couldn't take
all the racist jokes i couldn't take the
homophobia i couldn't take the
xenophobia i couldn't take the sexism
if i i'm about to say i couldn't take
the grab ass and i couldn't take the
culture that seemed too demeaning and
too inhumane for my spirit
but i did stop by rod's house
as i was on my way to somewhere
and it was rod who struggled with me to
actually go back to the ship
can you imagine that
and in his struggle with me i remember
some points that rob made one of the
points that rob made
was that he said the young men and the
women in that division
there on board the uss theodore
roosevelt
many of them if not all of them they
don't feel no different than you do
actually
they just deal with it in a different
way
that you've always have spoken out
outwardly
now might be the time for you to build
within
with your actual comrades on the ship
can you imagine that
i had to grapple with that
it didn't make sense to me
at the time but i trusted rod
i actually turned around went back to
the ship
actually served my punishment
but then a year later we launched the
appeal for redress
based upon this book inspired book by
david cortwright soldiers in revolt
and i want to say
and david will be here somewhat later i
got my sign there's a minute left i
actually used six minutes that quick but
what i want to say finally
i'm gonna close this book
what i want to say finally is that
there are many struggles taking place in
the united states today
ron mentioned them earlier
the environmental struggle you right
here in the city washington d.c that is
the most gentrified city in the united
states
the most i mean black people being
pushed out of this city wholesale i work
for organization we fight like hell to
stop i mean the most affordable housing
in this city public housing
there's not there's this connection
between public housing being eradicated
public schools being eradicated and
they're having this massive military
budget
that's sucking the blood out of every
city
all the resources
and leaving people to die
right there no schooling no housing but
we got massive bombs as the lake tupac
and mauro shakur said they got money for
wars but what they can't feed the poor
so regardless of how you got here
we all in the same boat
and as george jackson
left us with in blood in my eye and
soledad brother those words i'm bringing
to an end now those words i internalize
and i live every day he simply told us
to settle your quarrels
come together
understand the real true reality of our
situation
understand that fascism is here it's
here
if you don't believe it's here at least
within a structural sense it's here
ideologically
you see ideologically fascism is here
that millions have died that could have
been saved and that millions more will
die or live half butchered poor lies
if we fail to act do what must be done
embrace your love and humanity in a
worldwide revolution join us us being
veterans for peace join us us being iraq
veterans against the war join us join
the organization doing the work for the
people give up your life for the people
thank you so much
fantastic
we certainly have our marching orders
don't we
thank you
you know so we often uh the images of of
the military of war you know up to now
you know seem so
masculine
um
and yet we know that
the men who were fighting were supported
by women at home often very young women
with children wondering what what was
going to happen with their future
and certainly the anti-war movement
was
certainly galvanized by
many women women strike for peace and so
many organizations
but
to exemplify the kind of bravery we've
been talking about here and an enduring
commitment
and maybe i can even say some downright
husba
there's no finer model than susan
schnall
who i know will arouse in us the urge to
do better and choose peace
susan as a navy nurse
led the anti-war march on san francisco
in october 1968
she is currently
an assistant professor at new york
university's school of professional
studies in health care management and
serves as president of the new york city
chapter of this marvelous organization
veterans for peace she has organized
scientific panels about agent orange at
the american public health association's
annual meetings and works very closely
with uh with families that have been
affected by agent orange over
generations
please let me join me in welcoming susan
schnall
good evening everybody it's it's
wonderful to be here
i just would like to start by mentioning
i've completed three weeks of a peace
talking tour
in japan and the beginning of all of my
presentations
a reminder
of what happened 75 years ago in
nagasaki in hiroshima and to apologize
on behalf of the american people and
american veterans and the u.s government
for the terrible destruction we visited
on japan
it is for me and it was a kind of
personal reconciliation tour my father
was killed on the island of guam in july
1944
and so going to japan to talk about
peace and reconciliation reminds me of
how important it is for all of us to
continue that struggle and that struggle
to reconcile former enemies
for all of us to work together for peace
also a reminder today is i know most of
you may think of it as veterans day but
it's armistice day
and those of us and veterans for peace
are demanding that we rename this day
armistice day so that we talk about a
day of peace
instead of showing the glory of war
[Applause]
from the summer of 1967 through june
1969
i was a navy nurse at oak and all
hospital in oakland california
i was assigned to the surgical and
orthopedic wards
they were world war ii barracks crowded
with 35 to 40 patients
all young men who had been wounded in
this country called vietnam
they were very young
17 18 19 years old some were missing
limbs
some were so shot up they had tubes
coming from various parts of their body
draining fluids
it was at night that i heard the cries
and screams of pain and fear
and it would start on these long open
wards each unit a wooden shack holding
40 steel framed old-fashioned hospital
beds filled with wounded young men
at night the lights would be turned off
so they could sleep and dream their
nightmares of war of dead and dying
bodies
rotting in the dense jungle growth in a
far away country called vietnam
these youngsters would scream their
agony
my leg
my leg it's been blown away
be careful there's a tripwire next in
the grass
and then they would cry agonizing and
panic yells
i'm in pain
give me something for the pain
i can't take it
nurse
please give me something for the pain
the cacophony would start at one end of
the long unit and it would be carried by
the next man-child
i told you i need something for this
pain
their limbs would be held aloft by hooks
that used to elevate
butcher hooks and they would be helding
up a leg or an arm
that had large open wounds
oozing pus
infection mixed with blood
they would have those stumps that would
always remind them
of their war and loss
one eighteen-year-old
young clean-cut guy on his way to
surgery
for a foot amputation
he was terribly frightened
and crying
i grabbed a hold of his stretcher as he
was being wheeled to the operating room
and asked him to talk to me
he said he was scared of dying
and as we started to talk the doctors
pulled away the gurney they said they
didn't understand why he would be scared
to have his foot amputated
after all
it was only his foot
they had seen so much worse on other
soldiers
he was chilled and shaking
as they moved his bed out and down the
ramps to the operating room
and his death
and i couldn't protect him
from the war
from his fear
from his death
how could i not know his name
i know this scene i clearly remember
where it took place
the old orthopedic ward the doctors
standing around
upset i've been called in to operate on
this kid
his foot was losing all circulation
and gangrene started to spread
i was only a few years older
but i felt responsible for him
for his fear
for his pain
he and the other young men were the
reasons why i became a nurse in the navy
somehow i could heal them
make them whole again
ease their passage back into society and
family
until i couldn't
and realized that this war had to stop
this was in 1967
1968
during the height of the american war in
vietnam
i watched the battles on tv
and lived the war at work
i was against this terrible destruction
and waste
and yet i had become a part of it
i had a responsibility to act and work
with others to stop the war
and as a member of the armed forces it
was imperative to inform the american
people that there were active duty gis
who were also against the conflict in
southeast asia
that we supported the troops by wanting
to bring them home
i was working with the group organizing
the gi and veterans march for peace to
be held in san francisco on october 12th
we had difficulty
distributing flyers
the press wouldn't wouldn't write about
the story
and
we would put up posters in the middle of
the night
that would be torn down the next day
from the news i learned that the u.s
dropped leaflets
on
south and central vietnam to urge the
vietnamese to go to these protected
hamlets so they could avoid
dying or being sprayed on by agent
orange
and i thought well if the united states
could drop flyers for war in a country
thousands of miles away
why couldn't we drop flyers against the
war and for peace on military bases
at home
i had a friend who was a pilot
and we put thousands of flyers that were
publicizing the gi and veterans march
for peace on october 12th
and we dropped the flyers on the
hospital where i was working oaknell
naval hospital on treasure island that
was a marine base on yerba buena island
and on the presidio an army base
in san francisco
and then we flew into alameda naval air
station where the uss enterprise was
docked and we threw the flyers onto the
deck of the aircraft carrier
[Applause]
we did get a little publicity i did wear
my uniform at the press conference and
said that we were we were active duty
military
and we were organizing a march for peace
two days later after dropping the flyers
i was given an all-navy regulation which
stated that navy personnel could not
wear their uniform while participating
in partisan political issues
and i thought well if the generals and
particularly westmoreland could go in
front of congress and ask for more money
and more troops
to be sent for war in vietnam that's a
political issue why can't i
as a military activist wear my uniform
for peace
[Applause]
the court-martial board disagreed
they sentenced me to dismissal from the
military and
to six months at hard labor
i was released pending appeal and it was
kind of a cool way to begin organizing
because everybody had heard about the
action and had heard about the march and
we were easily able to start a gi coffee
house against the war and distribute
papers because now all of the people on
base
new
at this time in 1968 the united states
was at the paris peace talks
sixteen thousand five hundred troops
died in vietnam
eleven
600 more gave their lives in 1969 an
additional 6 000 died in 1970.
estimates are that over 3 million
vietnamese died in this conflict women
children babies in their land in their
country
today we know that presidents kennedy
nixon and johnson
knew that the united states couldn't win
this war in southeast asia but they kept
increasing troop numbers armaments
bombing an agrarian country thousands of
miles from the shores of the u.s
we never heard of a vietnamese
committing an act of terror in this
country on a united states citizen
and let and yet we let our military
forces attempt to bomb them back to the
stone age
on february 3rd 1969
a closing argument submitted by the navy
trial council about my actions
quote
even her referring to me
slightest actions were not noble or
idealistic they were petty and
small-minded
i ask you
is it petty and small-minded to try to
stop the killing and massacre of
millions of people was it petty and
small-minded to want to bring the us
troops home alive
to prevent the deaths of an additional
40 000 troops to want to bring them back
to their families their communities
rather than use them for cannon fodder
so presidents could get reelected and
not appear weak to the american voters
what is your decision america
[Applause]
well i think
you you can understand why
uh
i
noted
especially susan schnell's
bravery and commitment thank you so much
for all you've done and continue to do
the list of thank yous is very long as
we
prepare to
bring this marvelous session to a close
i'd like to
ask you to join me in thanking some of
our key co-sponsors such as
people who have worked tirelessly such
as terry provence from a vietnam peace
commemoration committee
betty munson from
vietnam veterans for peace
and our
key staff members here from the elliott
school of international affairs anthony
desantis who has
put this so much of this program
together
and
my
wonderful
person who's been working with me
tirelessly yazmin siddudi from the
seeger center for asian studies
these are just a few of the people who
have
been able who worked together
in a in such a cooperative way to to
bring make this event possible
we're grateful that we will have
an encore of some wonderful music from
dr nyan
and ms juan
we will not be able to
have q a i'm sure you're all bursting
with questions however feel free to
color our
many speakers
make talk to each other
and
please enjoy the rest of the evening
thank you
before we leave
before we leave i i want to talk about
the origin of this exhibit it was the
war remnants museum in saigon when they
learned i had spent almost three years
working as a civilian with the gi
movement
in the coffee houses asked me to
curate this exhibit for them it opened
there in in
march of 2018 this is a duplicate that
where
as i mentioned earlier is touring the
the united states
universities and then less than a year
ago on december 3rd i was fortunate to
attend a book launch a book called
conversations with diego rivera in new
york city and there i met
lynn elizabeth who's the director of
new village press which is distributed
by nyu press
and when she learned about the exhibit
she asked me to
make a companion book which is the book
that's on sale now
she gave me until
march
1
to give her a polished manuscript as she
said and then it would be in the catalog
for this fall
well with the help of my wife barbara
doherty
[Applause]
and
professor david cortwright from notre
dame we
got that manuscript of lynn elizabeth at
4 30 in the morning on march 1st
and therefore we have the book today
i have a new friend with lynn elizabeth
who has been just
a dream publisher
i i say that not as if i have a lot of
experience because it's my first book
but it has been a pleasure to work with
her
and
we have special prices today the book
retails for 35
but she's selling it for 30 or 2 for
50
or for students you get the 25 price
anyway by smiling
thanks again enjoy the music enjoy the
wine and the food thank you for coming
[Music]
[Music]
sunday book tv features the latest books
from former trump deputy assistant
sebastian gorka on march 16
1968
american troops entered the south
vietnamese village of milai on november
17
1969 the story broke on television
including abc news the villagers version
of the incident was given by survivors
yesterday they said a patrol of 100
americans stormed into the hamlet drove
all the residents out of their huts then
opened fire with automatic weapons
two american soldiers one an officer the
other an enlisted man are being held in
this country in connection with the case
but neither has been brought to trial
and in the early 1970s some soldiers
remembered they were actually expected
to do what they did
but it's like uh do it but don't let me
catch you i didn't feel like there was
any reason for the public to know
because i felt like this had been done
before
uh
i didn't think that uh i'd ever be
thinking that much of the day first
joining us by phone howard jones
university research professor of history
emeritus at the university of alabama in
tuscaloosa he's the author of milai
vietnam
1968 and the descent into darkness
professor jones before the mi li event
how long had the war in vietnam been
going on and how was it going
well we had become deeply involved in
the mid 1940s a little bit after the
end of world war ii when we entered what
i think historians mostly call an
advisory period
and it was not really going well up to
1968
the time that we're going to be talking
about it was a basically a stalemate
that just continued to escalate
and the in march of 1965
under lyndon johnson we sent the first
combat troops in about 3500 marines that
landed at da nang which was east of
milai and south vietnam
and it was an important place because it
was the birthplace of the viet cong and
it was a real hotbed and it was like the
entrance way into the south vietnam
south vietnam so that's really the
background of 1968 please describe then
what happened at milai on march 16 1968
well the context was that in early 1968
the tet offensive had been launched and
it was the beginning of the bloodiest
year of the vietnamese war
and the united states had sent over
increasing numbers of soldiers and
unfortunately so many of them were very
young
inexperienced had never been in combat
or anything of the sort and then we were
also fighting a different kind of war
in the sense that it was a people's war
that we didn't understand for quite some
time and that is that
all viet cong which were the enemy were
vietnamese but not all vietnamese were
viet cong
and the problem for the soldiers the
officers all of them many times to make
a decision on the spot was how do you
tell the difference
and the answer came in the form of kill
them all one person said let god sort
them out
and did that include children yes
why because they grew up to the viet
cong
and so we entered what was really known
as a war of attrition
in which we were trying to wear down the
enemy believing that we could do it
because because we had superior military
forces but in a people's war you're
dealing with men women children taking
part in the war in all kinds of ways
that were unexpected and so these young
boys entered into a
war that really was not clearly
understood by
officers and certainly not by these
young soldiers and so on march 16 1968
about 105 american soldiers invaded this
little village that was known by the
army to be
milai and they invaded in a two-pronged
effort and their purpose was to sweep
out
all the vietcong
they had been told by intelligence which
was flawed
by the cia in particular that the
village was loaded with maybe 400 viet
cong and here you had about 105
americans and these were young
they were scared obviously
their only goal became to survive
and they listened to their advice of
their
seniors back in boot camp kill or be
killed
and so they had never experienced this
and in the days leading to march 16th
perhaps 28 american soldiers had been
killed their own people their buddies by
mines booby traps snipers and the bottom
line was an invisible enemy they had
never seen the enemy so they were scared
they were frustrated they were vengeful
and they were helped up by a big pep
talk from the night before from their
captain about this is their final chance
to really get
get the enemy and the intelligence was
deftly wrong
there were no vietcong in the village
instead there were nothing but villagers
elderly men
women
children
babies
and no
men of fighting age because they were
all off in the war itself
and so they went in thinking that they
were going to be victims like their 28
americans were
and they began shooting first and it
just grew and grew and grew i think i
think you could say that milai was the
result of a perfect storm
in the sense that the plan was flawed
the intelligence was flawed
everything was flawed in what the
americans did
and the result was a catastrophe in the
sense that there were 504
at the end of four hours less than four
hours there were 504
dead
vietnamese who were defenseless they
were elderly men women children babies
including among these were 19 at least
rapes
13 charged
and probably 40 or so soldiers who
actually did the shooting but not all of
them could be categorized as being
involved in the massacre
but later on 30 of them were charged and
15 had mustered out of the army and were
untouchable because of the supreme court
case
back in 1955
that said if you commit a crime while in
uniform you cannot be tried if you are
already out of uniform
and the law also said that if you were a
civilian you could not be tried for
something you did in uniform so they
were just mustered out and gone
and 15 would stand trial but all of them
were acquitted
because no witnesses appeared
or if they did in one case if lee bailey
just tore the person apart on the stand
and destroyed his credibility
and the result was that only one
soldier william kelly
was convicted
and that was basically because he
admitted
in court in shooting into the ditch
and
another one who captain ernest medina
lied twice on the stand and then later
confessed after the statute of
limitations ran out
so william kelly was convicted
sentenced to prison for
life at hard labor and then on appeal it
was cut to 20 years another appeal to 10
years and finally he was released
on a
commutation of his
his
parole really was the right word to use
by the secretary of the army and
certainly not nixon because he was
already out of office at that time it
was november of 1974
that cali went free and he still is free
when and how did the massacre become
known and did the military try to cover
it up
the military did in the sense of the
americal division
under general major general samuel
coster who is a bright rising star in
the footsteps of
general william westmoreland and it was
covered up in that division but not in
the higher echelons of the army at the
beginning
it started out with the
the coverage of what happened by a young
press man jay roberts in the army
and ron haberly a young
soldier who was an army photographer and
they took pictures they witnessed
everything and all of this and frank
barker the lieutenant colonel who had
formalized the plan formulated the plan
had told them when they asked what do we
report
i mean it's obvious that there were
killings and this and that and barker
said
we want you to write stories that
reflect the heroism the victorious
nature of this and they did as they were
told they wrote stories that appeared in
army publications and it made their way
into the new york times about what a
splendid victory this was that they had
wiped out the vietcong and they had had
only one casualty a soldier who shot
himself in the foot and is suspected
that he did that on purpose so he could
get out of serving
so after three and a half hours of
fighting this was the victory that we
had
and the
whole thing just kind of percolated
throughout
the soldiers themselves and the story
got back to westmoreland and
westmoreland was told that it was a
great victory he wrote them a nice
congratulatory message and that was the
way things stood
until the story began to leak
and it leaked when one young man named
ronald riddenhauer
was talking having beers with a young
soldier
in april 68
just just after it all happened
and the young soldiers said man did you
hear what happened we killed them all we
killed them all and he pushed him
ridden our dead and he gave him details
and all of this
and all of a sudden he was holding the
story and riddenhauer knew that he could
not publish it while he was in the army
because of retaliation and so he held
back on it and then when he got out of
the army he began following leads
talking to other people he knew
others he knew were there and his story
became clear to him so he wrote a
five-page registered letter
to president nixon and the secretary of
state and the number of congressional
members and other leading military
members and all of that and sent it to
them in march of 69
which then spawned an in-house
investigation
that led to the exposure of it
within the army
and then they tried to keep that quiet
and then the word got out that there was
something really going wrong
and there was a young soldier this story
went
down in fort benning georgia in prison
who was behind it all
thus entered seymour hirsch
who went there and finally found him and
then finally found another young soldier
and took one of them to
my mike wallace's up and coming show the
60 minutes show and he was interviewed
on nationwide television and so you had
cali who was exposed you had this young
man who was exposed who admitted
everything including what cali did
and that then hit the press it hit the
news magazines walter cronkite and
everything and it all came out really in
november of
1969
that was how long it took before this
story became clear
and finally professor jones what is the
legacy today of milai
there are many cases but i think
standing out above this is that you had
an instance in which even our american
soldiers
could commit war crimes
under the pressure of what they're
facing in combat that we have to come
face to face that it's not just those
soldiers over there
in europe and places like that it is
american soldiers and i think what it
shows is what hannah
arndt said
a number of years ago about eichmann and
the germans that there's a banality of
evil
and one historian called it ordinary men
are capable of anything in the right or
wrong circumstances
and one one man i interviewed said the
most frightening lesson he learned in
teaching
this period is that we're all one step
away from milai
and so you have
this happening again and again
in the sense of looking at
abu ghraib or looking at guantanamo or
what's happening in iraq and and
afghanistan that kind of thing
and
the the only the redeeming factor in
this which i searched for redeeming
factors
was three young men in a helicopter
hugh thompson glen andreatta and larry
coburn
who witnessed what happened they were
flying overhead this little bubble top
helicopter and their job was to be
bait to be shot at so that the soldiers
on the ground would know where the enemy
was and there was no enemy there
but they came back and talked about the
bodies they saw in the ditch in on the
trail and all of this and they took a
stand
and that is an instance of what i call
real moral courage
in other words to do what is right even
if it means crossing your own friends
being intimidated being
accused of
treason of turning on their own people
betraying them and all of that and they
stood out in this throughout the whole
episode and that is
really i think the chief legacy that we
can look at that it can happen to anyone
and i i have to confess when i was
writing this book i kept asking myself
what would i have done in those
circumstances facing the fog of war
facing vengeance facing all of these
things at once what would i have done
and i i honestly don't know
howard jones professor of history
emeritus at the university of alabama in
tuscaloosa and author of milai
vietnam 1968 and the descent into
darkness thank you so much for joining
us
well i thank you i appreciate it so much
and now on c-span radio
seymour hirsch the journalist who
brought the story of the milai massacre
to the world on november 12 1969
he spoke at tulane university in new
orleans on december 2nd 1994
talking about the progression of the
story from a tip to tracking down and
interviewing one of the soldiers who
would be charged in the attack william
calley jr
this program first aired on c-span 3's
american history tv online at see hyphen
span dot org forward slash history let's
just go back to the fall of 1969
it's september late september washington
has wonderful falls
beautiful weather i'm in an office in
the national press building my next-door
neighbor is ralph nader i just had
written unsafe at any speed we're
workaholics working at night a lot of
times
um
and uh i'm a freelance writer let's see
by this time i had worked for the
associated press for three or four years
covering uh vietnam in effect i covered
the pentagon for the ap
and i did my reporting on on vietnam
from the pentagon i i think i basically
could say i learned
to hate the war in the sense that i got
to know military officers and i got to
hear him talk about what the war really
was about and i understood sort of
viscerally that by 1968 or 69 because of
the demands of washington for body
counts and for statistics and mcnamara's
idea of quantifying the war
by by the middle 60s you couldn't make a
colonel in the u.s army without being a
professional liar
and so
i didn't fault them but i understood it
i had
left the pentagon and the ap in 60 late
67 i worked because of the war i think
largely i worked as a press secretary
uh for senator eugene mccarthy when he
challenged lyndon johnson for the
nomination in 1968 the children's
crusade it was called anti-war basically
gene mccarthy was
from minnesota liberal democrat
and a wise man
understood the war
uh i wrote speeches for him and did
stuff and and went on and
i'm telling you all this because i was
sort of
i got to know the press as a press
secretary and
mccarthy did very well in the new
hampshire primary some of you might
remember he got over 40 percent of a
write-in vote and all of a sudden my
office is chartering american airline
jet planes and you know having 100 200
reporters every day with us so i got to
know the press
i published a book on chemical and
biological warfare my first book i think
it was excerpted in new york review
books i was sort of you know you're
i guess you could call me
a
left
liberal moderate liberal journalist
um
when i went to mccarthy a lot of my
friends in journalism said i would be
dead going into politics i'd never be
accepted as a straight reporter again
i was working on a second book in 69
in the
fall of 69 an article i wrote on
chemical and biological warfare had been
the lead article in the new york times i
think sometime in september 69 so i was
just
um a freelancer i was writing articles
um occasionally for newspapers four or
five or six papers at a time the
baltimore sun the philadelphia inquirer
i was maybe in 69 i probably made ten
thousand dollars or eight thousand
dollars which was in those days of 25
cents a gallon for automobile
uh was okay
um uh uh
i i i was
perfectly all right i get a call
in september
and somebody um says to me
a lawyer a public interest lawyer at
that time if you remember there were a
lot of guys trying to beat the draft and
there was a lot of
there were a lot of people inside the
military there were dissenters and
protesters themselves and there was a
lot of lead for a big need for lawyers
um to defend these guys at various bases
there were sit-ins there were protests
and he said to me
there's a great story
he said somebody's the army is holding a
gi at fort benning
in north carolina and says he's killed
75 people civilians
i don't know why partly i was doing a
book on pentagon cost overruns or
profiteering
which is sort of boring but um and
i read all the stuff on war crime
tribunals and you know the quakers had
put out a book
uh i knew enough from dealing with
people in the war
as a pentagon correspondent from dealing
with the officers
i knew
something just made me think this was
worth checking out
and so i started to check out and don't
forget this was the days in which nixon
um had told us he'd been elected been in
office about eight months he told us if
you remember he had a secret plan to end
the war
none of us knew then that his secret
plan was to win it you know by bombing
cambodia in secret doing all the stuff
you know tricking the cia and all this
stuff we didn't know that was a secret
plan we just thought he was going to
begin some sort of drawdown there was
some prospect for peace
we uh
we didn't understand henry kissinger
then very much we thought he was the
harvard man who was going to lead us to
uh out of the maze
so i started
i did what you normally would do i'd
also been in the army
i'd spent six months constricted and you
know for six months reservist and i was
a public information officer but i don't
mean office i was enlisted man but that
was my title i wrote press releases in
fort benning um can fort riley kansas
first the big red one division i wrote
little hometown releases and stuff like
for the army newspaper and did some you
know standard stuff that was about eight
years earlier but i knew how the army
operated
there's no way somebody's being
court-martialed without a record
somewhere you can't do it in secret so i
went to the i began looking
i went over to the pentagon
i went to the jag office the judge
advocate general's office went through
all the
the papers
uh the public filings read all the cases
that they brought and these were the
days in which there were a number of
crimes being committed by the troops and
being prosecuted in crimes on various
bases and i read all the murder cases
nothing about civilians being killed in
great quantities in vietnam there were
rapes and murders et cetera you know
just one on one or two on two two gis
being accused um i went to the newspaper
clips didn't see anything about it i
asked a few people sort of discreetly i
wasn't going around if this was true
and the army was the the gist of my
message was that the army wasn't anxious
to have it out this was a tip of a hot
story that nobody had
and i was sort of stuck journalist and
author seymour hirsch at tulane
university december 2nd 1994. i don't
remember everything i did but i mulled
it around this we're talking about you
know i'm doing other things i i was
working on my book doing i had a
i guess you'd call it a full plate
and so
um
i didn't let it go
and i called back after about a week the
initial source who
i have to tell you
is now
not quite a cabinet level official in
the current government but very close he
runs a large agency
in the uh in the clinton administration
um it's sort of interesting i called him
back he's a public interest lawyer and i
figured
he had been in some court proceedings
somewhere a sealed court proceeding and
there'd been some mention of it i didn't
know
and i said look i'm stuck i can't get
anywhere there's no no case that looks
like this
and you know he said i'm telling you
it's real i said i need to know
something he said well i don't know how
i can help you i said you've got to get
me something more
and it's you know it's sort of hokey
uh but in about two days he called back
and he said yeah a lawyer name he's got
a i don't know the guy's name but
there's a lawyer involved named latimer
and so i started looking around for
latimers
and it turned out there was a former
retired judge named george w latimer
on the court of military appeals
and
judge latimer
had
had let's say he retired a couple years
earlier i thought he was my man
because i went i looked up all in
whatever the legal uh directories there
are and i i checked around and this must
be made sense he represented other
people in military cases and he was
since he was a retired judge in the
court of military appeals
always think of robert cheryl's great
line
military justice is the justices
military music is the music but anyway
um anyway he was a man of some probity
and so i i worked back from
latimer and son of a gun
i found that he was representing
somebody named callie
in a case
i went back from there and i found a
clip
in the september 18th i think give or
take a day
way
in the middle of september
a month earlier by now i'm into october
i found the clip in the
in the new york times on a saturday
buried literally two paragraphs maybe
even less one paragraph
small i found a clip that said
uh a man named william l kelly a second
little first lieutenant was being held
in connection with an unspecified number
of murders or charges unspecified
charges at uh
at not at fort bragg but at fort benning
uh in georgia
uh
right next to jackson
is it a columbus georgia rather
and
so i checked the record out on this guy
called a friend at the mine he was out
of miami it said and i called the miami
newspapers and there was a clip on him
uh cali when he
let's see kelly was then about 22 and
somewhere in the middle 60s when he was
19 he made the newspapers because he'd
been hired by the florida and i think
east coast railroad as a night switchman
and he had screwed up and forgotten to
throw a switch and two trains that
crashed two freight trains and he made
the newspapers that was the only clip on
the guy and i called around i think i
even called his old his family residence
i got nothing out of that
and
i
got on a plane
went down to georgia
went to the base
walked into the uh
the office where cali was all right
and i i went down there once and i i
again without fully
revealing everything i went and i looked
at the record and i was assured
that i was told
by a colonel
very pointedly that
there's nothing here with cali
because
he had shot up a gin mill what he'd done
is gone and gone crazy and shot up a
bunch of prostitutes in a vietnamese bar
in saigon or outside saigon and that was
and i
by the way the fella wasn't lying the
officer i'm sure he told me what he'd
been told so that was sort of
discouraging i went back
and
i wasn't going around saying i'm
investigating a mass murder but i was
sort of down in the dumps about that
and then i'm in the pentagon i'm back to
my book and i'm in the pentagon let me
tell you something about military guys
that i learned very quickly
they were not the enemy of the vietnam
war they were as much victims
as as the people they were you know
directing and killing in effect the real
villains of course were the civilians
who set these you know from the johnson
and kennedy administrations who
initiated this war
and so i i figured that out i never i
always thought there was a lot of
integrity and one thing about military
guys i learned as a pentagon reporter
um if you
if if you deal with them straight uh
they'll deal with you straight they
don't care whether i'm left or right all
i want to know is that i'm going to be
straight if it's off the record it's off
the record if i say i'm not going to
write about this i and i don't you know
if i don't break the rules they'll deal
with me they don't care what i think
they just want somebody to be straight
so they're i'm in the pentagon
back at work on my book and the an
officer i knew from my earlier stint in
67 66 with the ap had gone to vietnam
as a colonel and got wounded badly and
had been promoted to general with the
call being frocked for a star and i
happened to bump into him in the hall
oh within a few days of uh
being very discouraged about the cali
case and we were walking along i was
chiding him
kidding him about making general i'm
going to get to go to a charm school
there's a little school you have to go
when you're a general
and
and then i said what's this about
cali
and i'll never forget it he stopped he
had a bet he was working for
westmoreland the army chief of staff he
was working for the chief of staff's
office
and clearly he was in the middle of all
this at the time because unbeknownst to
me there was behind the scenes this
incredible drama being played as the
army was investigating and tearing out
his hair about what to do
and sitting on it anyway he stopped and
i'll he went like this he jammed his
hand against his knee and he said sigh
he said
that boy callie he didn't shoot anybody
higher than that
and
wow i mean that's pretty powerful
needless to say i didn't say you know
sir you've just given me the best story
i've ever had
you don't do that but i just i guess i
played it cool and i was stunned and i i
it's there it is there and cali is it
from 1994 journalist and author seymour
hirsch as we note the anniversary of the
milai massacre so i went over to
to the one people you'd be surprised
maybe but i went to the right wingers at
that time the chairman of the house
armed services committee was mendell
rivers
who was sort of a dipsomaniac a good old
alki
and you know there is you know there
were helic there were um
you know air bases and
and navy aircraft carriers named for him
and bases galore he's one of these old
style politicians
but if
anybody there's just no way i figured
the army was not going to tell people
like mendel rivers about this they
weren't going to let it no matter how
much they wanted to be secret about it
they had to tell the rivers they had to
protect themselves with him
because he really thought
you know i grew up when i grew up in
chicago
i i during world war ii we lived in 47th
street across the street was the victory
theater
and my sisters my older sisters would
take me
on saturday afternoon to watch the world
war two movies and what i remember
growing up
is that every saturday uh
robert robert ryan and van johnson
uh would would fly around and they would
be in competition the two guys to some
nurse but they'd also be flying against
the japs we call them the nips then and
the movies always have a scene where
they were both competing for the same
nurse but there they are
uh flying against each other and um
uh in in air war against the japs the
nips and the the the america the
japanese guy pilots always had their
their the their their fighter planes the
zeros always had the the coptic clothes
and they had these hats tied tight and
they had a grimace the americans always
had canopies open and had escot and
scarves and went around going like this
and they were always saving the other
guy they were always coming
on the other guy's tail and saying look
out he's on your tail last second van
johnson had been competing for the girl
would say robert ryan
and then you'd see the scene where the
the guy the japanese guy the pilot would
all of a sudden there'd be a lot of
bullets he's ready to kill van johnson
and then robert ryan would shoot and
bullets would pour into the cockpit and
then there'd be a
moment of silence and then the plane
would bank down and you'd hear the wine
and a trickle of blood would come out of
the corner of his lips and he'd go into
the water and we'd all cheer and so here
am i
it's 1969
and i'm saying hey
you know what
we're in the chaps
we're the nips
we're those guys
that did this stuff we us me americans
are doing the stuff i
watched
and so
believe me i understood what i was doing
this was not going to be
fun
because
i was looking at it
yeah part of me said fame fortune glory
the other part was very pragmatic about
how are you going to prove this you know
what are you going to do you know
americans do not want to hear
that we fought our wars
like the nazis and and the nips did
that's just not the way that's not the
way where it's shaped up to be so anyway
i go to see
a mental river's guy a guy named doesn't
matter armed services committee and i
see a senior staff guy
and washington b and washington you know
you know i worked in the ap and i
covered issues and of pentagon
and i take him for a walk and i say
what's this about cali and he said oh
jesus isn't it terrible and i say yeah
i'm flying blind
and he says i can't talk about it the
old man's gone absolute fatty about it
he said
and
big hush-hush stuff he said psy
you've got to do something you've got to
tell me you're not going to write about
it it'll destroy the army
right so i don't know what i did i i
sure i may have said i probably did oh i
won't write about it i don't know what i
said i certainly wasn't totally
forthcoming and said i assure you i'm
going out of here so i had something
i now have two guys tell me there's
something bad i'm still very much in the
dark i don't know exactly what it is but
it's bad
and i then go back and i call
latimer
i look up george w latimer
and he lives in salt lake city he
practices there he's a partner in a firm
he's a mormon elder i do
the necessary work
and i call him and i say to him that i'm
real casual
and i say i'm flying to california the
next day and my plane stops at salt lake
and i've got some time do you mind if i
come by and talk to you about this cali
thing
and he says well
i said just take a few minutes he said
it's a horrible it's you know they
shouldn't be doing this and i said sir i
agree with you whatever i said so we
made a date so i i buy a ticket i have
to get money i think at that time i i
had i just got an american express card
i keep on thinking those ads do you know
this man he broke the massacre with the
american express card you know they
never asked me to do it
but
i didn't have much cash but i had a card
i got and so i bought some tickets
and i went that afternoon to the
military court of justice the library
and i pulled out the last five or six of
his decisions
and i read him
going out to uh salt lake city
uh
i'm not you know it was shrewd i'm not
overly as i think about it was pretty
swarmy but that's what we do for a
living you know and and i go out there
and and i knock on his door
i get in there and it's a very
unpretentious office and i sit down he's
a partner in this firm
and i say sir tell me what your
reasoning was in the such and such case
and what about such and such and after
about 20 minutes he thinks i'm just the
nicest boy he's ever met
which is you know again what we do in
our living that's my that's my business
you know as i say
uh
it's not my job to warn him that i'm
really here doing something else but um
i don't know if i'd do it today i don't
know if it'd be quite as slippery but
anyway
we talked about those cases and then
mostly by the way cases in which some
guy raped 42 people and it's all
and basically the issue always was that
they couldn't find the body so no habeas
corpus and they reduced the sentences
like crazy since they really couldn't
find a body after some guy mutilated a
woman and buried her somewhere found
guilty and even though they had evidence
that you know they always were what they
did in the military court of appeals
seemed to reduce all the cases every
capital crime that came up they reduced
it to you know six months or three
months anyway
that was a separate issue
and then i said sort of just very
dramatically
i said
i just for some reason i i just doubled
the number
i i had been told 75 i said i hear it's
150. i heard they killed they claimed he
held 100 the army says he killed 150
people and the judge got mad
again
i don't commend this it's journalism 101
you know that misrepresent a fact but
that's what i did anyway seymour hirsch
broke the story of milai in november
1969. this talk took place at tulane
university in
1994. getting that story was important
fame fortune glory and also was
important uh for other reasons you know
i didn't like the war i thought this had
something to do with it but i don't
forget you know if you'd asked me what
would happen i would have said pulitzer
prize maybe you know give or take a
break um i i you know i was thinking big
i guess anyway i said 150 anyway for
whatever reason
and he got mad and he went to a file
cabinet
and pull out a file walk back to his
desk i'll never forget it and he opened
it up and he said here and he gave me a
charge sheet
which showed that one that william laws
callie jr was formally charged with the
unp premeditated murder of 111.
the word only jumps into my mind only
111 oriental human beings it's one of
the great lines of all time they meet
once i wrote about this and everybody
jumped on that word as if
ten oriental human beings equal one
caucasian
and maybe you know what 14 for one black
i don't quite know how the army measures
it but anyway oriental human beings and
it was only 111 was his point you know
how can they possibly say it's 150. it's
an amazing sort of when you think about
it
and he he gave it to me and you know i
go eureka
111 one guy i mean i again and he takes
it he puts it back
and
i i have a lot of fun i i give a lot of
talks at journalism school and often
i'll take this as an example how far
would you go if he left the office would
you what would you do i find to a man
all that you know no matter how much you
warn him about ethics everybody says
take it take it but anyway the fact is
none of that happened
i even do a thing where i i say puts it
back in the drawer and they say take it
take it anyway you know go in there and
students in journalism school so so much
for
whatever the ethics of today are the
stories are pretty important anyway
um
what happened is he and i talked and for
the next 10 minutes i managed to have a
conversation with this guy while
i'm too old to do it now my brain's too
adult while copying word for word the
first maybe 30 lines of that page upside
down so i was copying word for word i
was reading it upside down he got in his
desk you know squinting a little bit
looking while he yeah some con i have no
idea what i said why he didn't say are
you writing down this i affected writing
notes so i basically had
i didn't have the document
but i had evidence that callie had been
charged
um
and then i left and i said where is he
he said i can't tell you i said i've got
to find him he said well i'm not going
to help you and he'd been charged at
fort benning i said is his little fort
benning he said i can't tell you so i go
back and i think i've got a great story
and by this time i told you i've been a
press secretary i'd written
a
book i had a contract for another one
random house i was
i certainly knew every reporter i'd
worked for the ap for four years and
broken a lot of good stories there i was
certainly
considered to be a competent good guy
i was uh
in the summer of 63 i must have written
five or six pieces that i sold to seven
or eight different newspapers that a lot
of them were page one baltimore sun as i
said major papers washington post
uh freelanced
and i started to see if i could sell a
story and my life magazine had been
talking to me about doing a piece for
them
which was then hot stuff in the late 60s
a dollar a word
and they wanted me to do a long take out
on something and i called my edit the
editor with whom i've been discussing
the piece and said i've got a hell of a
story told him what i did he was all
excited
and
and he said i said i've got to find
callie and i he said look you keep on
working let me talk to my editors i'll
get back to you two days later he calls
me
and he said we can't do it
i said you've got to be kidding
unbeknownst to me
and
which is amazing given ron reidenhauer
who out of here
um
had already
done his work had already filed his
protest had started the whole process
by the same time the fall of 69 he was
disillusioned with the army he thought
there was there was going to be a
cover-up they weren't only talking about
charging a lieutenant he thought it went
much higher than that he began to talk
to the press
and he had gone to life magazine much
earlier with the story and in fact if i
recall
he and i even had talked to the same
editor
uh he talking four months earlier and me
four months later i didn't find out
about i didn't know ron right on left i
wrote my first story even though he
existed i didn't know that his track was
totally separate from mine we quickly
met together and he helped me enormously
but at this point he's doing his own
thing so the editor at life that i was
dealing with the reason he was initially
so enthusiastic which he did not tell me
is he'd already been approached by ryden
hour and probably had seen the letter
right now wrote that all of you know
about which triggered everything
and uh he said no i went to look which
had also asked me to write and look said
no
i found it almost impossible to believe
i went to the new york times editor and
he thought that was out of the question
i didn't as i told you i'd had the lead
piece in the new york times magazine a
cover piece a couple weeks
earlier in early september 69
i went to some newspaper people and i
was really horrified nobody wanted to
touch it
it's pretty amazing was 69 was 69
and robert ryan was robert ryan and van
johnson was van johnson and nobody
wanted to be the first to say
what that story said journalist and
author seymour hirsch at tulane
university in new orleans december 2nd
1994. so i was sort of stuck
i had a neighbor kid i played pickup
basketball named david obst
and david ran a news agency dispatch
news service which was an anti-war news
service that produced some high quality
stuff they had some very good people a
guy named michael morrow in vietnam and
david was sort of their agent and david
had i've been writing stuff for the new
republic and david had convinced me i
would write a piece and sell it to the
new republic for 300 and he'd convinced
me early in the spring of 69 to let him
syndicate the piece and he'd make me a
lot more money which he did he was
selling him to the newspapers for me we
were splitting the profits and i was
making more money
and so david kept on saying i could do
it
and um i even remember
um i told you i'd sold stuff to the new
york review books which was the very
avant-garde and i have stone who was
everybody's hero the famous journalist
i went to and izzy told me
that
i should do it for bob silvers at the
new york review
and i called him up and he he was
appropriately dying to do it wanted to
do it right away
and he was going to remake the front
page of his and start the story on page
one and he i sent him my stuff
the first story i drafted
and i'll never forget he called me back
and he said it's fine but give me about
two or three hundred words on why this
is bad my story was just about cali and
what he did i said what do you mean he
said let's just tell the reader why this
is bad and it was so loony you know you
got a story about a guy that commits
mass murder and so i couldn't do it
there i just didn't do it or me as
entity forever but i said no i'm not
gonna let you do it and meanwhile
um i just decided i just had to go get
callie if i could get cali to talk maybe
people would do it so i didn't know
where he was but i thought he was in
fort benning georgia
so i got on a plane southern airways
then i flew down went to fort benning i
never forgot i got there early in the
morning
and i rented a car
and
i get to the base it's an open base even
though we're in wartime fort benning's a
great big huge base with it was a basic
training base it was an uh airborne
ranger base it was special they were
special forces i even think had some
training there they had a main camp and
about four or five
uh satellite camps each about 15 20
miles away so i get there and i don't
know where i go to the phone book and
he's not there obviously and i'm just
thinking it's seven o'clock on why i
figured hell he's in jail i know he's in
jail he's being you know i don't know it
but the judge told me
he was
he was going to be held for a court
martial they decided to do it so i go to
the i just get in the car and i have my
little suit on and a briefcase and i
drive to the post stockade the army the
army jail the first one and i park in
the commanding officers spot it's early
in the morning i walk in there and i
slam the door sergeant get me bill
callie what
and
no cali so i get in the car and i drive
15 miles to the next base and i go to
two or three of these barracks walk in
the same bed park in the most senior
offices spots slam the door loud i'm a
lawyer
that's what i'm trying to be
if anybody asked me i would have said no
but i with the certitude of a lawyer i
say sergeant get me you know there's
always a sergeant or a specialist for
spec four
and uh he's not anywhere
so that's disappointing i then do the
whole normal bit that you do
um clubs i work clubs i basically can
find anybody unlisted in america uh
because everybody does something
particularly people you're looking for
who are prominent let's say they're
always in some club golf you know tennis
a little league you can find anybody
that way and um it's not hard um and so
i just start going you don't need it's
not a trick it's just you know you just
figure it out you know
find out where they live and call gas
stations they'll tell you who services
the car where the credit card anyway
it's not that hard so i do all the clubs
i go through every damn club in the base
i go to every um
boq bachelor's office's quarters you
know for and for the uh
he's a
a second lieutenant or first lieutenant
and i just do all the things that you're
supposed to do and i'm really stuck it's
not going anywhere
and time's going by i'm looking and
looking
i i've flown half the night to get there
i wanted a guy i took an early morning
flight at four suddenly i got there i
remember seven in the morning
anyway um
and i i know in order to make it work i
gotta find him at one point i decide to
flush myself a little bit and i go into
the judge advocate general's office
which is the chief law office and
there's a colonel there and i walk in
and i still don't know if callie's here
i don't i'm not sure i'm beginning to
lose faith
and i go up to the it's a warrant
officer a senior warrant officer sort of
a cross between an enlisted man in an
officer he's guarding the
he's the only man on duty there and i go
up and i introduce myself and i'm
careful to say i'm a reporter i say i'm
looking for bill calley william kelly
and he just twangs
and he says uh excuse me yes sir would
you mind waiting a second and i said
yeah i'd mind waiting a second where is
he he said sir i'm on under orders to
call the colonel
and i said uh-huh and as soon as he
turned his back a second i dashed out of
there and he started to chase me he said
sir you've got to stay and i just ran
out of there and i'm stuck now
and i run i get in the car and i drive
you know to a px and a
hamburger place it's now lunch time
and so here we are
cali's being charged he doesn't show up
anywhere in any registry any club any
officer's quarters he's not in he's not
being held he's not listed in the phone
phone book and i'm thinking about it
thinking about it i'm really i'm eating
my hamburger
drinking my coke and i'm stuck
and then i remembered something vladimir
told me
lattera told me that kelly had come back
in august
of 69 from vietnam and they began
processing him in september and i
remembered something my pentagon days
which is the military has quarterly
phone books every three months they put
out a new phone book and they're very
thorough about it on all bases and at
the pentagon too
of new listings and old listings had
dawned on me if he came back in august
he wasn't charged until early september
or now october
why he might have come back he would
have gone through regular processing
they had no reason not to process them
nobody found any charges just coming
back in rotation even the army wanted
them back he had to go into some pool
so i got on the phone i got the base
operator
we're talking about georgia
um i got the local military base
operator and i said this is a tough one
operator i want you to go
to the last i want you to go to the june
phone book not the september one i want
you to go to the last entry for new
listings in june took me a long time to
get it straight i want the last new
listings for the june book in other
words you you have a june book in your
every month or two every week or two
you're updating it she said yeah get me
the last one for july of august late
august and after a long time she's
pretty friendly i must say and she finds
she finds that i've got it i said see if
you have a cali william j
and she says yeah
there's a cali william j i said where is
he and then she said it's wonderful i'll
never forget it she said blah blah blah
and hung up
she gave me the number but she said it
was a she gave me the abbreviation in a
southern accent and i could not
understand what she said
so
by now i'm really spacey you know one
eye looking for this warrant officer
i get her back i don't remember how i
did it i call back i'm pretty calm you
know because
you can't
by shrieking which is what i wanted to
do so i get her and she get back and she
finds it again and she spells it out
he's in a
engineering battalion he's in a he's in
a battalion headquarters that's an uh
an engineering company a battalion
headquarters for an engineering group
um in one of the other bases about 20
miles away
and that's where he's listed i said
great get in the car and i get
directions and i go like a bat out of
hell there i've got this rented ford
and i get to this it's a new it's new
army this is a concrete
um barracks
uh
it's a it's a combination barracks and
administrative office for an engineering
battalion
and kelly's not an engineer i think a
pretty smart place to hide him he's an
artillery or he's an infantry man but
he's in an
engineering
group and it's a
concrete three stories on each side and
in the center is an office
where the battalion commander
and his clerks exist you know do their
paperwork from 1994 journalist and
author seymour hirsch as we note the
anniversary of the march 1968 milai
massacre by u.s troops in vietnam and so
i parked my car a couple hundred yards
away and i walk into his side door
and um
i
go through one floor and i go up and
down one side
and it's it's double double bunks all
need all spit shine you know just like i
used to when i was in the army we i
could
do a bed like nobody else when you tuck
those corners in everything's pretty
it's pretty spiffy outfit i go through
three floors nothing there i go down to
the first floor it's the only way to get
from one side to the other and it's one
of those offices that have uh half doors
that divide in half and the top half was
open and the bottom half was closed
you know it's got one of those swinging
the i don't know what you call it but
anyway you know what i'm talking about
and i actually i hear people inside i
actually crawl
underneath where it's closed to get to
the other side where there's more wings
on the other half so i crawl underneath
i don't know why i just didn't walk
around i guess it was too lazy so i
crawl underneath and i get to the other
side and i start on the second floor
sure enough in a bunk high up in the top
bunk in the corner somebody's sleeping
and i go and i kick the bed
kick i reach up kick real high
okay get up cali some kid gets up
i remember strikingly blonde queen
and i don't remember his name
but he was from ottumwa iowa and some
blonde kid the name is in cali and i
said yo what are you doing here and i
was you know i'm crushed
um because you know i'm running out of
space he's not you know
what am i going to do
and
he says
and
the the being in the army i guess or
just being noticed i said kid tell me
what are you doing here at two o'clock
in the afternoon on a beautiful day and
i get this long story he's from otomo
iowa it's farm season harvest in iowa
and the army's lost his records
he's a six-monther his dude had been due
to been rotated a month earlier out but
they've lost his records and he screwed
up and they stuck him in this battalion
for a month i said no jesus a terrible
story commiserated about it
and i said so what are you doing he said
well i'm the mail clerk
mail clerk
and i said
well i said did you ever hear of a guy
get any mail for a guy named callie
william kelly
he says oh you mean the guy that shot up
everybody
and i said yeah he said yeah i used to
get his mail when i first started
working i used to sort his mail and i'd
keep it and somebody pick it up and then
they told me all that males goes to
brigade
uh goes to he's a he's a brigade he goes
to battalion goes to the next higher
level he has to go battalion
headquarters i said what explain it to
me he said well i stopped seeing his
mail about three four weeks ago which is
when cali probably was charged and now
all the mail i don't even see it but it
goes directly
it goes to the next headquarters the
brigade headquarters smitty handles it
i said where's smitty
he said well i don't think somebody will
talk to you just got busted he was a
three striper and he just got busted
last week he's really mad i said well
what do you think he said i don't think
he'll talk to you i said will you help
me get there he said no way
i said i'll tell you what i said
whatever the kid's name it's a kid that
has had no action i said what time you
got he said whatever he said 2 10. i
said in exactly nine minutes i'm going
to pull up to the side in a red ford
you be there jump in and take me there
he thought about it he said
okay if you promise to drive me back
it's a deal so i go out the side door i
don't have to crawl i'm going out the
back door get my car wait
2 19 or whatever the time was i pull up
he jumps in drives me it's about three
miles convoluted away i had it's really
funny to get back i had to draw me a map
but he shows me where it is
the brigade or battalion headquarters is
a one-story old wooden building
i drop them back and i come back i i and
the brigade is this one old is what i'm
used to the old one army one one-story
army wooden
office building
uh like a sort of a little larger than a
trailer and
there's a huge
big
almost cliche black sergeant
a huge gut leaning against the door he's
got the screen door open and he's
leaning against the door it's you know
almost quitting time and he's picking
his teeth or whatever he's doing just
sitting there
and
he's a mellow guy obviously and
i pull into the commanding officer's
spot again and i jump up and i say
sergeant get smitty out here on the
double and the sergeant starts laughing
he figures old smitty's done it again
you know he's been busted i don't know
what he thought
well here comes smitty out like this and
all nervous i said get in the car kid
i'm not much older than he is and he
he uh he gets in the car and i close the
door and i said cool and i'm a reporter
and i got no problem i said oh yeah i
said tell me how you got busted and i
get the long lament about this that
and then i said tell me about callie he
said there's nothing to tell he said he
lives off base
uh i don't know where he you know he
said
uh uh i got an address
uh no he said i got an address he lives
somewhere off base but you know i he
said that's it i said there's nothing
else you know he said no i got an
address where we send the mail
he said maybe he's there i don't know i
said nothing else
just his personnel file
i said smitty get it come on no way i
said come on put in your blouse come on
okay
gets out of the car
goes back in nazi the sergeant who's
laughing away at this scene he thinks
this guy's i'm he thinks i'm going to
take him away probably
comes back in frightening
close to the car unblossos the shirt
gives me the file first page is the same
charge sheet i'd seen in the lawyer's
office about 10 days earlier
so i copy everything i need a copy which
is you know quite a bit
i'm now feeling better i almost wanted
to rip it off but it would cause me too
much trouble he was afraid to xerox i
didn't think i needed it i thought at
this time the hell was it i'm smoking
he goes back i then it's now closed the
end of work the work day in fort benning
and uh which is very close as i say
adjacent to columbus the the base and
the city start right next to each other
kelly still lives there runs a jewelry
store there he married a woman whose
father owned it
and um
and so i go to the um i find that the uh
the house he lives in it's a rented
house you know it's sort of a nice area
suburban area what you will of
pretty close to the base it's a just on
a regular street and i'm following a car
ironically and it pulls into the same
driveway i'm going into so i pull behind
it and there's three young second
lieutenants turn out all just graduates
they turn out all the fresh graduates
out of west point the first big
assignment they graduate i guess in june
and this is their
you know their first big training
assignment before they get shipped off
to vietnam and get a ball in their back
or whatever happens to officers you know
not so good second lieutenants in
vietnam
and these are all articulated bright
guys and they invite me in we sit down
they give me a drink and at this point
i've been going steadily
you know for i i think i got up i think
i was on a five o'clock plane and
connected and i i had to go to
philadelphia to get a plane down to
anyway it was crazy what i'd done but i
was you know i've just been going
journalist seymour hirsch broke the
story of milai in november 1969.
this talk took place at tulane
university in 1994. they gave me a
scotch
and we sit down and i say where's cali
and they said well we can't tell you he
moved out he's moved out
i said okay so we start talking they
tell me their view how terrible it is
kelly's a great guy he was simply he
wasn't there was no murder involved he
was in a fire fight you know whatever
cali told them they told me
and
then finally after about an hour of this
i finally said guys look i'm not out
there i'm here to tell the truth if
that's the truth i promise you
[Music]
i think i was pretty straight about the
problem he was in there were different
opinions and finally one of them said
okay we'll tell you where he is
they've got him stashed in the senior
officer's quarters senior bachelor's
office of course quarters for generals
and colonels and i think lieutenant
colonels
at the last place probably you know it's
amazing being in the army the notion
that they let a lieutenant live there
these are you know just never of all the
places i wouldn't i would have never i
would have gone to a neonatal ward
before i went there
i mean it just never occurred to me very
smart so they tell me where it is it's
uh it's october lights beginning to fall
by five six o'clock i had maybe a couple
drinks so i drive there and it's it's
a bachelor's office quarters a big
parking lot and there's three concrete
buildings on surrounding the parking lot
there's you know a pool and tennis
courts it's a nice place i park on the
street on the outside
and i go into the first building
knock knock knock bill bill
hey bill and i just do this most of the
people aren't there a lot of them say
get out of here no bill a couple of
people open the door we're talking about
colonels and generals you know jesus you
know they don't want to be bothered some
of the quarters are pretty nice they're
all very nice some are small but some
are bigger
you know they have little sweets
um it's all um and um these are for men
without wives not families
um someone what they call tdy temporary
duty and
most of the people are reasonably
pleasant and say never heard of who what
what nobody so i go through the whole
place once i go through the other two
places once by now it's an hour and a
half
maybe i don't know
two floors
maybe uh 40 maybe 120 150 units and i'm
not gonna store with the same lilt bill
a lot of energy
and so i have a little notepad and i
i've gotten about 20 of them and i just
figure i'm just going to keep on
knocking i'm just going to knock and
knock until i get every one of these
doors he's here i know he is i don't
know which one they wouldn't tell me
which one but i didn't push him the kids
wouldn't tell me
so i go back to the car and sit a minute
and i go and i knock again
it's dark now and i do go through i
think i do a second runner i do part at
least one more building and then i'm
walking across the parking lot
oh i do another run and i'm really
discouraged i'm not getting anywhere
and
it's now 8 8 30 maybe even 9 o'clock
it's a couple hours of this crap or
knocking on doors and getting nowhere
and i'm going back to the car and i was
thinking i want to get to a motel yeah
i'm going to check in for two hours and
i'm going to start again at 11. get two
hours of sack and start started again at
11 11 30. i don't care if i drive
everybody nuts i'm going to get it
and
they're in the
in the parking lot some guy is working
on a car and he's got those oil cloths a
drop cloth and he's under the car and
another guy's with him and he's run
along like an extension cord from one of
the buildings
one of those
mechanics lights and he's working and i
think about it i don't wanna i said okay
i go over and i say hi looking for bill
bill who bill kelly
and the guy underneath the car says this
buddy it's okay jack let me talk to this
guy the guy leaves
and he says what do you want i said your
cali he said no i'm not kelly he said
what do you want i said look i told him
i'm a reporter kelly's in trouble he
looks at me
he said follow me
he wipes his hands off we go and
he doesn't say anything we sit down
he's a warrant officer senior warrant
officer
and he said he lives upstairs
and i said so
where is he he said he's on a speedboat
he's got a speedboat he goes be boating
all the time
i know that's what he was doing and
he'll be back late he gets back late
you know he's a little screwed up
and
he then says to me we talk and he tells
me what cali told him and then he says
to me he'd been in vietnam he says you
know and i know it didn't happen that
way he was unbelievable he sent me
christmas cards for 10 years
and i never pushed it for a lot of
reasons i didn't push these
relationships i felt exploited it enough
he sent me christmas cards for a long
time after that um he made his own
judgment about the war himself he
retired soon after this
and he said it's and we talked for hours
we talked about the war
you know it was really unbelievable
he'd seen a lot of bad stuff and he knew
what was going on and i was so naive i
mean i knew it was bad but
anyway
um
you know i came here
i was telling randy or before this
i came here in 71. i'll never forget to
speak of tulane and it was elaine was
then
the height of anti-war activity there
was a lot of stuff going on here
and there's a lot of division about it
and this campus was pretty out there
there were sit-ins i'm sure some of you
remember that a lot of protests and i
think the time's picky and it's my
memory i could be wrong ran an editorial
against my speaking out here and if i
remember they ran it in with a red
border i think for kami but i don't know
but it was very unfriendly and there was
a
when i got there they had they had to
move the format we were going to speak
someplace and then we moved it to
another place a bigger format because
there was a lot of and this is the days
of the vietnam war and and and uh and
vietnam veterans against the war and
there were a lot of vets there
huge crowd
and
i i remember getting out there and i
remember
i just i what i did was so bizarre and i
think about it
i said
um anybody here from who served in
vietnam 68 69 some hands anybody served
in the americal division that was the
division cali was out of and i named a
couple of
of uh helicopter units particularly one
unit i knew about anybody served in that
unit well come on up
i promise you don't have to do anything
and the guy shuffles up
and i said
okay
you were what would you do he said he
was a door gunner and you know this is
no lover of the vietnam war but you know
he was or you know he was just a grunt
who was a vietnam veteran against the
war i guess but he he wasn't looking for
any trouble
and i said
um
tell him what you did after a tough
mission he said what do you mean i said
well he had a tough mission he was the
right unit at the right time i knew i
was right you would go in a door gunner
and you'd go on a mission to be a lot of
combat and as usual americans were
getting blown away and you were going in
and
taking out wounded and taking out dead
and going under tremendous pressure
and learning the hate you know really
building up a tremendous hate for the
vietnamese because you were carrying you
were you know you were fearing these
people out
tell them what you did on the after
these missions how you got rid of that
anger he said i didn't do it maybe other
guys did it but i didn't do it i said
i'm not saying you did just tell him
what you did
well
he said we after you know medevacing
people we sometimes before going back to
our lz or his landing zone
we go maybe go hunt up some farmers and
chase them around well tell what you did
come on well
i didn't do it and i said just tell him
he said well you'd go and find him in a
field and we try and
fly over them and
turn the
chopper on so we can get him with the
blade in the head
and behead him
and
i said that happened didn't it there's a
name i don't remember the name for it
they had a name for it
yeah he said that happened we're noting
the anniversary of the march 1968 milai
massacre with a 1994 talk by the
journalist who broke the story seymour
hirsch and i said what did you do after
that well you go back i mean before you
went back oh yeah
well you didn't want to get in trouble
so we had a place outside the landing
zone we'd stop and clean it up
and i said yeah well who cleaned it up
wow you had some
some you know
gooks
hired some gooks to clean it up some
vietnamese it really was that bad
i remember that vividly i'll never
forget that i mean that's a level to
which this warrant officer was beginning
to introduce me
in any case it's now one o'clock i've
been there three or four hours more
scotch
i'm zonked and callie isn't back and we
go to the door and i remember there's a
single ball because he was on the first
floor a lot it was a single bulb and
outside the screen there were all the
flies buzzing around he's standing here
talking to me and i want to go and he's
having one more story
and finally i said look i got to go i'll
i'll check this guy in the morning he
said okay and i start walking away he
said hey hey
he said rusty's here i said i look i
don't want to meet any of your friends
he said no rusty rusty cali i didn't
know his nickname was rusty
and so
i come back and he says rusty this is
hersh
and he said yeah i figured you'd find me
sometime and i said what do you mean he
said my lawyer told me you were looking
for me
so he invites me in
we go upstairs or downstairs i don't
remember we sit down and he starts
and the thing that you know i've been so
ready to hate him you have to understand
how much i was ready to hate him one of
the terrible stories that came out of me
lie
was
the kids had told me
about how when they had them all in the
ditch
one of the things that they had done is
they i i heard this story right from the
get-go they had shot everybody in the
ditch and one of the kids
had
survived maybe 100 people in the ditch
they were spraying bullets and he
crawled out a two-year-old kid on all
the bodies after they were done with
that particular part of the ditch and
were off shooting other people and he
began to run scream hysterical and cali
said to paul medlo or one of the other
kids plug him and he wouldn't do it in
cali to show what a man he was took his
carbine officers had kirby and ran
ran up behind the kid and plugged him
shot him so i was ready to hate him
and here i'm seeing a guy five foot
three
about 120 pounds five four maybe five
five i don't know very slight
translucent skin you can see the blue
veins
and he just
again what can you say you know clearly
i mean what's he doing leading men
not trained not educated the guy that
you know ran the switch is wrong so we
go into the office and i'm you know i'm
reeling with trying to figure out what i
think
and he gives me a beer and he has a beer
and we talk and i'll never forget he's
telling me how cool it is how it was
really a fight it was really war and all
this stuff
and then he wants to take a shower his
girlfriend's getting off she's a nurse
at four o'clock in the morning she's
getting off and
i'm gonna come with him we're gonna pick
her up and we're gonna get a steak at
the px and a bottle of bourbon we're
gonna have dinner
with her
i mean she went nuts when she saw me but
that's another story she left him he
picked up another girlfriend but anyway
so he goes to take a shower and he left
the door open
and i watch him go and he and before
getting in the shower he throws up
and i see him throw up in his blood
he's got an ulcer this big
and he's he's throwing up pure blood
it's all red even though he had a beer
and i don't think he knows the door is
open and so i can see in there and
he comes out and we start talking and
eventually he breaks it down make a long
story short about 5 30 in the morning
after dinner he says call medina captain
medina was the captain who unbeknownst
to me i didn't even know who he was at
that time maybe i did was on the base
too secretly he gave me his number and
i'll never forget he said count he gave
the story away
he told me that
you know it was clear that great murders
have been committed but he was ordered
to do so he thought he said medina will
tell you and i woke up medina i told him
who i was and he was wild he said what
would you get this number how do you
know about this and i said captain
cali says he was under orders i never
gave any such order he's just an
unmitigated liar and callie's listening
i had the phone held and i hung it up
and after that he it's funny he knew he
was gone in a way
he later
said to me as we were leaving he wanted
me to go bowling six o'clock in the
morning
he wanted me to go bowling
and
you just want to let go of me and i
finally left
and i as tired as i was i went right to
the airport i called my friend david
started typing a story and and then made
a
um wrote a piece a story that the one
that i won all the prizes for that began
i just you know the story i wrote was
lieutenant william kelly jr is a mild
mannered 26 year old army first
lieutenant the army uh the pentagon says
he murdered 111 vietnamese civilians in
cold blood
anyway um and i just underwrote the
story i got to i know what i did is get
out of the way of the story
um
and
the the thing that's interesting is the
lawyer judge latimer was very angry at
cali for speaking to me and then did
something i think was really in his
client's best interest he said what can
i do for you
so that i called him and told him what
kelly said what can i do for you so you
won't do this if you run the interview
this way he said the trial's over
what can i do for you he said you have
no business he had no business talking
to you you really had no business
training he said i understand you do
what you do he had to urge him not to
talk to me journalist and author seymour
hirsch at tulane university in 1994. and
so we made a deal i disguised the quotes
that the direct quotes that would have
been very damaging for him he agreed to
hear the story i was going to file
and
to make corrections which he did you
know putting in dates and places he made
enough corrections of the the facts and
not so much corrections but additions no
it was 13 charges no was second to
convince the military i'm convinced that
you know if you were looking at that
paper and you had a full understanding
of all the paper you'd know that i was
dealing from something very solid and he
also agreed to talk to the editors of
newspapers
when they i would tell the editors to
call him we were going to go back to
newspapers he also agreed to tell him
that he had read the story and although
he disapproved of it he could in good
faith not say there was anything wrong
which is an amazing agreement and i mean
i lived it to my part i never wrote
about the incident never wrote about
cali judge latimer and i never talked
again but we made a uh we we made a pact
and the other thing we did is my friend
ops and i decided to give up
on the newspaper world and we syndicated
it ourselves we set up a corporation
known as dispatch
news service domestic we had there was
an international newspaper we set up a
new news service
and we
copyrighted the story in the name of the
my name and news service what we did is
we made it easier for newspapers we
didn't go to a newspaper and say here
you you're responsible for telling
everybody that
that we're no better than the nazis
and um
i'm exaggerating but that's basically
how it felt it felt pretty horrible
we moved one filter
an old friend of mine named mike
nussbaum who's a wonderful lawyer in
washington my been my lawyer for 30
years
michael agreed to read the story for
libel and made some changes and i think
even i don't know had his own
discussions with other people about it
and we told editors that here's the
story that you can call cali's lawyer
and you can call my lawyer who was then
michael was then a partner in a
firm there was no money involved in this
it was simply everybody was doing what
they wanted to do we offered it to
everybody the new york times for 100
bucks as much as the papers and billings
montana everybody the same price
and we sent it off by overhead express
telex
um
no there's no fedex then there's no
internet we just sent it by we sent it
by uh overhead cable to a 40 or 50
newspaper we called him up and said it's
coming and judge it on its merits and we
said here's who you can call
and i'll never forget i went to see ben
bradley who was the if some of you saw
all the president's men
ben was
i don't know if jason robarts has been
or ben as jason robarts but
i i went to see him a wonderful friend
of mine larry stern a washington
reporter arranged this and michael my
lawyer and i came in with this story and
ben convenient senior staff his senior
editors and we all went into ben's
little office i didn't know
i knew my reputation as a very good
editor this is before watergate this is
1969.
and
we have xerox copies of that first story
we give it to everybody
and ben starts reading it and it was
it really was one of those wonderful
larger-than-life moments after about
three minutes he takes his version of
the story and he flings it into the
lap of uh jack foisy i think it was the
foreign editor and he
says 500 reporters on the staff and i
can't get anything like it run it it
smells right
you know it was straight and then i
always thought jason roberts had nothing
on ben bradley he doesn't by the way
good instincts and the same instincts
you saw three years later with woodward
and bernstein because he went with them
too anyway
the long and short of it is
that
it was after that first story was
published 35 and this is the good side
of it for the american press 35 i think
are 36 newspapers right that story uh in
some cases the lead story philadelphia
chicago major boston made a banner
headlines the same day tuesday
and about two days after that story got
out there were wire stories about it
somebody named ron wright never called
me at home
one night at home and said hey
he said
you've got to come talk to me i'm the
guy who started it
and i got on a plane and went to
claremont he was then a student in
claremont i met ron
and
uh
you know
nobody could have been more generous or
more open he simply wanted this story
out and if i was going to do it he was
going to do everything he could to help
me and he
gave me the names of people in the
company and he got me going and i ended
up doing an odyssey for four weeks
i went to see people and the next story
i went to see somebody i drove all night
the next day to get to a place called
orem utah found a kid named terry that
that uh rana told me about
and knocked on his door in his little
shack a gas heated shack in orem utah
three o'clock in the morning i remember
snowy passes by then it was it there had
been it was maybe early november they've
been a big snow already in utah i guess
it was towards ski country there out of
salt lake city and i knocked i found it
was very hard to find his place only one
gas station opened in a host city
and his little brother came and answered
and i said is your big brother there i
want to speak to him and he came out in
his pajamas or his underwear and it was
an oil burner and i told him who i was
and he said
do you want me to tell you the same
thing i told the colonel
and i said yeah and his next line i'll
never forget it was it was a nazi type
thing he said and from there i went on
and um it was a
i didn't think back
uh i'll tell you um
um
the only irony thing is that when i
ended up writing a book about all this
which i did in eli for um my editor bob
loomis at random house is a wonderful
wonderful editor and a wonderful man we
all agreed that my role in this should
be no more than a page or two and it
just shows you how far we've come i
think it's because of television and the
advent of you know watergate and all
that stuff
um if we had to do that story even 1975
what i'd done would be the story and the
other things wouldn't be it's sort of
weird how things were and those days
it you know get the process of getting
the story was so much less important
anyway i think i've talked much too long
it is a fun story
um
and uh you know here i was and i was an
outsider
and
the system worked in a funny way
um i i think we should just dispense
with questions
unless anybody has a compelling need
because of uh
if somebody has a compelling need compel
otherwise good night bye-bye
from december 2nd 1994
journalist and author seymour hirsch at
tulane university in new orleans on how
he broke the story of the march 16 1968
massacre at milai in vietnam
you can find this american history tv
program online at see hyphenspan.org
forward slash history
and you can listen to all of our
programs with the free c-span radio app
online at cspan.org and on your smart
speaker just say play c-span radio
and we appreciate your comments and
following us on twitter at c-span radio
we're your source for history and
current events unfiltered